AT TODAY'S THE ASSEMBLY BUDGET
SUB COMMITTEE ON EDUCATION
FINANCE SUBCOMMITTEE NUMBER TWO
BUT TODAY IS OUR EARLY
EDUCATION DAY- ALWAYS IMPORTANT
YEARLY HEARING TALKING BROTHER
OUR YOUNGEST LEARNERS- WE HAD A
HEARING LAST WEEK WE HAD TO
POSTPONE THE ANOTHER IMPORTANT
TOPIC- GETTING OUR PUBLIC
SCHOOLS ARE REOPENING
CALIFORNIA BUT RIGHT HAND IN
HAND WITH WITH THAT IS FOCUSING
ON OUR- GETTING OUR- EARLY
LEARNING PROGRAMS ARE CHILD
CARE AND PRE K. PROGRAMS- BACK
AT AT THE END DRIVING AND MAKE
SURE WE- SUPPORT THEM THE BEST
WE CAN HERE IN CALIFORNIA SO
THAT'S THE- THAT'S THE CRUX OF
TODAY'S HEARING- WE WILL HAVE
AS USUAL LIKE SOCIALLY. DISTANT
PHYSICALLY DISTANCE HEARING
LIMITED SEATING LIMITED
OPPORTUNITY FOR PUBLIC COMMENT
IN THE HEARING BUT THERE WILL
BE CHANCES TO PARTICIPATE- ON
THE TOLL FREE NUMER LATER IN
THE HEARING. TODAY WE WILL
FOCUS ON OF COURSE- WILL BEEN
FOLKS DOING WITH THE STATE AND
FEDERAL BUDGET RELATED TO
RELIEF TO OUR CHILD CARE
NETWORK IN CALIFORNIA. OF
COURSE YOU HAD- THREE SEGMENTS
OF A FEDERAL ARE THAT DOLLARS
COMING IN AS WELL AS THE STATE
BUDGET THAT WE'RE LOOKING AT
THIS YEAR- AS WE KNOW TO THE
GOVERNOR TO FINISH HIS MASTER
PLAN EARLY EDUCATION IN
DECEMBER WILL HAVE A CHANCE TO
TAKE A LOOK AT THAT AND- REALLY
ASK THE- THE IMPORTANT
QUESTIONS HOW DO WE SUPPORT.
AND STABILIZE OUR EASY CHILD
CARE SYSTEM IN CALIFORNIA HOW
DO WE SUPPORT THE SENSOR
WORKERS AND WHAT'S NEEDED TO BE
DONE NOW TO BUILD UPON OUR EASY.
SYSTEM FOR CALIFORNIA. SO WITH
THAT. WE WILL BEGIN WE HAVE AN
OPENING COMMENTS I WILL NOTE
THAT MY FELLOW CA AND COMMITTEE
MEMBER WHO'S ALWAYS HERE ON
TIME AND ALWAYS STAYS TILL THE
END- WHEN SHE STARTED SHE
TALKED ABOUT HER EXPERIENCE IN
EARLY EDUCATION YOUR PASSION SO
YEAH LETS YOU SEE IF YOU WERE
IS THE BEGINNING AS WELL. YEAH
I AM THANK YOU CHAIRMAN I
APPRECIATE THAT- EARLY
CHILDHOOD EDUCATION- IS A VERY
IMPORTANT TO ME I HAVE A FOUR
YEAR OLD DAUGHTER- AND
CALIFORNIA GIVING ACCESS TO OUR
THREE AND FOUR YEAR OLDS TO A
QUALITY LEARNING EXPERIENCES
VITAL ON MY SEAT IN MY OWN
DAUGHTER BUT I'VE ALSO SEEN AND
MY WORK AS A CHILD CARE
PROVIDER AND AN ADVOCATE FOR
EARLY CHILDHOOD EDUCATION. I'M
EXCITED THAT THE GOVERNOR THAT
THE STATE IS TAKING SERIOUS
ACTION AROUND DEVELOPING A PLAN
TO EDUCATE OUR LITTLEST
LEARNERS AS I LIKE TO CALL
THEM- AND REALLY SAID ABOUT THE
CONVERSATION AND ABOUT THE
PERSPECTIVE YOU KNOW MY
PERSPECTIVE COMES FROM NOT OF A
NONPROFIT- PRESCHOOL AND
CHILDCARE PROVIDER AND THIS IS
A MIX DELIVERY SYSTEM ARE EASY
COMMUNITY AND IT'S IMPORTANT
THAT. WE'RE LOOKING AT ALL ALL
ANGLES AND SUPPORTING THE
SYSTEM AS IT IS WHILE
EXPANDING- FOR OUR CHILDREN
THANK YOU AND I KNOW THAT
YOU'LL BE A GREAT ADDITION NOT
JUST BECAUSE YOUR PASSION BUT
YOU KNOW THESE ISSUES FIRST
HAND HAVING A STATE CONTRACT
FOR THE CALIFORNIA STATE
PRESCHOOL PROGRAM AS A WITH
THAT WE WILL BEGIN NOW WITH
ISSUE NUMBER ONE. WHICH IS- AN
OPPORTUNIST CAST THE GOVERNOR'S
CALIFORNIA MASTER PLANNED FOR
EARLY LEARNING AND CARE WE HAVE
A CHRIS PERRY WITH THE
CALIFORNIA HEALTH AND HUMAN
SERVICES AGENCY TO NOW QUEBEC
WITH WEST AT WHO HELPED CRAFT
THE REPORT AND. SARAH CORTEZ
WITH THE L. A. L. I BELIEVE
WE'RE GOING TO. WITH CHRIS. AT
CORRECT. THANK YOU CHAIRMAN AND
SUBCOMMITTEE MEMBERS FOR HAVING
US HERE TODAY TO PRESENT THE
HIGH LEVEL OVERVIEW THE MASTER
PLANNED FOR EARLY LEARNING AND
CARE. THE MANDATE FOR THE
MASTER PLAN WAS TO BUILD ON THE
ASSEMBLY BLUE RIBBON
COMMISSION'S RECOMMENDATIONS
AND THE VARIOUS OTHER STATE
CHILD CARE POLICY ASSETS TO
CREATE A CLEAR AND ACTIONABLE
ROADMAP FOR THE STATE'S EARLY
CARE AND LEARNING SYSTEM AND
YOU KNOW SHORTLY AFTER THE
LAUNCH OF THE MASTER PLAN FOR
EARLY LEARNING AND CARE EFFORT
THAT KOBE NINETEEN AND THERE
MIGHT BE YEAH. AND WE'VE ALL
SEEN THE TREMENDOUS RESILIENCE
OF PARENTS AND CHILDREN
PROVIDERS AS WELL AS THE
INCREASED FRAGILITY OF THE
EARLY LEARNING CARE SYSTEM SO
AS WE WORK TO BRING THE ACTIONS
DESCRIBED IN THE MASTER PLAN
INTO REALITY I LIKE TO START BY
SHARING THE VISION OF-
SECRETARY. DOLLY WHO- REALLY
ONE US TO NOT ONLY MEET THE
FOUR KEY OBJECTIVES OF THE
MASTER PLAN SUCH AS IMPROVING
LIFE OUTCOMES AND MAKING CARE
OPTIONS MORE EASILY ACCESSIBLE
AND PROMOTING SCHOOL READINESS.
AND SUPPORTING THE WORK FORCE
THAT HE ALWAYS HE ALSO HOPE
THAT WE WOULD BRING THOSE KEY
PILLARS TOGETHER AND CREATE AN
ADDITIONAL FOCUS ON CREATING A
COMPREHENSIVE EARLY LEARNING
SYSTEM THAT. COULD BRING BIG
ECONOMIC RETURNS AS WELL AS-
SOCIAL OR HELP IN EDUCATION
RETURNS TO ITS STATE. AND WITH
THAT I'LL TURN IT OVER TO YOU
KNOW WHO WOULD HAVE TO WALK.
YOU THROUGH THE SPECIFICS OF
THE PLAN. THANKS CHRIS WE HAVE
SOME SLIDES AND I'M GOING TO
START SHARING RIGHT NOW. IN ITS
SECOND HERE- AND REALLY
APPRECIATE YOUR TIME TODAY ON
THIS TOPIC- YOU CAN SEE THAT
NOW BRIAN IS CHRIS SAID YOU
KNOW THIS IS BEEN- QUITE
UNDERTAKING AND ONE THAT WE
HAVE A SIGNIFICANT AMOUNT OF
SUPPORT FROM. SECRETARY DOLLY-
HIS TEAM HAD TO HELP HIM IN
SERVICES- AND WHATEVER CREATED
THE GUIDANCE AND SUPPORT THAT
CHRIS HAS PROVIDED US DROUGHT
DOES WORK- YOU HAVING YOUR-
MATERIALS FOR TODAY- ALREADY ON
THE AGENDA- AND NOW LINE OF YOU
KNOW REALLY WHAT IT'S ALL ABOUT
AND ULTIMATELY IT'S ABOUT
GETTING CALIFORNIA TOOK PLACE
WHERE- WE ARE DELIVERING ON THE
PROMISE OF THE CALIFORNIA FOR
ALL KIDS OF MANY OF THE
OBJECTIVES OUTLINED IN. THE
ASSEMBLY WILL BRING COMMISSION-
WERE WERE CALLED OUT AND
AMPLIFIED ORGANIZE YOUR SUPPORT
IN CREATING AN ACTION PLAN THAT
IS ABOUT MAKING SURE WE CAN
PROVIDE FOR COMPREHENSIVE CARE-
FOR INTO THE TODDLERS ENSURING
THAT FAMILIES CAN EASILY
IDENTIFY ACCESS AND CHOOSE CARE
THAT MEETS OUR NEEDS ARE VOTING
SCHOOL READINESS- UNIVERSAL
PRESCHOOL AND GROWING OUR
WORKFORCE AND STATE WHERE THEY
WORK FOR SOME. I THINK THIS
YEAR PARTICULAR THIS PAST YEAR
IN PARTICULAR HAS SHOWN US JUST
HOW IMPORTANT EARLY CHILD- CARE
AND LEARNING IS HOW FRAGILE IT
IS AS WE LOOK AT THE IMPACT THE
COMPANIES HAD UPON FAMILIES OUR
WORK FORCE AND THE NEEDS OF
CHILDREN SO THIS IS THIS PLAN
IS- IN TOTAL A WAY TO LOOK AT
WHAT WE NEED TO DO OVER THE
NEXT TEN YEARS IN TERMS OF
ACTIONS. THAT REALLY DELIVER
ON- ADDRESSING THE NEEDS THAT
WE SEE AND LIKE I SAID EARLIER
BUILDING ON THE GREAT WORK THAT
WAS- SPEARHEADED BY THE
ASSEMBLY BLUE RIBBON COMMISSION
BUT ALSO YOU KNOW THE REPEATED
THEMES THAT WE SAW FROM THE
LIFTING CHILDREN OUT OF POVERTY
TASK FORCE- THE RATE REFORM
WORK GROUP THAT CALIFORNIA'S
TRANSFORMING THE WORKFORCE FOR-
WORKGROUP SO THERE'S BEEN A
NUMBER OF THINGS THAT THE
LEGISLATURE HAS HAD AN
IMPORTANT AND-IN PROMOTING
DRAWING ATTENTION TO. AN
ORGANIZING- THAT HAVE COME.
FORWARD IN THIS MASTER PLAN IN.
ONE THING I WANNA HOW FOR YOU-
THE MASTER PLAN IS. IT'S A GOOD.
THAT CAN BE FOR IN WE'VE WE
HAVE MADE UP OR AVAILABLE WHICH
IS. I THINK YOU KNOW HAS A- MY
NUMBER PAGES- BUT WE'VE FOR AND-
THAT WE HAD TO ENGAGE PEOPLE IN
UNDERSTANDING THE ISSUES- AND
THAT. WHAT WHAT WHAT'S THE
STORIES OF FAMILIES CHILDREN
PROVIDERS CAREGIVERS TEACHERS
IN THE SPACE SO WE HAVE MADE
AVAILABLE. THE MASTER PLAN
REPORT A SUMMARY IT'S IN
MULTIPLE LANGUAGES THE SUMMARY
IS AND- VARIOUS LANGUAGES AND-
I HAVE A WEBSITE THAT HAS BOTH
VIDEO BECAUSE IT HAS. A WAY
THAT THAT PEOPLE CAN ENGAGE
WITH THE INFORMATION- OF THE
MASTER PLAN WE'VE HAD OVER
SIXTY THREE HUNDRED UNIQUE
VISITORS TO THE SITE- WE'VE HAD
OVER. TWENTY FOUR THOUSAND
PAGES SO IT'S A GOOD TIME
PEOPLE ARE ENGAGING WITH THE
INFORMATION THAT'S IN THE
MASTER PLANNING WERE SEEN AS
HEAVILY CONSTRAINED CALIFORNIA
BUT WE ALSO HAVE. PEOPLE IN
OTHER STATES OTHER COUNTRIES
LOOKING AT WHAT CALIFORNIA IS
DOING IN THIS AREA. AS CAPTURED
IN THE MASTER PLAN. SO IN YOUR
AGENDA ITEM ALL IT OUTLINES THE
VARIOUS GOALS AND HIGHLIGHTS
AND STRATEGIES. THAT ARE KEY TO
THE MASTER PLAN SO WE HAVE
ORGANIZED THE MASTER PLAN
AROUND FOUR KEY GOALS. ON A YOU
CAN SEE THEM HERE ON THE SITE-
ONE IS HAVING PROGRAMS THAT ARE
ARE. ADDRESSING THE NEEDS OF
YOUNG CHILDREN THINKING ABOUT
HOW THE PROGRAMS ARE NOT JUST
EXISTING BUT HOW THEY'RE
UNIFIED HOW THE STRENGTHENED
AND HOW THEIR SUPPORT OF
COLLECTIVELY. OF OUR CHILDREN'S
LEARNING AND DEVELOPMENT AND
THEN ULTIMATELY YOU COULD HAVE
PROGRAMS BUT WE CAN'T DELIVER
PROGRAMS WITHOUT. THE WORK
FORCE THAT'S AVAILABLE AND NEED
TO SEE OUR WORKFORCE- BOTH
SUPPORTED DEVELOPED. AND
INCENTIVIZE ALONG THE KIND OF
CAREER PATHWAYS THAT WE WANT TO
SEE THAT BUILDS FOR OF QUALITY
THAT BUILD FOR. WHAT WE KNOW
RESEARCH SIZE MATTERS TO YOUNG
CHILDREN- AND IS SUPPORTED THEN
BY SOME COHERENCE IN THE WAY
THAT WE IDENTIFY WHAT THOSE
PROGRAMMATIC WORK STANDARDS
WORKFORCE. OUR STANDARDS ARE
I'M- THE NEXT AREAS FUNDING IN
THIS IS ONE THAT WE HEARD QUITE
A BIT ABOUT AS WE ARE COMING
INTO THIS WORK. AS WE ARE
WORKING THROUGH DEVELOPMENT AND
THAT'S FINE WHICH IS YOU DON'T
GET VERY FAR WITH PROGRAMS THAT
WORK FORCE IF WE CAN'T PUT
TOGETHER. A LOGICAL. WAY OF
THINKING THROUGH HOW TO BRING
TOGETHER FINDING HOW TO THINK
ABOUT FINDING AS IT. NEEDS TO
BE INCREASED AND BUILDING THAT
AROUND THAT THE KINDS OF THINGS
WE WANT TO SEE WITH THAT. THE
RIGHT PROGRAMS- PUTTING THEM
THE RESOURCES THAT THAT'LL
ULTIMATELY BUILDS ITS
WORKFORCE- THAT WE WANT TO SEE
AND THEN FINALLY OPERATIONS-
THINKING ABOUT GOVERNANCE
ADMINISTRATION. HOW DO WE
STREAMLINED THE SYSTEM SO THAT
IT'S FAMILY PARENTS CENTRIC
CHILD FOCUSED- AND EASIER TO
NAVIGATE SO THAT THOSE THINGS
THAT WE SAY MATTER- WITH REGARD
TO CREATING EQUITABLE
OPPORTUNITIES. ARE QUITE ARE
ARE MORE APPARENT OBVIOUS AND
AVAILABLE. THE FAMILY SO THOSE
ARE THE FOUR BROUGH AREAS I
WILL JUST MAKE A HIGH OF EACH
OF THESE SO YOU KNOW GOAL ONE
B. PROGRAM. WE BEEN THERE- YOU
KNOW BOTH RESEARCH A RECOMMEND
THE- AROUND- UNIVERSAL- WE'VE
LOOKED IN DEPTH AT PAID FAMILY
LEAVE AND WHAT IT WILL MEAN
THAT TAKE NUMBER CALIFORNIA'S
PRESENTLY AND BUILDING THAT
SYSTEM. OUT TO BE MORE
INCLUSIVE AND EQUITABLE FROM
THE STATE AND THEN A KEY AREA
AROUND ALCOHOL TREATMENT OF
CHILDREN WHERE WE HAVE.
PRACTICES THAT WE KNOW- ARE
PRESENT AND NEEDED TO MAKE THAT
MORE OF A STANDARD OF THE STATE
WITH REGARD TO HOW WE SUPPORT
BILL LANGUAGE LEARNERS JOIN
WITH DISABILITIES- AND TAKING
UP ARMS. YOU KNOW ADDRESSING
OUR PRACTICES THAT WE KNOW. ARE
VERY BARRIERS TO US ACHIEVING
EQUITY SO ELIMINATION OF
SUSPENSION AND EXPULSION-
WORKING HARD TO SUPPORT
INCLUSION AND THAT STARTS AT
THE VERY BEGINNING- WHERE WE
ARE FOCUSED ON INFANTILE THEIR
CARE AND HOW WE NEED TO MAKE
SURE THAT WE'RE BUILDING OUR
WORKFORCE CAPACITY. AND
PROVIDING MORE TARGETED
ATTENTION TO HOW WE ADDRESS
THAT AREA NEED FOR OUR STATE.
FARM YOU KNOW WORKFORCE THIS IS
THE SECOND GOAL- IS SO KEY TO
THE SYSTEM WHICH IS. WE KNOW
THAT WE CAN ONLY PROVIDE ACCESS
IF WE CAN HAVE PEOPLE THAT ARE
THERE TO SUPPORT CHILDREN. AND
HAVING THAT DONE IN A WAY THAT
ALLOWS FOR THE FULL RANGE OF.
OF CARE GIVERS TEACHERS- THAT
OUR PUBLIC ASSIST AND SO ONE
WE'VE GOT IS THERE'S MANY. IN
TYPES OF PRO WHICH OFTEN
SEGMENTED CITING SEPARATE ON
THE WORK FORCE AND SO ONE KEEP
PROPOSAL THAT THE MASKED BY
MAKES IS LET'S BUILD A
WORKFORCE AROUND COMPETENCIES.
SO THAT REGARDLESS OF WHERE WE
ARE WITH REGARD TO THE FUNDING
THE PROGRAMS WE SEE PATHWAYS
FOR THOSE- IN ROLES AS
CAREGIVERS PROVIDERS TEACHERS.
AND IN THOSE PATHWAYS WE WANT
TO MAKE SURE THAT THE RESEARCH
AROUND WHAT WE SAY MATTERS FOR
YOUNG CHILDREN. IS CONNECTED TO
WHAT WE THEN TRAINING AND
SUPPORT THE WORK FORCE WITH AND
SO USING- MAKING SURE THAT WE
ARE CREATING THE FOUNDATIONAL
UNDERSTANDING AROUND CHILD
DEVELOPMENT. LEARNING
ENVIRONMENTS- YOU KNOW FAMILY
ENGAGEMENT AND THE LIKE SO THAT
WE CAN ADVANCE THESE
COMPETENCIES AS PEOPLE PROGRESS
BUT THAT WE HAVE THEM AS A
FOUNDATION. AND THAT THAT
PROGRESSION FOLLOWS A CAREER
PATHWAY THAT'S- INCENTIVIZE
SUPPORTED BY HOW WE FUND THE
SYSTEM AND THAT WERE WORKING
TO. BETTER STREAMLINE
DIFFERENCES RIGHT REACHED C. OF
PERCEIVED DIFFERENCES OF
PROGRAMS AND MAKING THEM-
CONNECTED OR SO WE CAN SUPPORT
ALIGNMENT. FOR HOW OUR
WORKFORCE WILL MOVE THROUGH AND
ACROSS THE SYSTEM AND- KEEP
PEACE FUNDING SO. THIS IS ONE
THAT I KNOW- THIS COMMITTEE IS
BEEN VERY INVOLVED WITH- YOU
KNOW AND I THINK IT'S ABOUT A
QUESTION OF HOW DO YOU
STRUCTURE. SO THAT WHEN WE GET
TO THE PLACE WHERE WE HAVE MORE
FUNDS TO PUT IT WE CAN SAY THAT
WERE LOGICALLY ADDRESSING IT
AND DINNER AND- CONNECTING TO
THE THINGS THAT WE SAY WE VALUE
IN THE SYSTEM SO. YOU KNOW WE
HAVE- ONE KEY STRATEGY AROUND
SLIDING SCALE FEES AND THAT IS
IF WE CAN EXPAND WHERE WE
PROVIDE SUBSIDIES SO THIS ISN'T
ABOUT ASKING PARENTS TO PAY
MORE IT'S ABOUT FINDING WAYS
WHERE. WE CAN EXTEND SUBSIDIES
WE WOULD THEN BE ABLE TO HAVE A
SLIDING SCALE SPEAK THAT THAT
ALLOWS FOR- SOME RAMP DOWN. AND
THEN WHAT THAT AND WE COME.
LOOK LIKE AND THEY- IMPORTANTLY
THE AT WAY WE HAVE OUR REMEMBER
SO HAVE A RIGHT PROGRAM THEY
HAVE STRUCK. WE'RE SAYING WE
CAN THOSE CAN BE UNIFIED. AND
IMPORTANT- ORGANIZED- AROUND
ACOSTA A MODEL OF REIMBURSEMENT
SO THIS WOULD BOTH SIMPLIFIED
WITH AMPLIFIER VIEW ON EQUITY
AND IT WOULD BRING ME INTO THE
FORMULATIONS OF FOCUS ON WHAT
CHILDREN NEED. AND ATTENTION TO
QUALITY CHARACTERISTICS OF WHAT
WE PROPOSED IS- HAVING A
STRUCTURE THAT HAS BASE RATES
WITH ADJUSTMENTS FOR THE THINGS
THAT WE KNOW MATTER- AND ARE
CONNECTED VERY MUCH TO WHAT WE
CALLED OUT FOR WORKFORCE AND
PROGRAM. AND FINALLY THE LAST
AREAS MAKING THE SYSTEM SO THAT
IT IS- STREAMLINED THE FROM THE
VIEW OF FAMILIES AND PROVIDERS
MAKING IT SO THEY WERE
ORGANIZED AROUND HOW WE- BEST
SUPPORT AND USE DATA AND-
INFORMATION SO THAT WE CAN
DRIVE TO WHERE WE SEE NEEDS.
MAKING SURE THAT WE HAVE
FACILITIES AND BUILDING FOR
SOME TYPE OF SHARING.
EFFICIENCY OF YOU KNOW HAVING-
KICKING OUT THE BUSY WORKER
PAPERWORK- AND MAKING THAT
SOMETHING WE CAN STREAMLINE SO
THAT WE CAN ADD TO EFFICIENCY
OF OPERATION SO WE CAN FOCUS
MORE OF THE SYSTEM ON. THE
SUPPORTIVE. OF CARE GIVING AND
LEARNING. AND THEN I'LL THIS
CAN KERR. THIS WOULD BE YOU
KNOW ANOTHER MAJOR PART OF THE
MASTER PLAN WAS. LOOKING AT
WILL WANT WHAT WHAT A SYSTEM
LIKE THIS COST. INTO THAT'S
YOUR PLAN INCLUDES AN IN DEPTH
LOOK AT A COST MODEL FOR COST
MODELING FOR VARIOUS POLICY
SCENARIOS- FOR WHICH WE HAVE
ESTIMATED THAT DEPENDING ON
THOSE POLICY CHOICES. IT WOULD
COST AN ADDITIONAL TWO TO
TWELVE BILLION DOLLARS OVER
TWELVE THE TEN YEARS THANK YOU
I'M SUPPORT THE IMPLEMENTATION
A MASTER PLAN AND THAT RANGES
LARGELY BECAUSE THERE ARE MANY
IMPORTANT DECISIONS THAT WE
NEED TO BE MADE WITH REGARD TO-
WHERE DO YOU. ESTABLISH VARIOUS
YOU KNOW METRICS ON QUALITY
WHAT WE MEAN BY ACCESS AND SO-
THAT DEBUTED THE RANGE HERE
THOUGH BUILDS ON WHAT IS
PRESENTLY ABOUT SIX BILLION
DOLLARS IN. PUBLIC INVESTMENT
AND ANOTHER SIX BILLION DOLLARS
IN WHAT WE SEE AS PART OF
FAMILY COST RIGHT NOW SO
ESSENTIALLY WHAT WE'RE SAYING
IS. AT THE TOP END OF THIS
PLANT I WAS DOUBLING THE AMOUNT
OF TOTAL SPEND ON ON THE SYSTEM
FOR WHICH WE THINK IT NEEDS YOU
KNOW WE WOULD SEE A COMBINATION
OF PUBLIC INVESTMENT BUSINESS
CONTRIBUTIONS PHILANTHROPY. AND
SOME- POTENTIAL FAMILY FEES FOR
FAMILIES PARTICIPATING THAT ARE
CURRENTLY NOT TAKING ADVANTAGE
OF. THE EARLY CHILD CARE AND
LEARNING OPTIONS THAT WE HAVE
IN THE STATE AND ONE OF THE KEY
THINGS THAT WE THINK IS SUPER
TIMELY ABOUT THIS PLAN IS IT
ALIGNS STRONGLY. WITH WI FI THE
INCOMING ADMINISTRATION OR THE
CURRENT ADMINISTRATION HAVING
SAID AS THEY WERE- YOU KNOW IT-
OR WHATEVER IT IS THEY WERE
OUTLINING WHAT THEY PLAN TO DO
FOR ONLY CHILD. SO THIS REALLY
PRESENTS CALIFORNIA AS A STATE
WITH A SHOVEL READY PLAN WITH
WHAT THE FOUNDATIONAL PIECES IN
PLACE THAT THAT ARE PREPARED TO
TAKE ADVANTAGE OF FEDERAL
INVESTMENT IN THIS AREA- FOR
WHICH YOU KNOW WE ARE
DEMONSTRATED IN READY PARTNER
AS A STATE AND SO WITH THAT-
ALL WRAP THIS UP AND- SEE WHAT
QUESTIONS YOU HAVE BUT REALLY
APPRECIATE YOUR TIME AND YOUR-
SUPPORT FOR THIS IMPORTANT.
AREA AND FOR THE MASTER PLAN.
OKAY THANK YOU L. A. M. CORTEZ
WITH THE ANALYST. WELL MY
FELLOW PANEL WERE. HE TO THE
HAVE DROPPED THE MASS PLAN I
THE PANEL TODAY AS WHO READ THE
MASTER COME DOCUMENT AND IT'S A
BRIEFINGS WELL THE LARGEST WAS
NOT INVOLVED IN ANY OF THE
RESEARCH EFFORTS OF DRAFTING OF
THE MASTER PLAN. THE
LEGISLATURE WAS ABLE TO STOP
THE RESEARCH QUESTIONS THROUGH
THE BUDGET TRAILER BILL
PROCESS. AND THE LEGISLATURE
COULD EVALUATE WHETHER THE
MASTERPLAN ANSWERING ALL THE
STATUTORY OR QUESTIONS. OR
OTHER QUESTIONS OF INTEREST
PASSED. WE WOULD OVER THE CAN
THAT THE- OF THE PLAN GLAZER
SHE WAS PART OF AN TWENTIES
BUDGET. IMPLEMENTING OF THEM
OUT PLAN NOT YET BEEN AGREED BY
THE LARGEST. DID PRESENT. THAT
STEM FROM THE MASTER PLAN WORKS
SUCH AS THE G. CARE EXPANSION
PROPOSAL THE EDUCATION BUDGET
COMMITTEE SUBCOMMITTEE RECENTLY
HEARD. THAT THE LEGISLATURE WE
WANT TO ENSURE THAT THESE
ACTIONS NINETEEN ALIGNMENT WITH
ITS PRIORITIES WE WILL NOTE
THAT ALTHOUGH THE MASTERPLAN
ANSWERING SOME QUESTIONS AT A
VERY HIGH LEVEL THERE ARE A LOT
OF OUTSTANDING QUESTIONS THE
STATE WE NEED YOUR ADDRESS TO
IMPLEMENT THE MASTER PLAN MOST
NOTABLY THE FISCAL PICTURE.
THIS CONCLUDES MY REMARKS. BUT
I'M AVAILABLE FOR QUESTIONS.
THANK YOU. ALL A SERIES OF BUT
ALSO WITH COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
SELMER VITIS. THANK YOU SO
MUCH- I AM EXCITED ABOUT THIS
MASTER PLAN BUT I'M REALLY
CURIOUS TO KNOW- HOW IT'S GOING
TO BE IMPLEMENTED- AND THEN
GETTING INTO SOME OF THE DIDN'T
MORE OF THE DETAILS AND SOME OF
THE QUESTIONS I MAY HAVE MAY BE
ANSWERED AND ISSUES ADDING FIVE
AND SIX BUT I JUST WANNA SHOOT
FOR FORT FOR THEM NOW SO DOES
THE ADMINISTRATION ENVISIONED
HE K. AS THE PRIMARY EARLY
CHILDHOOD EDUCATION PROGRAM FOR
FOUR YEAR OLDS. TRANSITIONING
OTHER STATE SUBSIDIZED CHILD
CARE AND DEVELOPMENT PROGRAMS
TO PRIMARILY SERVE OUR YOUNGER
CHILDREN. THANK YOU FOR THE
QUESTION I'D LIKE TO ASK MY
COLLEAGUE AND DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE TO. TO ANSWER YOUR
QUESTION. HI GOOD AFTERNOON
THIS IS SERRA BURDEN WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE I'M
HOPEFUL YOU CAN HEAR ME OKAY-
SO TO YOUR QUESTION THE BUDGET
DOES INCLUDE FUNDING FOR.
INVESTMENTS IN THE TRANSITIONAL
KINDERGARTEN PROGRAM AT LOCAL
EDUCATIONAL AGENCIES- IT
INCLUDES VARIOUS INCENTIVE
PROGRAMS FOR WORKFORCE
INFRASTRUCTURE AND INCENTIVE
GRANTS I'M SO TO THAT END YES
THE ADMINISTRATION IS
REFLECTING ON THE RESEARCH IN
THE MASTER PLAN THAT SHOWS THAT
TRANSITIONAL KINDERGARTEN IS A
GREAT OPTION. TO PROVIDE
EDUCATIONAL OPPORTUNITIES FOR
MORE FOUR YEAR OLD TO
CALIFORNIA. SO IS THIS EFFORT
ALSO TO BALANCE THE DAHLE GOALS
OF UNIVERSAL ACCESS FOR FOUR
YEAR OLDS AND PRIORITIZE ACCESS
FOR ASK OUR RISK TO. ALL WITHIN
THE T. K. PROGRAM- AND WHAT IS
THE PHASING OUT OF STATE
PRESCHOOL GOING TO LOOK LIKE
AND IS THERE. ANY DISCUSSIONS
OR ANY AND INFORMATION I HOP
ABOUT HOW WE'RE GOING TO WORK
WITH THEIR PRIVATE PROVIDERS
AND NONPROFIT PROVIDERS AND
INCLUDING THEM- IN IN THIS IN
AND IN THIS PROCESS MOVING
FORWARD. YES THERE ARE NONE
AGAIN WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE SO HOPEFULLY I CAN
COVER ALL OF THOSE BUT WE ARE
NOT PROPOSING ANY CHANGES TO
THE STATE PRESCHOOL PROGRAM AT
THIS TIME- WE RECOGNIZE THAT
THE MIX DELIVERY SYSTEM. IS
VERY BENEFICIAL TO FAMILIES IN
CALIFORNIA- SO WE RECOGNIZED A
NON PROFITS AND CEOS IN LEDS
ALL PLAY A SIGNIFICANT ROLE IN
PROVIDING OUR SERVICES FOR
CHILDREN SO. THERE'S DEFINITELY
GOING TO BE ALIGNMENT- BETWEEN
THE EXPANSION OF THE
TRANSITIONAL KINDERGARTEN
PROGRAM AS ITS PROPOSED IN THE
BUDGET. I AS IT'S PROPOSED IN
THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET- IN WITH
THE EXISTING PRESCHOOL PROGRAMS
AS THEY ARE RIGHT NOW. AND HOW
MUCH FEDERAL FUNDING TO THE
STATE RECEIVED TO SUPPORT THE
PRESCHOOL DEVELOPMENT GRANT
STRATEGIC PLAN REQUIREMENTS.
AND ALSO OR ARE WE GOING ARE
THERE ANY OPPORTUNITIES FOR
ADDITIONAL FEDERAL FUNDING- HOW
IS THE TAN F. BLOCK GRANT GOING
TO BE UTILIZED OR- AND YET YOU
LAST. HI THIS IS CHRIS BURY I
CAN ANSWER THE FIRST PART OF
YOUR QUESTION REGARDING PDG
PRESCHOOL DEVELOPMENT GRANT-
INDEED WE RECEIVED A PRESCHOOL
DEVELOPMENT GRANT INITIAL- AND
IT WAS FOR PROXIBID AND IN IN
THAT. FUNDING WE WERE ABLE TO
PAY FOR THE FIRST NEEDS
ASSESSMENT FOR CALIFORNIA THAT
IS STILL A RESOURCE THAT'S
BEING MADE AVAILABLE TO. THE
PUBLIC- TO VIEW THE DATA THAT'S
BEEN COLLECTED AND CONTINUES TO
BE UPDATED. IN THE PRESCHOOL
DEVELOPMENT GRANT RENEWAL PDG
ARE- WE ARE NOT DEDICATING
ADDITIONAL RESOURCES TO THE
NEEDS ASSESSMENT BUT WE ARE
USING THE ONE DONE DURING THE
INITIAL GRANT. I HOPE THAT
ANSWERS YOUR QUESTION. YEAH IT
DOES THANK YOU. AND GOOD CAN
ANYONE CAN DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE- SPEAK TO OR OR THE-
WHOEVER MAY HAVE INFORMATION.
BUT OUR TOWN F. BLOCK BLOCK
GRANT AND HOW THAT'S GOING TO
BE LIES IN THIS. MASTER PLAN.
THIS IS SEVERED OR THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE SO WE ARE
STILL USING TOWN OF FUNDS AND
ARE POWERED STAGE TO- PROGRAM-
SO WE- ARE STILL UTILIZING ON
EIGHTY MILLION AND- TEN O'CLOCK
AM FUNDS FOR. THAT CAL WORKS
PROGRAM AND WE DON'T ANTICIPATE
THAT CHANGING AT THIS TIME- SO
THAT SPEAKING TO HOW WE ARE
CURRENTLY USING. YOU CURRENTLY
UTILIZING THE TEN THE FUNDS FOR
CHILD CARE AND WE EXPECT THAT
TO CONTINUE. THANK YOU AND-
LASTLY IN THE SPECIFIC
RECOMMENDATIONS UNDER ITS-
STRENGTH AND QUALITY STANDARDS
AND TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE
PROGRAM SO THAT THEY SERVE ALL
CHILDREN. ARE WELL AND
CULTURALLY AND LINGUISTICALLY
RESPONSIVE SETTINGS WHAT IS
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE LOOK LIKE
AT THE- END USER IN THIS WOULD
THIS ALSO FALL UNDER. THE REAL
NEED FOR PROVIDERS TO FIND
ACCESS TO QUALITY SUBSTITUTES
THAT'S ONE OF THE THIGS I HEAR
MOST FROM PROVIDERS- DURING
THIS PANDEMIC EVEN PRIOR TO THE
PANDEMIC IS WHY WHEN YOU- HAVE
A TEACHER THAT IS SICK- FINDING
A SUBSTITUTE IS DIFFICULT AND
THIS PANDEMIC HAS MADE THAT AND
EVEN. MORE IMPOSSIBLE REALLY
AND PARTICULARLY THIS IS
PARTICULARLY IMPORTANT FOR
PROVIDERS THAT ARE SERVING OUR
UNDERSERVED COMMUNITIES
MINORITY STUDENTS- STUDENTS
THAT ENGLISH IS THEIR SECOND
LANGUAGE- SO WOULD LOVE TO KNOW
WHAT THAT TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE
LOOK LIKE IN THIS COMPANY AND
MY PUTTING. AND THE NEED FOR
DEVELOPING THE WORK FORCE AND
QUALITY SUBSTITUTES AND THAT'S
RIGHT BUCK BUCKET. SO I'M HAPPY
TO TAKE CARE TO GIVE EUROPE ONE
REFERENCE FROM THE PLAN THAT I
THINK IS RELEVANT TO THAT POINT
WHICH IS- ONE ELEMENT IN IN.
GOAL FOR AREA IS CALLING OUT-
SOME VALUE BENEFITS AND SHARED
SERVICES NETWORKS. AND B. WHAT
A SHARED SERVICES THAT WE'RE
GETTING WE'VE SEEN THIS- ON
SOME SCALE BOTH WITHIN THE
STATE WE HAVE SOME EXAMPLES BUT
ALSO ACROSS THE COUNTRY WHERE
IT'S- TAKING- A ENTITY THAT
OFFERS SUPPORTS AND SERVICES.
FOR THINGS LIKE BUSINESS
OPERATIONS BUT JUST AS YOU SAID
COULD BE. A WAY TO GET
SUBSTITUTES AVAILABLE TO OUR
FIELD SO THEY CAN PARTICIPATE
IN PROFESSIONAL OR YOU CONTINUE
TO HAVE SERVICES IF A CAREGIVER
IS UNAVAILABLE OR EDUCATORS ON
AVAILABLE SO WE HAVE PUT FORTH
THAT WE THINK THERE NEEDS TO BE
SOME STRUCTURES LIKE YOU'RE
SAYING FOR TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE
IT COULD OCCUR THROUGH THESE
ENTITIES. I NEED TO BE
ORGANIZED WE HAVE A VERY BIG
STATE WITH LOTS PROVIDERS SO
HAVING SOME WAY TO MAKE THAT
AVAILABLE TO ALL INCLUDING
FAMILY CHILD CARE INCLUDING OUR
CENTER BASED CARE INCLUDING-
THOSE EXISTED SCHOOL DISTRICT
SO. WHY FORM. HAVING AND THAT
THAT WE CAN PROVIDE FOR SUPPORT
I'M ANOTHER COULD BE- WE'VE
CALLED OUT- THERE ARE AREAS
WHEN WE CALL WE SAY YOU KNOW
LET'S WORK ON IT- SUSPENSIONS
EXPULSIONS AND THEIR
ELIMINATION LET'S WORK ON-
REDUCING OUR BRINGING FORWARD
SUPPORT FOR TRAUMA INFORMED
PRACTICE STILL LANGUAGE
LEARNERS THOSE ARE ALL AREAS
WHERE TECHNICAL SYSTEMS COULD
TAKE THE FORM OF BOTH WHAT IS
TRAINED FOR IT COULD ALSO TAKE
THE FORM OF WHAT IS IN TERMS OF
SPECIALIZED SUPPORT TO DEAL
WITH. YOU KNOW ISSUES THAT THEY
MAY HAVE PRESENT THEMSELVES- IN
CLASSROOMS IN HOMES WHERE CARE
IS BEING GIVEN SO A VARIETY OF
WAYS THAT YOU CAN INTERPRET HOW
TO THINK ABOUT TECHNICAL
SYSTEMS BUT WE SEE THAT WORKS
BEING ONE PART AND WE SEE THESE
AREAS THAT WE NEED TO ADDRESS-
HOW DO WE GET SOME SPECIALIZED.
SUPPORT AVAILABLE TO THE FIELD.
AND WHAT. MASTERPLAN
RECOMMENDATIONS- ARE THERE TO
IT STABILIZE CHILD CARE-
ESPECIALLY IN THE NEAR TERM AS
YOU KNOW THIS I WOULD IMAGINE
THAT THIS A MASTER PLAN. UPON
ITS INCEPTION DIDN'T TAKE INTO
CONSIDERATION WOULD BE FACING A
GLOBAL PANDEMIC THAT WOULD TURN
YOU KNOW THE PRESCHOOL AND
CHILD CARE INDUSTRY UPSIDE DOWN
SO I'M JUST CURIOUS TO KNOW
WHAT YOU KNOW WHAT. WHAT
RECOMMENDATIONS ARE TO HELP
STABILIZE NOW. SO I WILL CALL
OUT ONE MAJOR ONE WHICH IS
DATA- THERE THERE IS YOU KNOW
WE'VE SEEN THIS ACTUALLY TO GO
TO FACT- ALREADY WHICH IS
HAVING DATA SO WE KNOW. WHERE
CARE IS AVAILABLE GETTING THAT
INFORMATION TO PARENTS BUT ALSO
HAVING DATA SO WE KNOW WHAT
KIND OF RESOURCES ARE NEEDED
AND TO BE ABLE TO COORDINATE
SERVICES- WHERE THEY ARE
AVAILABLE SO THAT THAT I THINK
IS ONE THING IN THE NEAR TERM
THAT AGAIN HAS HAD SOME VALUE
IMMEDIATELY BUT IS ONE THING
THAT IS BEING. WORKED ODD
PRESENTLY AND WILL HELP WITH-
RECOVERY EFFORTS AS WHERE WE'RE
LOOKING AT- THE EFFECTS OF
COBIT I THINK THERE'S ALSO
PIECES IN THERE THAT ARE THERE
WITH REGARD TO OUR WORKFORCE
NEEDS- AND BEING ABLE TO THINK
ABOUT THE DIFFERENT STRUCTURES
WITH REGARD TO HOW WE FIND THE
HOW WE TRAIN- BECAUSE NOT ONLY.
WERE NOW IN A PLACE WHERE WE
ALREADY KNEW WE HAD A NEED FOR
MORE. ON THE WORK FORCE. BUT WE
NOW NEED TO. EVEN BE ABLE A
LOSS OF- THE WORKFORCE THAT WE
NEED TO QUICKLY- YOU KNOW. WORK
TO TRAIN PEOPLE AND OR BRING
PEOPLE BACK INTO. AND ALL THIS
NOTE THAT I DID RECOGNIZE- YOU
KNOW MIGHT THE PRESCHOOL THAT
THAT IRAN AND CHILD CARE CENTER
THAT IRAN- BEFORE THE PANDEMIC
EVENT DURING THE PANDEMIC IT
THE FIRST COUPLE OF MONTHS WERE
REALLY HARD- AND I DID NOTICE
AND RECOGNIZE HOW QUICKLY OUR
CCRC. REPRESENTATIVES GOT ON
THE PHONE WITH US TO ASK US YOU
KNOW HOW MANY KIDS WE HAD
FAMILIES LOTS WE HAD OPENED
COULD THEY PLACE. THE CHILDREN
OF ESSENTIAL WORKERS IN OUR
PROGRAM AND I THINK THAT THAT
DATA COLLECTION THOSE QUESTIONS
THAT ON THE GROUND RELATIONSHIP
WITH OUR AGENCIES IS REALLY
VITAL AND I APPRECIATE THEIR
WORK. THANK YOU. OKAY THANK YOU
GREAT QUESTION SOUGHT SOME
FOLLOW UP QUESTIONS. OF COURSE
THAT THE MASTER PLAN IS MUCH
MORE THAN. THAN TEEKAY BUT I
DID WANT TO ANSWER THAT
QUESTION THAT SHE REFUSED TO
ANSWER BECAUSE- THAT THE SHE
REFUSED TO BUT- APARTMENT A
FINANCE THEY HAVE A JOB TO DO
AND SO DO WE- BUT- YEAH WE
THINK LOUD AND CLEAR. AS WE
TRANSITION. TO UNIVERSAL TKA
AND HAVE THAT L. A. BASIN PROP
NINETY EIGHT EIGHT BASED- THERE
IS AN OPPORTUNITY TO BOOST.
THAT ZERO THREE THREE. BOTH
KIDS AND FAMILIES BUT ALSO
PROVIDERS IN OTHER WORDS ARE.
IT WE HAVE ABOUT A BILLION
DOLLARS THAT WE CURRENTLY SPEND
THE CALIFORNIA STATE PRESCHOOL
PROGRAM AS THE AGENDA SAYS. YOU
KNOW ROUGHLY A HUNDRED AND
FIFTY SIXTY SOMETHING THOUSAND
IT WENT DOWN DURING THE- DURING
OCTOBER NINETEEN DURING FOR
FULL DAY APART DAY. AND SO WITH
THOSE MONIES NO LONGER NEEDED
WITH THOSE KIDS NTK YOU KNOW.
SOME PEOPLE ARE PROBABLY
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE A GREAT
GIVE IT TO US TO EXPAND MONEY
FOR. I HSS THAT THE YOU KNOW
HEALTH CARE HIGHER AT OTHER
WERE THE WERE LIKE NOT ON. THIS
MONEY WAS FOR. AS LITTLE OUR
LITTLEST LEARNERS AS YOU SAID
AND IT SHOULD STAY FOR OUR
LITTLEST LEARNERS SO- THIS IS
NOT THE POLICY COMMITTEE. BUT
WE HAVE A TWO BILLS GOING TO
THE PROCESS ARE BILL THAT I
KNOW YOU'RE PARTNERS WITH ME
ON. ON ON- PHASING IN UNIVERSAL
T. K. BUT A BILL BY CERTAINLY
MOUNT IN THE SENATE. WHICH
STATES THAT YOU DO HAVE THAT
TRANSITION. THOSE MONIES THAT
USED TO GO. FOR FOUR YEAR OLDS
IN THE STATE PRESCHOOL PROGRAM
SHOULDN'T GO TO THE BLACK HOLE
OF THE STATE BUDGET. WE SHOULD
BE REDIRECTED. TO PROP UP
ACCESS FOR INFANTS AND TODDLERS
ALL THE WAY UP TO THREE YEAR
OLDS IN THE STATE PRESCHOOL
PROGRAM-MAKE THE MORE VIABLE
AS WELL AS YOU KNOW LOOKING AT
THINGS LIKE. KIDS ARE NTK AND
MAYBE THEY'D MAKE IF IT'S A-
EVEN BEST CASE SCENARIO OF
TEEKAY IF IT'S A FULL DAY WE DO
KNOW IT'S NOT A REAL FULL DAY.
YOU KNOW PARENTS YOU KNOW. FOUR
FIVE HOURS HAVE TO GO PICK UP
THE CAN THE DAVIS THAT DOESN'T
WORK- SO HAVE YOU KNOW AFTER. A
RAP AS WELL SO THAT CERTAINLY
IS OUR NOTION AND- ANOTHER GIG
THE PART OF FINANCED IN
COMMITTED AS AS WELL BUT WE'RE
TALKING TO THEM AND- AND THEY
HI I THINK. A SUPPORT THE
DIRECTION THAT THEY WERE
HEADED. BUT I WANT TO ASK A FEW
MORE STEPS ABOUT THIS. OUT A
ONE I I'M GLAD YOU BROUGHT UP
THAT THE BITE IN- THAT KIND OF
VISION WHAT THE BUT THE BUYING
TEAM- CAMPAIGN DONNA'S TALKED
ABOUT THE GATE. AT A GIONALE OR
CHRIS DO WE HAVE ANY INDICATION
THAT THAT THEY'LL BE RESOURCES
TO HELP US IMPLEMENT. OUR LOFTY
GOALS WHETHER IT'S- PROVIDING
INCREASED ACCESS OR- YOU KNOW
REIMBURSEMENT RATES THAT YOU
KNOW PAY THE PROVIDERS. WHAT
THEY NEED MAKE SURE WE DON'T
PAY THAT. WORKERS POVERTY WAGES
AS WELL- I'LL I'LL- THE ANSWER.
OR TO JIM NOW. I THINK WE'RE IN
A GOOD POSITIONING CALIFORNIA
IF THE PRESIDENT SIGNS THE
CURRENT LEGISLATION WORKS
SLATED TO RECEIVE APPROXIMATELY
THREE POINT SVEN BILLION
DOLLARS. THAT WE WILL BE ABLE
TO UTILIZE THREE SEPTEMBER
TWENTY TWENTY TWO. AND YES IT'S
REALLY HELPFUL TO HAVE A PLAN
AS A ROADMAP FOR HOW WE MIGHT
MAKE SOME OF THOSE DECISIONS
ABOUT- WHERE TO EXPAND HOW TO
EXPAND. WHAT WHAT. THE RATE
DISCUSSION WE KNOW IT'S
HAPPENING AT THE BARGAINING
TABLE. AND WE REALLY LOOK
FORWARD TO HAVING THESE
ADDITIONAL RESOURCES AT THE
SAME TIME. THAT IN ADDITION TO
THE BLUE RIBBON COMMISSION
REPORT WE HAVE. A MASTER PLAN
WE CAN. REALLY RELY ON THOSE
DOCUMENTS TO MAKE THOSE
CRITICAL DECISIONS. JANELLE DO
YOU WANT TO SPEAK MORE
SPECIFICALLY TO- WHETHER
THEY'RE TO BE IT I DON'T THINK
THAT THE LEGISLATION IS.
TERRIBLY SPECIFIC ABOUT-
INVESTMENTS OUTSIDE OF CHILD
CARE- BUT THAT MAY COME INTO
SHARPER FOCUS IN THE COMING
WEEKS. YEAH I WOULD SAY I'M I'M
WITH CHRIS THAT I THINK IT'S-
WE DON'T HAVE PROPOSALS YET
THAT WOULD SAY HERE'S WHAT'S
GOING INTO THE FEDERAL BUDGET
BECAUSE I THINK SO MUCH
ATTENTION HAD TO QUIT ON THE
COVERAGE- RELIEF. BILL WHICH
YOU KNOW BY NOW THAT THAT HAS
PASSED THROUGH AND HOPEFULLY.
ABOUT WHERE TO GO AND I THINK
THAT- THE MASTER PLAN BECAUSE
OF THAT OF MY MAKE PRESENTS A
VERY GOOD CASE OF THOSE THINGS
THAT THE ADMINISTRATION SAID IT
WHEN THEY WERE- CAMPAIGNING
REALLY ARE THE THINGS THAT WE
SEE AS NEEDSAND THEN WE CAN
SUBSTANTIATE THAT WITH THE
RESEARCH- THAT'S PART OF THE
MASTER PLAN AND THAT. THE
DEFINITION OF ACTIVITIES THAT
ARE PART OF THE MASTER PLAN.
YES SO. I THINK IT'S A GOOD
POINT SO RIGHT NOW WE'RE WE'RE
SEEING THAT THE COVER NINETEEN.
PACKAGE IT'S ONE TIME MONEY AND
SO IT'S NOT THE ON GOING
FEDERAL BUDGET WHICH CAN GIVE
US ADDITIONAL SUPPORT. FOR YOU
KNOW ONGOING ISSUES LIKE
REIMBURSEMENT RATES-
PROFESSIONAL DEVELOPMENT-
ACCESS AND SLOT SO DO WE HAVE
ANY INDICATION THAT THAT WHAT
WE'RE GONNA SEE OTHER FELLOWS
ARE FROM THE FROM THE- ONGOING
FEDERAL BUDGET. IS GOING TO
HELP US IMPLEMENT WE WILL BUT
WE UNVEILED IN DECEMBER. WELL
IF IT TERMINATE IF WHERE YOU'RE
GOING WITH THIS IS WHAT MIGHT
COME AFTER THE REALLY FUNDS ARE
THERE GOING TO BE ON GOING
FUNDS WHETHER IT'S THROUGH THE
ANNUAL BUDGETING PROCESS. THE
CONGRESS USES OR THROUGH A BIG
INFRASTRUCTURE INVESTMENT OR
BOTH WE CAN'T PREDICT THAT
RIGHT NOW BUT WHAT'S REALLY
CLEAR IS THAT THE OKAY NINETEEN
PANDEMIC HAS CAUSED GREAT
GREAT- HARD TO THE EARLY
LEARNING SYSTEM IN CALIFORNIA
NEEDS RELIEF DOLLARS WILL DO A
LOT TO BRING US. CLOSER TO
WHERE WE WERE BUT AS I SAID IN
MY OPENING REMARKS IT WAS
AFRAID FRAGILE SYSTEM TO BEGIN
WITH AND WHAT WE HOPE IS IF WE
CAN USE THE RELIEF DOLLARS
STRATEGICALLY. AND CONTINUE TO
BUILD THE SYSTEM TO CREATE
GREATER RACIAL EQUITY GREATER
OUTCOMES MORE SUPPORT FOR THE
WORK FORCE AND A GREATER
ABILITY TO COMMUNICATE QUICKLY
AND- ACCURATELY WITH PARENTS
ABOUT THE CARE THAT'S
AVAILABLE. WE CAN DO SOMETHING
REALLY REALLY AND
TRANSFORMATIVE WITH ADDITIONAL
DOLLARS DOWN THE ROAD AND SO WE
LOOK FORWARD TO USING THE
RELIEF DOLLARS TO BRING
OURSELVES CLOSER TO WHERE WE
WERE AND THAT THE CLOSER THAN
WHERE WE WERE BEFORE THE
PANDEMIC. SO THAT WINDOWS
INFRASTRUCTURE ON GO TO I'M
GOING DOLLARS KIND WE CAN
INCLUDE THE BILL I'M A SYSTEM.
WE WILL BE PROUD OF. OKAY AND
YOU KNOW WE DID AS WE NOTED
SOME PROPOSALS IN THAT JANUARY
BUDGET HOPING THAT HOPE TO
ALIGN WITH THE MASTER PLAN
WRECKERS- CERTAINLY WHEN THE
BUDGET WAS PUT TOGETHER IN
DECEMBER WE DIDN'T KNOW WHERE
WE'RE AT WITH THAT YOU KNOW
COVERED ECONOMY NOW IT'S A BIT
DIFFERENT THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE D. DO WE THINK THAT
WE'LL SEE I MEAN CERTAINLY WE
WILL HAVE SOME IDEAS ON ART
LEGISLATIVE BUDGET BUT DO WE
THINK DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE.
WILL HAVE SOME REVISED IDEAS
WITH RESOURCES IN THE MAY
REVISED TO HELP IMPLEMENT THE
MASTER PLAN RECOMMENDATIONS.
FOR GOOD AFTERNOON OUR CARL
THANK YOU ERA DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE WITH REGARDS IT BACK-
WE'RE GONNA CONTINUE ONGOING
CONVERSATIONS TACKLE SOME I
THINK MY COLLEAGUES MENTIONED
WERE ALSO WAITING. FEDERAL
LEGISLATION TO SEE WHAT HAPPENS
THAT- I KNOW PERSONALLY MYSELF
I'VE SEEN ON THE NEWS THAT.
SOMETHING MAY OCCUR HOWEVER YOU
KNOW WE WILL CONTINUE THOSE
DISCUSSIONS AS WE MOVE FORWARD.
OKAY AND THEN I HAVE TO FINAL-
T. K. QUESTIONS MAYBE THIS CAN
GO BACK TO CHRIS. ENGINE NOW-
YOU MAY SEE THESE IN THE IN THE
AGENDA AS WELL NOT SURE IF.
THAT IS ACTUALLY AN AGENT YES
YOU MAY SEE THEM IN PAGE THREE
OF THE AGENDA. THE FINAL TWO
QUESTIONS THERE AND IN THE
BULLETS- AS FAR AS- WE DID TALK
ABOUT THIS IN OUR PROP NINETY
EIGHT HEARING A FEW WEEKS AGO.
SO THE FIRST QUESTION IS THAT
THE BUDGET A FOCUS ON ONE TIME
MONEY TO HELP INCENTIVIZE AND
SPUR- DISTRICTS TO IMPLEMENT
TEEKAY AND START THE PROCESS
AND WANTED TO AGAIN QUERY- THE
HIT YOU ALL ON THAT THE
RECOMMENDATION FOR FULL
FUNDING. FOR T. K. I NGUYEN THI
WHEN- WHEN IT'S FULLY REALIZED
THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA. IS THE
NOTION THAT IT WILL BE PAID FOR
WITH EXISTING PROP NINETY EIGHT
RESOURCES OR DO YOU THINK THAT-
THE STATE NEEDS TO LOOK AT- YOU
KNOW- PUTTING MONEY ON TOP OF
THAT ARE YOU KNOW JUST WHAT
WE'RE DOING RIGHT NOW IN THE
BUDGET SO FAR. ONE TIME MONIES-
WHAT WHAT DO YOU THINK- CHRIS
ORIGIN NOW. TELL ME WHEN HE
STARTED INTENDED TO CRESCENT
AND MAYBE EVEN DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE NAY ON AWAY INTO THIS
BUT- I YOU KNOW WHAT WE
PREPARED IN THE MASTER PLAN
WAS. AN ANALYSIS OF WHAT WE SAW
ON THE RESEARCH WITH REGARD TO-
YOU KNOW THE- PACKED OF. TREES
OTHER LEACH. OPPORTUNE AND
THEREFORE YOU KNOW MADE THE
RECOMMENDATION THAT WE- SEE
GREAT VALUE AND A UNIVERSAL
PRESCHOOL- FOR ALL HILDREN AND
HAVING. AN OPPORTUNITY AT THE
AGE OF FOUR AND FOR THOSE THAT
ARE LOW INCOME AND- IN CHILDREN
WITH THAT ARE IDENTIFIED WITH A
DISABILITY HAVING TWO YEARS
PRESCHOOL. WE'VE ALSO THEM
ACOSTA GOT OUT BUT WE HAVEN'T
TALKED SPECIFICALLY ABOUT THE
MECHANISMS BY WHICH WE WOULD
THEN FINANCES SO WHAT WE FOUND-
IN OUR REVIEW OF THINGS IS. YOU
KNOW WE'RE WE'RE AWARE OF THE
PROP NINETY EIGHT DYNAMICS WERE
AWARE OF. THE POTENTIAL FOR
FEDERAL FUNDS SO THE ABILITY TO
THINK ABOUT WHERE THOSE
REVENUES COME FROM- WAS NOT
LAID OUT IN SPECIFICS HOWEVER
AND I THINK. THE L. A- POINTED
THAT OUT- BUT WE DO HAVE THE
COST ANALYSIS FOR THOSE.
VARIOUS PARTS OF THE PLANT.
FINANCE DO YOU WANT TO ADD
ANYTHING. YEAH I WAS THERE A
PARTNER WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE SO I WOULD JUST ADD
THAT HE THE PROPOSAL TO EXPAND
TRANSITIONAL PARK IN THE GARDEN
IS AS JOURNAL SAYS BORN OUT OF
THE RESEARCH FROM THE MASTER
PLAN IN TERMS OF THE FUNDING
STRUCTURE ON THAT WOULD SUSTAIN
ANY FUTURE PROPOSALS- TO MAKE
THE TRANSITIONAL KINDERGARTEN
PROGRAMS ONGOING WOULD
NECESSARILY LEVERAGE THE
EXISTING INFRASTRUCTURE OF
LOCAL EDUCATIONAL AGENCIES
INCLUDING. OF THE PROPOSITION
NINETY EIGHT FUNDS THAT THEY
USE- THAT'S NOT IN OUR PROPOSAL
AT THIS TIME BUT WE DO
RECOGNIZE THAT. OF THE FUNDS
THAT WE ARE PROPOSING FOR THESE
GRANT PROGRAMS THAT WE HAVE IN
THE BUDGET RIGHT NOW THEY ARE
UTILIZING THIS PROP NINETY
EIGHT PHONES. THANK YOU AND
THEN THE LAST QUESTION IS-
EXCUSE ME THE LAST QUESTIONS
ABOUT THAT T. K. STANDARDS IN
ALIGNMENT I KNOW THAT WHEN I
SPOKE TO YOU- SO I WRITE US
ABOUT THIS. ONE THING YOU SAID
IS WHAT ABOUT THE STANDARDS
TK'S VERY DIFFERENT THAN
PRESCHOOL WE HAVE YOU KNOW A
YOU KNOW MORE REASONABLE RATIOS
AND SO WE'RE PUTTING MONEY ON
THE BUDGET TO HELP DISTRICTS
FURTHER EXPAND T. K. THERE WERE
SILENCE OR- NOT WE ARE WE'RE
WE'RE SPEAKING ABOUT OUR
LEGISLATION THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE HASN'T SPOKEN UP ABOUT-
ALIGNMENT IN NTK STANDARDS. IS
THAT SOMETHING THAT YOU THINK
THAT NEEDS TO BE ADDRESSD- NOW
OR STORE DOWN THE ROAD. HELLO
AGAIN SIR BERNARD DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE SO WE CERTAINLY
RECOGNIZE THAT THE STANDARDS
BETWEEN THOSE TWO PROGRAMS. ARE
DIFFERENT THE WAY THAT OUR
CURRENT PROPOSALS ARE SET UP-
WE DON'T BELIEVE THAT THE
INTERACTION OF FACTS THAT WE
WOULD SEE FROM AN ONGOING
TRANSITIONAL KINDERGARTEN
EXPANSION ARE GOING TO BE
REALIZED AT THE VERY LEAST IN
THE BUDGET YEAR. WITH THE
INCENTIVE GRANT PROGRAM THERE
IS A ONE YEAR- DATA COLLECTION
PROCESS THAT WE HOPE TO GET
FROM LEDS BEFORE WE START
ANOTHER YEAR OF DOLING OUT
THOSE INCENTIVE GRANTS- AND
THAT PROCESS ALLOWS US. TO SEE
WHAT SORT OF CAPACITY BUILDING
MEASURES WILL BE TAKEN UP
THROUGH THESE GRANTS AND
DETERMINE HOW WE CAN BUILD UPON
A TRANSITIONAL KINDERGARTEN
PROPOSAL SO AT THIS TIME WE
THINK THAT THESE. ARTICULAR
GRANT PROGRAMS ARE SHORT TERM
IN NATURE- AND- TO THE EXTENT
THAT THE ALIGNMENT BETWEEN
STATE PRESCHOOL AND
TRANSITIONAL CONTEMPORARY GRANT
WILL BE REALIZED IN THE FUTURE
IS CERTAINLY A CONVERSATION
THAT WE ARE LOOKING FORWARD TO.
AND UNDERSTAND ITS TO HAPPEN IN
ORDER FOR ANY EXPANSION OF
THESE PROGRAMS ARE ANY CHANGES
THAT WE MAY LOOK AT AS A RESULT
OF RESEARCH FROM THE MASTER
PLAN. WILL COME TO FRUITION SO
WE CERTAINLY RECOGNIZE THAT
THEY ARE DIFFERENT- TO THE
EXTENT THAT THEY EXPAND THEY
WILL WE WILL. LOOK FORWARD TO A
CONVERSATION ABOUT ALIGNING
THOSE AS WELL. OKAY THANK YOU
AND AGAIN AS AS YOU KNOW WE
HAVE SOME. IDEAS ABOUT THIS
THAT WILL BE PUTTING FORWARD
POTENTIALLY IN THE BUDGET. AND
THROUGH COMPANION LEGISLATION.
ANYMORE QUESTIONS ON THE MASTER
PLAN THE SECOND SECTION. SEEING
NONE- LET'S PROCEED NOW WITH
THIS IS AN INFORMATIONAL ITEM
THANK YOU IT WAS VERY HELPFUL
ISSUE NUMBER TWO IS RELATED TO
ACTUAL OF THE BUDGET AND SOME
OF EARLY ACTIONS AND WE'RE
GONNA BE LOOKING AT FOR TWENTY
TWENTY ONE ISSUE NUMBER TWO. WE
HAVE THE L. A. L. TO FINANCE
PERMANENT EDUCATION AND DSS. HE
SAID THE SAME WHAT. WE'RE GONNA
START WITH L. A. L. LIKE YOU.
THAT IT THEIR LIVES ANALYST'S
OFFICE YES I WOULD HAVE TO GIVE
A BRIEF OVERVIEW OF THE STATE
SUBSIDIZED HEALTHCARE SYSTEM
AND I WILL BE REFERENCING A FEW
PAGES FROM REJECT THAT FOR
THOSE THAT HAVE THEIR CHEN
HANDY THE STATE SUBSIDIZED
SEVERAL CHILDCARE AND PRESCHOOL
PROGRAM THE STATE SPEND ROUGHLY
FIVE POINT EIGHT BILLION TO
SERVE AN ESTIMATED FIVE HUNDRED
FOUR THOUSAND CHILDREN IN THESE
PROGRAMS. RECOLOR CHILDCARE IN
THE STATE SERVICE ALL CHILDREN
MEETING ELIGIBILITY CRITERIA
FOR THE OTHER PROGRAMS IS THE
AMOUNT HEALTHCARE SERVICE
GENERALLY SET ANNUALLY BY THE
STATE DURING THE BUDGET PROCESS
THE STATE HAS TWO TYPES OF
CHILDCARE PROGRAMS EITHER
VOUCHER BASED PROGRAMS- ARE
DIRECT CONTACT. BY TODAY'S
BATCH OF A PROGRAM PRIMARILY
CAO K. AND TURNED IT HIM
CORRECT BASED PROGRAM HELP
PROVIDER ARE READING BASED ON
THE RICH MARKET RATE THE RATE
ITSELF IS BASED ON A SURVEY
CONDUCTED EVERY OTHER YEAR BUT
THE STATE DETERMINES WHAT
SURVEY TO USE AND WE ARE
CURRENTLY USING THE TWO
THOUSAND SIXTEEN SURVEY THE
RATE VARIES BY COUNTY AGENTS
HEALTH SERVICE AMOUNT OF CARE
USE AND THE TYPE OF CHILD CARE
PROVIDER RELEASE PROGRAMS
FAMILIES WILL GAIN ELIGIBILITY
FOR CHILD CARE WITH A COUNTY
HUMAN SERVICES DEPARTMENT OR AN
ALTERNATIVE YOU CAN EVEN SEE.
ONCE THE FAMILY RECEIVED
ELIGIBILITY YOU CAN USE THE
VOUCHER TO RECEIVE CHILD CARE
FROM ANY PROVIDER IT PREFERS.
THAT ANY SECOND OR FIRST. WE
ALSO HAVE DIRECTLY WITH MINORS
NEARLY PROVIDERS PROJECTED.
SECREST AND CHEN KELLY. DIRECT
CONTACT PROVIDED A REIMBURSE BY
THE STATE REMEMBER. RATE EVERY
ANNUALLY BY THE STATE. THE
STANDARD RATE. RATE IS IT JUST
BY EIGHT. I'M OUT OF HERE USED
SOME OTHER. IN MOST NOTABLY
DIFFERS FROM THE REGIONAL RATE
BECAUSE IT'S A NOT HAVE A JOB
WHERE ADJUSTMENT. IS PROVIDERS
CALL WITH THE TO SERVICE NUMBER
TWO WHO AND FAMILY WORKED RIGHT
WITH THE- PROVIDERS BECOME.
WORLD IN THESE. PAGE SEVEN OF
YOUR BEGIN THE DISK. OF THE
PANDA IN ON CHILD CARE.
PROVIDERS AND THE STATE'S WORST.
CHILD PROVIDER HAVE THERE'S-
THAT THEY SERVING FEWER SHE AND-
A LOT OF IN DUE TO SERVING
CHILDREN. PROVIDERS ARE ALSO.
HIGHER COSTS TO CLEAN SENATE.
AND PERSONAL EQUIPMENT. EIGHT
OTHER GENDER HAS SOME. ABOUT
LICENSE CLOSURES AND ALSO ONE
PAGE TEN THERE IS A TABLE THAT
WAS KIND OF A- RELATED ACTIONS
TO LAST MONTH. AND PRIMARILY
SUPPORTED SPEAKS UP. CHAPTERS.
LAST MONTH THE STATE. TO EXPAND
HUNDRED THE OF THE THING AND
SIX FORMALLY. THE STATE
RECEIVED- CC JETER HERE TO THE
PASSAGE OF R. Y. THREE THREE.
LATE LAST YEAR. THIS EARLY I
HOCKEY FOR MORE. I'M IN YOUR
AGAIN ON PAY THERE. IN A RECENT.
WE ARE PROVIDE WITH ISSUE THE
LEGISLATURE COULD CONSIDER
ACTUALLY MOST OF. SUPPORT
PROVIDER. AND FAMILIES DURING
THE- WITH THE REMAINING OF THE
STATE FUNDS THE LEGISLATURE
MEANWHILE TO CONSIDER ACTION AT
THE STATE COULD IMPLEMENT
QUICKLY. GIVEN THE IMMEDIATE
CREATED BY THE COOK AND I
NUMBER. THIS INCLUDES USING
EXISTING PROGRAM TAKE. EXISTING
ACT. AND USING ALLOCATION. THE
LEGISLATURE COULD ALSO
CONSIDERS. SPENDING ACROSS THE
CURRENT THE BUDGET. THIS IS THE
STATE CAN. THE TEMP SUPPORT FOR
A LONG PERIOD OF TIME. THE
LEGISLATURE COULD ALL CONSIDER
MODIFY FLEXIBLE AS TO IN
MICHIGAN HEARD IN. THE APPLE
PROVIDED AND THEN I'LL IS YEAH
THE FEES. WILL FURTHER DEVELOP
THAT THE FOR OF A AND IS ONE
TIME BUT- DURING THE- VILLAGES.
HAS HIGH OR HIGH USING MY TIME
BUT TO PROVIDE TEMPORARY
SOFTWARE. WORKERS BUT IS THAT
YOUR MAILING TO CONSIDER
PROVIDING SIMILAR. ISSUE THE-
FUNDING. TO CONTINUE TO PROVIDE
ACCEPTED CHILD FEEL. WITHOUT
ONGOING FUNDING FOR RISK TEMP
FLOW LEAVING. BE DECEMBER. THIS
MY REMARKS BUT I'M HAPPY TO
TAKE AT THE- TIME. EIGHT I IN
THE BUDGET ACT OF TWENTY TWENTY
CALIFORNIA RECEIVED THREE
HUNDRED FIFTY POINT THREE
MILLION THROUGH THE FEDERAL
CARE ACT BRICKELL THE NINETEEN
RELATED CHILDCARE ACTIVITIES.
OF THAT ABOUT A HUNDRED FORTY
FOUR POINT THREE MILLION WAS
USE FOR STATE COSTS ASSOCIATED
WITH SB EIGHTY NINE
EXPENDITURES FAMILY FEE WAIVERS
AND PROVIDER PAYMENT
PROTECTION. UNDER TWENTY FIVE
MILLION WAS USE FOR SUPPORTING
DATABASE PROVIDERS. I'M
INCLUDING. FUNDS FOR PROVIDERS
ACCEPTING VOUCHERS AT THE
MAXIMUM CERTIFIED LEVEL OF NEED
AND FOR ONE TEN SECONDS FOR
PROVIDERS ACCEPTING VOUCHERS
THAT OFFER CARE DURING THE CALL
THE NINETEEN PANDEMIC. ANOTHER
SEVENTY THREE MILLION WAS USED
TO CONTINUE CARE FOR AT RISK
CHILDREN AN ESSENTIAL WORKERS
IN EIGHT MILLION WAS USED TO
EXTEND FAMILY FEE WAIVERS UNTIL
JUNE THIRTIETH TWENTY TWENTY.
OCTOBER TWENTY TWENTY THE
ADMINISTRATION PROVIDED HUNDRED
TEN MILLION A CORONA VIRUS
REALLY FIND CHILD CARE
PROVIDERS. TO REIMBURSE THEM
FOR COSTS OF WADE FAMILY FEES
AND TO EXTEND THE LENGTH OF
CARE FOR CHILDREN OF ESSENTIAL
WORKERS WITH TEMPORARY VOUCHERS
SPECIFICALLY. THIRTY MILLION
WAS PROVIDED TO REIMBURSE
CHILDCARE PROVIDERS FOR FAMILY
FEES WAIVED FOR FAMILIES
ENROLLED THE NOT RECEIVING IN
PERSON CARE. EIGHT MILLION WAS
PROVIDED TO EXPAND ACCESS TO
CHILD CARE FOR CHILDREN OF
ESSENTIAL WORKERS AND FOR
CREASED INCREASED. COSTS OF
CARE FOR SCHOOL AGED CHILDREN.
I'D LIKE TO CONGRESS PASS THE
CHROME. RESPONSE AND RELIEF
SUPPLEMENTAL APPROPRIATIONS ACT
THAT INCLUDED APPROXIMATELY TEN
POINT THREE BILLION CHILD CARE
DEVELOPMENT BLOCK GRANTS COULD
REALLY FUNDS FOR CHILDCARE AND
EARLY START. OF THAT AMOUNT
CALIFORNIA RECEIVED NINE
HUNDRED SIXTY FOUR MILLION CCTV
G. FEDERAL FUNDS. EARLY ACTION
LEGISLATION APPROPRIATE FOR HER
TO MILLION OF THAT C. RSA FUNDS
TO ADDRESS IMMEDIATE NEEDS IN
CHILDCARE. INCLUDING STIPENDS
FOR CHILDCARE PROVIDERS THAT
ACCEPT STATE SUBSIDIES
INCLUDING STATE PRESCHOOL-
PROVIDING MORE THAN EIGHT
THOUSAND CHILDREN ESSENTIAL
WORKERS ACCESS TO SUBSIDIZED
CHILDCARE THROUGH JUNE
THIRTIETH TWENTY TWENTY TWO-
AND SEVENTY SIX MILLION TO
EXTEND THE CARE OF CHILDREN ON
TEMPORARY SUBSIDIES THROUGH
JUNE THIRTIETH TWENTY TWENTY
TWO. AND ANOTHER TWO MILLION
FOR ADMINISTRATIVE COSTS TO
ENSURE EXPEDIENT ALLOCATION OF
FUNDING AND SPOTS TO PROVIDERS
AND FAMILIES. AS WELL AS AN
ADDITIONAL SIXTEEN PAID NON
OPERATIONAL DAYS FOR CHILD CARE
PROVIDERS THAT ACCEPT STATE
VOUCHERS. DEMONSTRATION ALONG
WITH HE CHILD CARE PROVIDERS
UNITED. WHICH REPRESENTS CHILD
CARE PROVIDERS WILL SALAS A
WORKGROUP TO IDENTIFY THE
ALLOCATION OF THE REMAINING
FEDERAL C. R. S. A. FUNDS IN
PRIORITIES IMPACTING THE CHILD
CARE FIELD. AND THAT CONCLUDES
MY REMARKS AND I'M HAPPY TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS. OKAY
THANK YOU DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION. GOOD AFTERNOON THAT
THEIR CHAIR MEMBERS THEY'RE
ENTITLED WORKING DEPUTY
SUPERINTENDENT AT THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION ON BEHALF OF STATE
SUPERINTENDENT OF PUBLIC
INSTRUCTION TO BE THURMOND
THANK YOU FOR HAVING ME SPEAK
WITH YOU ALL TODAY. SINCE THE
COVER NINETEEN CHILDREN FACE
WAS ISSUED IN MARCH TWENTY
TWENTY CDS ADMINISTERED EIGHT
FIVE HUNDRED AND EIGHTEEN
MILLION INVESTMENT THROUGH
ELEVEN DIFFERENT POTS THAT
FINDS TO SUPPORT SHORT TERM
EMERGENCY CHILDCARE PROVIDERS
BEING FUNDED FOR CLOSURES AND
HELP HER. LESS FOR LOWER CHILD
ATTENDANCE. THE STEP BY.
WAITING THE ONLY BE AND
PROVIDING STATEMENTS ABOUT. IN
AND WE RELEASED A THERE
MANAGEMENT BULLETIN. PROVIDING
GUIDE TO THE FIELD RELEASED
THREE HUNDRED FAQS POSTED
WEBINARS FOR THE FIELD THAT
GUIDANCE AT A MINIMUM OF EVERY
TWO WEEKS FOR ROUGHLY A
THOUSAND PARTICIPANTS. AN
AWKWARD REGIONAL CAFES WHERE
ARE SEAT CONSULTANTS ARE
CONNECTING THE CONTRACTORS TO
PROVIDE TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE
AND SUPPORT MENTORING
DISCUSSIONS ON REGIONAL
CHALLENGES AND SUCCESSES. AS
WELL AS MENTAL HEALTH RESOURCE
THAT. CURRENTLY WE ARE IN AB
EIGHT TO WHICH IS BY THE
GOVERNOR TO BE AGO AND A
PERFORATED ONE HUNDRED AND TWO
MILLION AT THE NINE HUNDRED AND
SIXTY FOUR MILLION. IN CHILD
DEVELOPMENT BLOCK GRANT WHILE
THE VIRUS RESPONSE AND RELIEF
SCUTTLED METAL OVERLORDS ARE
CORRECT THAT THE AND- IS THAT
PART SUBSIDIZED CHILDCARE AND
SPEAK WITH THE PROVIDERS.
DURING JAN THAT SUMMARIZES THE
L. IT'S AB AT T. THE ON PAGE
THIRTEEN BUT AS A QUICK
REMINDER THERE'S TWO HUNDRED
TWENTY EIGHT MILLION FOUR ONE
TIME FLAT RATE AT FIVE HUNDRED
AND TWENTY FIVE THE TRAIL. CARE
SEVENTY SIX MILLION TO EXTEND
WITH AN INTENTIONAL EIGHTY
MILLION TO ENROLL MORE CHILDREN
AND EMERGENCY CHILD CARE YOUR
JUNE THIRTIETH. OF TWENTY
TWENTY YOU. AND ADDITIONAL PAID
OFFER DAY. DUE TO CARBON. ABOUT
YOUR- IN PART FAMILY CHILD CARE
HOME. NETWORK CONTRACT TAKES.
ALLOW THEM TO HAVE A TOTAL OF
THIRTY DAYS OF CLOSURE DUE TO
COVER NINETEEN THAT'S IN
ADDITION TO THE TEN DAYS THEY
ALREADY RECEIVED. THE CITY IS
PREPARING TO RELEASE THE FUNDS
AND IT'S BEEN CLOSELY
COORDINATING WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE TYPICALLY
ACCESS. OR AT THE POINT NOW
WHERE THE STATE COMPTROLLER'S
OFFICE IS WORKING TO MAKE THESE
FUNDS AVAILABLE. TO THEN
DISTRIBUTE. I REPORT WITH GIVEN.
AND LET TO ADDRESS A SHORT OF
FUNDING NEEDED TO REIMBURSE
PROVIDERS AT THE MAXIMUM
CERTIFIED HOURS OF CARE FOR
FAMILIES DURING WORLD WITH A
VERY FULL SCHEDULE. CITY SENATE
EMAIL LAST WEEK IN TERM
GUIDANCE TO NOTIFY CONTRACTORS
THAT PROVIDER SHALL BE
REIMBURSED BASED ON THE MAXIMUM
CERTIFIED HOURS OF CARE. YOUR
JUNE THIRTIETH TWENTY TWENTY
ONE. DESPITE EVERYTHING THAT WE
HAVE DONE AND ARE CURRENTLY
WORKING ON WE KNOW THAT THE
FIELD IS STILL STRUGGLING.
ISSUES INCLUDE CHALLENGES WITH
STAFFING MULTIPLE CLOSURES ARE
GRAHAM'S- CLASSROOMS DIFFICULTY
ACCESSING TESTING OUR VACCINE
AND INCREASED PROGRAM COSTS TO
ADDRESS HEALTH AND SAFETY.
INCREASE STAFFING NEEDS
SUPPORTING IN PERSON AND
DISTANCE LEARNING MODELS. TO
ADDRESS SPENDING. AND THE
DECREASED ENROLLMENT TO
MAINTAIN SMALLER GROUP SIZES
AND THE- COPART AND- AT CAN'T
DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL. YOU CAN
LICENSING AND CONFUSION OVER
FAMILY FEES ESPECIALLY WHEN A
PROGRAM IS HAD TO CLOSE AND
REOPEN DETERMINE EXPOSURE.
RESHAPED ALL OF THE RESOURCES
THAT HAVE BEEN APPROPRIATED TO
DATE SINCE THINK WILL REALLY GO
FAR TO ADDRESS THE SKILLS WE
ALSO GREATLY ONE APPRECIATE AND
ACKNOWLEDGE INCLUDING EARLY
LEARNING AND CARE PROVIDERS AND
TEACHERS IN THE ALLOCATION OF
THE 10% OF VACCINES FOR
EDUCATORS. MOVING FORWARD WE
ALL KNOW THERE'S MORE TO DO IN
THIS AREA ESPECIALLY ABOUT A
STRONG EARLY LEARNING CARE
SYSTEM MOVING FORWARD AND
CERTIFIED BUT WENT BACK TO THE
MASTER PLAN DISCUSSION ON THAT.
AS WE LOOK AT NEW INVESTMENT IN
ALIGNMENT WITH THE L. A. WE
WOULD RECOMMEND WAITING PAYING
THE FEES FOR OUR ALL FAMILIES
ADDITIONALLY LIKE TO FLAG THE
NEED FOR CONTINUED HOLD
HARMLESS FOR BOTH DIRECT
CONTRACT IN ABOUT YOUR
PROVIDERS. THESE ACTIONS WOULD
STABILIZE THE ENTIRE SYSTEM AND
REDUCE ADMINISTRATIVE BURDENS
DURING A TIME OF STRESS NEED.
ADDITIONAL STIPENDS THAT WOULD
BE ACCESSIBLE TO THE ENTIRE
EARLY LEARNING CARE FIELD COULD
ALSO HELP PROGRAMS ADDRESSED
THE ADDITIONAL COST FOR DOING
BUSINESS DO TO COMBAT NINETEEN.
AS WELL AS STABILIZING THESE
PROGRAMS DURING THIS TIME WE
WANT TO MAKE SURE WE CAN
ADDRESS THE NEED FOR ALL
WORKING PARENTS NOT JUST THAT
IS USING SUBSIDIES. THANK YOU
SO MUCH AND I'M HAPPY. TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS YOU MIGHT.
THANK YOU PERMANECE SERVICES.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR AND
MEMBERS CAN JOHNSON CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL SERVICES
I'M I ALSO JUST WANT TO REALLY
UP LEFT THE TREMENDOUS EFFORT
THAT'S BEEN HAPPENING ACROSS
OUR STATEAND AGAIN THAT THAT
DOCUMENT IS CHALLENGED AND THAT
WE HAVE AHEAD OF US AND SO
CERTAINLY IN TERMS OF BOTH THE
WORK FORCE AND THE CHALLENGES
THAT EXPERIENCE IN THE FAMILIES
THE POOREST. ARE REAL YOUR YOUR
AGENDA AT ASK A COUPLE
QUESTIONS RELATED TO LOSS OF
CAPACITY SO I WILL. A POINTS
OUT- PAGE EIGHT ON YOUR AGENDA
THAT HAS SOME INFORMATION.
THROUGH I DON'T REMEMBER. IF WE
LOOK THROUGH FEBRUARY OF THIS
YEAR THE TOTAL CAPACITY LOSSES
OVER FIFTY TWO THOUSAND AB
PLACES THAT CHILDREN COULD
OTHERWISE BEEN SERVED- OF
COURSE THAT WE NEED TO TAKE
INTO ACCOUNT. ANY NEW PROGRAMS
THAT WE ACTUALLY HAVE HAD SOME
NEW CAPACITY ESTABLISHED OVER
THE COURSE. OF THE LAST YEAR IN
SO ALL OF THOSE THINGS
CONSIDERED IT'S ACTUALLY A LESS
THAN A- 1% AT CHANGING EITHER
DIRECTION WHEN WE LOOK AT
NUMBER OF FACILITIES AND
CAPACITY BUT CERTAINLY AGAIN.
ARE THERE WAS NEED AN
ADDITIONAL SUPPLY AND SUPPORT
NEEDED PRETENSE TO MAKE- AND
CERTAINLY WILL BE S. B. WE'RE
GOING TO RECOVERY. AT THIS
EVENT I TERMS OF YOUR QUESTIONS
TO ASK AROUND FLEXIBILITY TO
GET APPRECIATE THAT THE
PARTNERSHIP AND THAT SEVERAL OF
THE ITEMS THAT HAVE STARTED
WORKING JUST PRESENTED. AT THAT
WE WORKED ON TOGETHER BUT I
WOULD JUST SAY AS WE'RE
LEARNING NOT ONLY IN THE SPACE
OF CHILD CARE AND. DEVELOPMENT
SERVICES BUT ACROSS OTHER. MS
THAT WE'VE MADE A- THAT SOME OF
THINGS THAT WE WANT TO SEE
CONTENT IN IN MAXIMO. TAKE OP.
TO LOOK FOR OUTER THE WAYS IN
WHICH- BOTH FAMILIES THE M.
PROGRAM MINISTRIES ARE
CONNECTING WITH THAT SO LOOKING
AT. MULTIPLE MODALITIES THINGS
LIKE ELECTRONIC SIGNATURES AND
A NUMBER OF PLACES THAT WE WERE
ABLE TO IMPLEMENT AS WE ALL AND
MANY OF US CONTINUE TO WORK IN
A REMOTE ENVIRONMENT. I WE ALSO
AGAIN I WANT TO RECOGNIZE OUR
WE HAD A NUMBER OF FLEXIBILITY
WE HAVE. IMPLEMENTED EARLY ON
RELATED TO THE ALLOWANCE OF
CREATION CREATING POP UP. AT
PROGRAMS THAT REALLY THAT'S A
COMBINATION. OF BOTH EXPANDED
TO- CAPACITY. FOR LICENSE
PROGRAM SO MAYBE IT WAS A SMALL
FAMILY CHILD CARE HOME TO HAVE
THE CAPACITY TO SERVE AFTER
EACH. STEP THROUGH A WAIVER I
WITH THE DEPARTMENT I WAS ABLE
TO INCREASE TO FOURTEEN. AS
WELL AS CENTERS IN THE
BACKSPACE AND SO WE HAVE WELL
OVER NINE HUNDRED. I PROGRAMS
IN THE POP UP CATEGORY AND
AGAIN THE LARGE MAJORITY OF
THOSE WERE THAT MORE THE
LICENSE PROGRAM EXPANSIONS. AND
SO ONE THING THAT WE'RE
COMMITTED TO DOING IT'S REALLY
PROVIDING SOME DIRECT TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE AND SUPPORT TO SEE
IF WE CAN'T STREAMLINED. AWARE
THAT CAPACITY X. EXPAND
CAPACITY CAN CONTINUE AND WE
CAN SUPPORT THAT BECOMING A
MORE PERMANENT SOLUTION SET TO
OFFER AT THE FAMILY'S GOING
FORWARD. ALSO FOR THOSE THAT
HAVE BEEN WORKED OUT FOR MY
FUTURE AND WHERE THAT'S
APPROPRIATE WE LOOKED AT ALSO
STREAMLINE THAT PROCESS TO GET
THEM LICENSE TO HAVE THAT
CAPACITY BUILT. I WOULD ALSO
JUST. ECHO BECAUSE COUPLE
THINGS THAT MISSED AND THAT
JUST OUTLINED RELATED TO REALLY
ACT. BE ABLE TO. PROGRAM ASKED
ARE EXT. BOAST CHANGES TO.
THEIR OWN AVAILABILITY IN THE
WORK FORCE AT BUT ALSO IN TERMS
OF THE CHILDREN THAT ARE COMING
INTO THEIR PROGRAMS. I'M IN THE
IN THE- CONDITIONS IN GUIDANCE
KEEP UP ALL OF THOSE PARTIES
THAT SAFE AND HEALTHY AND SO.
WHAT WE'RE LOOKING AT DOES NOT
NOT DAYS AND MAKING SURE AGAIN
THAT ACCESS IS CRITICAL THESE
ARE GOING TO BE THINGS THAT WE
NEED TO WE HAVE DONE AND THAT
WE NEED TO CONTINUE TO LOOK AT
GOING FORWARD- I THINK AGAIN
JUST TO EARLIER CONVERSATION.
AB THERE'S A LOT OF WORK AHEAD
OF US ALL IN TERMS OF AT THIS
RECOVERY AND- THINKING ABOUT
HOW WE ARE. MAKING THE
CONNECTION FOR FAMILIES REALLY
BUILDING AND PROVIDING
ADDITIONAL CAPACITY ACROSS THE
FIELD BUT ALSO. TAKING
ADVANTAGE OF THINGS LIKE
EXPANDED PAID FAMILY LEAVE AND-
OTHER WAYS THAT OUR CHILDREN
AND FAMILIES ARE SUPPORTED
ACROSS CALIFORNIA. THANK YOU.
OKAY THANK YOU- OF ALL START UP
WITH THIS A FEW QUESTIONS ON ON
THAT SO OBVIOUSLY WE WE'VE
ACTED ALREADY EARLY IN THE
BUDGET YEAR. TO ADDRESS EARLY
EDUCATION CHILD CARE AND THE
PANDEMIC WITH WITH FEDERAL
FUNDS. IN SO JUST THINKING
ABOUT WHAT THINGS THAT WE DID
RIGHT NOW IN THE CURRENT YEAR
THAT WE NEED TO BE THINKING
ABOUT- CONTINUING. IN THE
BUDGET YEAR AND BEYOND. SO
WOULD ANYBODY LIKE TO ADDRESS
THAT. YES THE KIDS HERE I WOULD
I WOULD JUST SAY A COUPLE OF
THOSE THINGS THAT I OUTLINED
AGAIN I THINK ARE REALLY
CRITICAL STILL LOOKING AT.
AGAIN THE WAYS. IN WHICH- MR
TRADERS ARE CONNECTING WITH
FAMILIES USING SOME REMOTE
OPPORTUNITIES TO LET TRAFFIC
SIGNATURES THOSE KINDS OF
THINGS- ALLOWED FOR- AGAIN AT A
FAST. HI GOING TO HAVE TO WAIT.
TO BECOME LICENSE OR EXPAND
CAPACITY- AND AGAIN LOOKING AT
SOME OF THE WAYS THAT WE
PROVIDED SUPPORT ADDITIONAL
SUPPORT TO PROGRAMS TO ENSURE
THAT THEY COULD. NOT REMAIN
OPEN. AND BE ABLE TO OPERATE
UNDER ADDITIONAL GUIDANCE. AND
IT IS THE THIRD NOVEL MARC AND
FROM THE DEPARTMENT OF THAT AD
THAT WE THINK IT'S ITS REALLY
IMPORTANT TO YOU CONTINUE WITH
THE FULL TERM LESS FOR THIS
NEXT YEAR. EXTEND BEING AT THE
MAXIM AND CERTIFICATE BRING
OTHER FISCAL YEAR AND WAITING
FAMILY FEES FOR ALL FAMILIES.
OKAY OUR AT THE NEXT I WANT TO
FOCUS ON. THE VIABILITY OF JUST
PROVIDERS IN THE FIRST PLACE
YOU CAN ISN'T MY SEVENTY YEAR
HAVING THESE HEARINGS AND-
WE'VE ALWAYS HEARD THAT EVEN
THE BEST OF TIMES OPERATING AND
OWNING A- CHILD CARE
BUSINESSES. IS TENUOUS AT BEST
CONSIDERING THIS PANDEMIC. IT'S
BEEN A DISASTER FOR- FOR SO
MANY. OF SMALL BUSINESSES AND
YOU KNOW NOT LOST UPON THAT
THAT SO MANY OF THEM ARE OWNED
BY WOMEN AND WOMEN OF COLOR. SO
CERTAINLY SOMETHING WE'VE SEEN-
FIRST HAND DURING THIS
PANDEMIC- I WANTED TO ASK C. D.
E. R. L. A- WE I'VE I WE'VE
SEEN COUNTLESS REPORTS AND A
LOT OF ANECDOTAL. REPORTS BUT
DO WE HAVE ANY SPECIFIC DATA.
ON THE NUMBER AND TYPE OF
PROVIDERS THAT HAVE CLOSED.
DURING THIS PANDEMIC EITHER
PERMANENTLY OR TEMPORARILY. AND
HOW DO WE HOW WE FEEL ABOUT
POTENTIALLY THEM COMING BACK OR
THEY CLOSE FOR GOOD. FOR THIS
IS. THE LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S
OFFICE- SO THAT THERE IS
CLOSURE DATA ON PAGE EIGHT OF
YOUR AGENDA- AND IT DOES HAVE
TEMPORARY CLOSE INCRIMINATE
CLOTHES ON THERE AND I AND I DO
BELIEVE MR JOHNSON AND DID
MENTION SOME MORE RECENT DATA
THIS DATA IS. AS OF OCTOBER
TWENTY TWENTY SHE SHE MENTIONED
HER TESTIMONY DATA I BELIEVE
THE FED BE WARY- DISH- SO YEAH
SHE SAID SHE DOES HAVE MORE
INFORMATION RECENT INFORMATION.
ON CLOSURES. SURE SO IN TERMS
OF- NUMBER AB LIKE TO KIND OF
REFERENCE YOUR AGENDA HERE AND
PROVIDE SOME UPDATED
INFORMATION AS AT THE END OF.
FEBRUARY IN TERMS OF THE NUMBER
OF OPEN AND OPERATING PROGRAMS-
WE HAVE A TOTAL AT THROUGH
FEBRUARY OF AB. THIRTY FOUR
THOUSAND PROGRAMS THAT'S-
TWENTY FOUR THOUSAND FAMILY
CHILD CARE HOMES AND TEN
THOUSAND CENTERS. AT
TEMPORARILY CLOSED WE HAVE AT
SEVEN THOUSAND PROGRAMS AND
THAT'S A TOTAL OF TWO HUNDRED
SIXTY SIX THOUSAND SLOTS
THROUGH FEBRUARY AND
PERMANENTLY CLOSED FROM MARCH
OF TWENTY TWENTY THREE FEBRUARY
OF TWENTY TWENTY ONE. IT'S A
TOTAL AB AT THIRTY THREE
HUNDRED NINETY SIX FACILITIES
THAT'S INCLUSIVE OF. ABOUT
TWENTY EIGHT HUNDRED FAMILY
CHILD CARE HOMES AND FIVE
HUNDRED AND FIFTY EIGHT CHILD
CARE CENTERS FOR A TOTAL OF
FIFTY TWO THOUSAND FIVE HUNDRED
AND EIGHTY ONE SLOTS AND AGAIN
AS I REFERENCED I WOULD
CERTAINLY HAVE HAD SOME NEW
CAPACITY. OVER THE COURSE OF
THE LAST YEAR AS WELL SO AND
THAT DOESN'T TAKE INTO ACCOUNT
THAT YOU CAPACITY IN THE
NUMBERS I JUST PROVIDED. OKAY
THAT'S THE PROBLEM OR QUESTION
ON THIS ON THE ON THE OF COURSE
SCHOOLS HAVE BEEN LARGELY
CLOSED UP UNTIL RECENTLY- YOU
KNOW IT'S BEEN THE ISSUE THAT
THEY'RE TRYING TO ADDRESS AND
MOST OF THESE SCHOOL SITE THAT
HAD CALIFORNIA STATE PRESCHOOL
PROGRAMS ON SITE CLOSED AS WELL
DURING COVER NINETEEN ART IS IT
IS IT FAIR TO SAY THAT THE
DIFFERENCE SCHOOL WAS CLOSED
ALMOST ALWAYS THE STATE
PRESCHOOL PROGRAM WAS CLOSED OR
NOT ALWAYS. HE SAID FIFTY THIRD
NEVER WORKING WITH THE
EDUCATION. SO WE WOULD STAY.
OFTEN BUT NOT ALWAYS AT THE
SCHOOL SITE WAS CLOSED THEN
THAT'S STATE PRESCHOOL PROGRAM
THAT WAS ON THE CAMPUS ALSO
WITH HAD TO CLOSE AND I WAS
OFTEN DUE TO OTHER SAFETY
ISSUES THAT THEY CAN'T WAS
THERE THEY DIDN'T HAVE OTHER
RESOURCES AND SUPPORT SYSTEMS
IN PLACE. M. AS WELL AS VARIOUS
THINGS WHERE THAT STAFF MAY NOT
ALSO BEEN IN THE SAME
COLLECTIVE BARGAINING UNIT AND
THAT SORT OF THING BUT OVERALL
MANY OF OUR PROGRAMS STATE OPEN
WITH ABOUT JUST OVER EIGHTEEN
HUNDRED TOTAL SITE. CURRENTLY
CLOSED AND ABOUT THIRTEEN UNDER
GOT THOSE ARE OPERATED. BY ONLY
AS BUT- OUR PROGRAMS THAT ARE
ALSO OPEN AND WE KNOW THE-
PROGRAMS ARE IN THE MIDST OF A-
THEY ALSO WERE OPERATING AND
DISTANCE LEARNING IF THEY WERE
PHYSICALLY CLOSED AND THEIR
FAMILIESWERE STILL GETTING
SOME SORT OF SERVICE THAT. EVEN
IF IT WASN'T IN PERSON. WE HAVE
HEARD THAT ANECDOTALLY AT LEAST
AND THAT WARMER PROGRAMS ARE RE
OPENING. WITH SCHOOLS REOPENING
AND WITH THE VACCINE
DISTRIBUTION INCREASING. OUR
PROGRAMS THAT HAVE REMAINED
OPEN THAT ONE IS THINGS THAT
THEY'VE REALLY STRUGGLED WITH
IS THAT IF. ONE OF THEIR STAFF
MEMBERS ARE COPAYS. FOR A
FAMILY DEAD THEY THEN WOULD
HAVE TO CLOSE DOWN THE PROGRAM.
IS DOWN TO CLASSROOMS AND THEN
GETTING THAT STUDENTS OR OTHER
TEACHING STAFF AND TO SUPPORT
IT WAS VERY CHALLENGING. SO
IT'S JUST BEEN AN OVERALL MIXED.
BAG ACROSS OUR FOR BROWN'S.
OKAY THANK YOU THAT'S CERTAINLY
SOMETHING THAT WE NEED TO
ADDRESS AS SCHOOLS REOPEN.
WORKING KEEP WORKING AT THE
SEPT THANK YOU OTHER QUESTIONS
ON ISSUE NUMBER TWO THIS AN
INFORMATIONAL ITEM AS WELL
BEFORE I GET TO THE BUDGET
PROPOSALS. SEMIRAMIDE AT. YEAH
I'D LOVE TO LOOK AT THIS FROM
THE BUSINESS PERSPECTIVE
ESPECIALLY SINCE WE KNOW THAT
TIME. FOR CHILD CARE PROVIDERS
AND PRESCHOOL PROVIDERS- TEND
TO BE WOMEN TEND TO BE WOMEN OF
COLOR AS WELL MINORITY WOMEN.
I'M TO THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE WAS THERE ANY
CONSIDERATION TO WAIVING THE
ANNUAL LICENSE FEE FOR CHILD
CARE PROVIDERS. THIS IS OUR
PARTNER I. WITH THE DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE- SO THAT WAS NOT A
PARTICULAR PART OF OUR VARIOUS
SCOPE IN NINETEEN PROPOSALS.
BUT WHAT I'D LIKE TO STRONGLY
URGE YOU KNOW SOME
CONSIDERATION THERE WE'VE
GIVEN- WE WAIVES FEES FOR OTHER
BUSINESSES AND PROFESSIONS AND
THIS IS AN INDUSTRY THAT WE
HAVE TO SUPPORT RIGHT NOW IN
THIS MOMENT SO I'D APPRECIATE
THAT CONSIDERATION AS WE MOVE
FORWARD AND- AND ARE BUDGET
DISCUSSIONS- TO LOOK A LITTLE
BIT MORE AT. ACTUALLY TO ASK
I'M NOT SURE WHO WOULD HAVE
THIS INFORMATION BUT- LAST
SUMMER THERE WAS A CHILD CARE
SURVEY- THAT HAD SOME REALLY
INTERESTING DATA IS WAS UP THE
MOST A RECENT BUILD SURVEY OF
HOW OUR INDUSTRY LOOKS IN AND
ANTICIPATES- BASING IT OR GET
THEM DURING THE PANDEMIC AND
MOVING OUT OF THIS KIND OF
BECAUSE ANYONE ELSE. THANK YOU
ASSEMBLY MEMBER KEVIN JOHNSON
DEPARTMENTS SOCIAL SERVICES A
COUPLE THINGS I ACTUALLY WANT
TO LET YOU KNOW WE WERE ABLE TO
WAY OUT LICENSING FEES FROM
APRIL THROUGH JUNE OF TWENTY
TWENTY SO JUST WANTED TO.
ENSURE THAT THAT COMPONENT BUT
THE- AT YOUR QUESTION AROUND
SERVING YES YOU HAVE A LOT OF.
BOTH ARE. OUT OF GOVERNMENT
ENTITIES DURING THE SERVING AS
WELL AS WHAT WE HAVE BEEN DOING
IT ACROSS ALL LICENSE PROGRAMS
AGAIN LICENSED FAMILY CHILD
CARE HOMES THE CENTERS- WE-
INSTITUTED WHAT'S CALLED OUR
EVERBRIDGE SYSTEM WHERE WE ARE.
ASKING FOR ANY PRETTY
SIMPLISTIC FONG AB MECHANISM.
FOR PROGRAMS TREE COURT AND
THAT NEEDS AB WOULD GET
TEMPORARY CLOSURES PERMANENT
CLOSURES IT'S THAT RAP. FORCE
THAT THEY'RE CLOSING
PERMANENTLY THEY HAVE TO NOTIFY
US IN SEPARATE WAYS SO WE HAVE
BEEN ABLE TO DO. AT SOME
INFORMATION SERVING AFTER THAT
MECHANISM OF COURSE WE'VE ALSO
BEEN ABLE TO DO. SOME REPORTING
RELATED TO CODE POSITIVITY FOR
BOTH AT THE CHILDREN IN CARE IN
THEIR HOUSEHOLDS AS WELL AS-
FOR THE WORK FORCE THAT'S
POSTED ON THE DEPARTMENT OF
SOCIAL SERVICES WEBSITE THAT
WE'VE BEEN ABLE TO MAINTAIN BUT
AGAIN. I WE HAVE BEEN FOCUSED
ON BOTH LOOKING AT CAPACITY.
AND HEALTH AND WELL BEING OF
THE PROGRAMS AND THAT NEEDS
WHICH ALLOWED US TO VERY VERY
QUICKLY BE ABLE TO. STAND UP
THINGS LIKE THE PORTER PORTAL
FOR FAMILIES TO KNOW WHICH
PROGRAMS WERE OPEN. ALSO BEEN
ABLE TO SUPPORT THE
DISTRIBUTION AB AT PERSONAL
PROTECTIVE EQUIPMENT OR PP. I
THINK THE FIELD WITH THE- LOCAL
COMMUNITY PARTNERS RESOURCE
REFERRAL AGENCIES AND OTHERS
SO. I'D NUMBER OF WAYS WE'VE
BEEN ENGAGING WITH THE WORK
FORCE OVER THE COURSE OF THE
LAST YEAR. AND TO CLARIFY THE
FEES THAT WERE WAVE AND APRIL
THROUGH JUNE WAS SOLD AS A
CHILD CARE PROVIDER A LICENSED
HEALTH CARE PROVIDER YOUR FEE
IS DUE ANNUALLY BASED ON WHEN
YOUR LICENSE. WAS APPROVED SO
IS IT ONLY LICENSES THAT WERE
DUE APRIL THROUGH. JUNE OF
TWENTY TWENTY THAT WERE WAIVED.
THAT'S CORRECT ALL TRIPLE CHECK
A CONFIRM BUT THAT THAT WOULD
BE. SO AGAIN AND- I'M THANKFUL
FOR THAT BUT WE REALLY NEED TO
SAKE TAKE A SERIOUS LOOK AT
EXPANDING THIS- AT ONE OF THE
MOST CRITICAL TIMES FOR
PROVIDERS. THANK YOU. THE
MEMBER ARRESTS. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR OF. I THINK WHEN
WHENEVER WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
THE- CHILD CARE I THINK WE HAVE
TO BEGIN BY SAYING THANK YOU TO
LAWS CHILD CARE PROVIDERS- THEY
HAVE. DONE SO MUCH ESPECIALLY
DURING THIS A GLOBAL PANDEMIC-
HAVE RISKED THEIR HEALTH THEIR
SAFETY. JUST TO CONTINUE
SERVING OUR CALIFORNIA FAMILIES
OUR CHILDREN- OFTENTIMES
PUTTING THEIR LIVES AT RISK-
SOME PEOPLE HAVE REFERRED TO
THEM AND I AGREE AS THE HEROES
ARE THE SHE ROSE- DURING THIS
PANDEMIC AND WE HAVE TO
RECOGNIZE THEM AS THE ESSENTIAL
WORKERS. THAT THEY ARE I. SO I
WANT TO BEGIN WITH THAT. WHEN I
READ ABOUT THE- CHILD CARE
CENTERS THAT HAVE CLOSED. WITH
THOSE OF CLOSE TEMPORARILY AND
THOSE THAT CLOSED PERMANENTLY
THERE ARE TWO ASPECTS OF THAT
OF COURSE THAT ARE OF GREAT
CONCERN ONE IS THE CHILDREN
THAT ARE NOT BEING CARED FOR
BUT THE OTHER IS THE BUSINESS
ASPECT THESE ARE ALL BASICALLY
SMALL BUSINESSES IN OUR
COMMUNITIES. OWNED AS MY
COLLEAGUE HAS INDICATED BUT
USUALLY BY WOMEN AND ALMOST
ALWAYS BY WOMEN OF COLOR. SO
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT SMALL
BUSINESSES THAT ARE GOING UNDER
AND I THINK THAT WE NEED TO BE
EVEN MORE CONCERNED. THAN WE
HAVE BEEN THE TEMPORARY
CLOSURES I DON'T KNOW IF YOU
GAVE THE NUMBERS ON THOSE I DID
NOTE THAT THE PERMANENT
CLOSURES AS OF NOW OR HIGHER
THAN ARE LISTED ON PAGE EIGHT.
OF. THE INFORMATION THAT YOU
THERE HAD BEEN PER. SO IT BEEN
THREE THOUSAND THREE. IT A
SLUSH NOW WE UP TO TWO THOUSAND
FIVE AND EIGHTY. PER CLOSED IS
THAT AT IS A CORRECT. YES
ASSEMBLY MEMBER THAT'S CORRECT
IN TERMS OF PERMANENT CLOSURES
THAT'S THAT THE TOTAL CAPACITY
THAT COULD HAVE BEEN SERVED.
OVER THE THREE THOUSAND THREE
HUNDRED NINETY SIX THE SAUDIS
THAT CLOSED OVER THE COURSE OF
THAT TIME PERIOD. Q. AND ON THE
TEMPORARY CLOSURES COULD YOU
GIVE US THE UPDATED NUMBERS.
CERTAINLY A TEMPORARY CLOSURES
AT THROUGH FEBRUARY AT SEVEN
THOUSAND NINETY FOUR FACILITIES
IN YEAH AND THAT THAT'S ABOUT
TWENTY FIVE HUNDRED A FAMILY
CHILD CARE HOMES IN FORTY FIVE
HUNDRED CHECK YOUR CENTERS.
TOTAL OF TWO HUNDRED AND
660-002-0030 THREE AT TOTAL
CAPACITY OR SLOTS. SO THAT IF
THIS IS CORRECT THEN THAT MEANS
THAT THOSE THAT WERE
TEMPORARILY CLOSED BEFORE HAVE
NOW MOVED TO THE PERMANENTLY
CLOSED. THERE ARE ACTUALLY TWO
DISCREET SEX SO THE PERMANENTLY
CLOSE PROBE AT PROGRAMS WOULD
BE ALL ALL WRAPPED UP THERE IN
THE TEMPORARILY CLOSER TO AS OF
FEBRUARY PROGRAMS THAT ARE
STILL. NOT INDICATING TO
LICENSING THAT THEY'RE PLANNING
TO CLOSE BUT THEY ARE CURRENTLY
NOT SERVING CHILDREN SO TO TWO
DISTINCT GROUPS OKAY BECAUSE IT
TEMPORARILY CLOSED WENT FROM
EIGHT THOUSAND DOWN TO SEVEN
THOUSAND. WHERE IS THE
PERMANENTLY CLOSED WENT FROM.
TWENTY ONE HUNDRED TO THIRTY
THREE HUNDRED. SO SOME OF THE
TEMPORARY CLOSE COULD HAVE
OPENS AND SO THEY WOULD SHOW UP
IN THE OPENING OPENS AT GROUP.
VERY GOOD VERY GOOD AND YOU YOU
TALKED ABOUT IT AT THAT. FONG
QUESTIONING FROM THE CHAIR
ABOUT THE DATA- CAN YOU SHARE
WITH US HOW THIS IS GOING TO
IMPACT THE RE OPENING OF OUR
STATE AND OF OUR ECONOMY. AND
MORE IMPORTANTLY WHAT CAN WE DO
AS A STATE TO HELP THESE CHILD
CARE FACILITIES- BE PART OF THE
RE OPENING OF THE STATE AND THE
ECONOMY. THANK YOU FOR VERY
MUCH FOR THE QUESTION ASSEMBLY
MEMBER ABSOLUTELY AT THAT THE-
IMPORTANCE- CHILD CARE AND
DEVELOPMENT PROGRAMS THE
SERVICES IN TERMS OF WHAT THAT
MEANS FOR THE ECONOMY IN THE
WORK FORCE THERE ABSOLUTELY
TIED. TOGETHER AND REALLY DO
SUPPORT FAMILIES TO ENGAGE IN
THE WORK FORCE I IN A DIFFERENT
WAY SO WE FULLY SUPPORTS AND
PRIORITIZE THAT AS A AS A AS A
CONCEPT OF HOW WE- WORK
TOGETHER AND SUPPORT FAMILIES.
I WE HAVE DONE A LOT AS HAS
BEEN OUTLINED TODAY OVER THE
COURSE OF THE YEAR AFFECTED TO
THE POINT THAT YOU'RE MAKING IN
THERE AND THE CRITICAL IMPACT
ABOUT THIS SCANDAL HAS HAD ON
THE SYSTEM WE WILL HAVE MUCH
MORE TO DO. SO IT'S A I WOULD
SAY THAT IS A BOTH A THE
ENGAGEMENT OF THE WORK FORCE
THAT FAMILIES IN TERMS OF THE
SOLUTION ING AND WAYS IN WHICH
WE CREATE NEW POLICY PROGRAMS
AND INVESTMENTS IS THAT
CERTAINLY A COMMITMENT OF OURS.
I WE WILL HAVE TO BOTH LOOK AT
RECRUITMENT- HAVE NEW PROGRAMS
AT NEW CAPACITY BEING BUILT
BASED ON THE NUMBERS THAT I
JUST PROVIDED BUT ALSO TRULY
SUPPORTING OF THOSE THAT ARE
OPEN TODAY WHO ARE IN NEED OF
THAT ADDITIONAL SUPPORT AS AS
BEEN OUTLINES. AT THIS
AFTERNOON SO IT WILL BE A MULTI
PRONGED SOLUTION THAT WILL NEED
TO OUT WORK THROUGH THE SUPPORT
HAVING THE FULL ARRAY INTO FIVE
TO THE FAMILY'S NEEDS I THINK
AGAIN WOULD ALSO JUST NOTE THAT
THINGS LIKE PAID FAMILY LEAVE
AND DIFFERENT OPPORTUNITIES AND
OPTIONS. AND THAT FAMILIES CAN
HAVE ARE PART OF THAT THAT
SCHOOL ARRAY. OF SOLUTIONS THAT
WE NEED TO LOOK TO. AND JUST AS
IT I MAY CHAIR YES- THE- WENT
WHEN- IT THE IF YOU'RE IN A-
AND YOUR- START TO LAY. YOU
OFTENTIMES AN EXIT INTERVIEW SO
THAT YOU CAN EVALUATE WHAT IT
IS IT'S WRONG AND WHAT WE CAN
DO TO IMPROVE. IN THOSE THAT
HAVE PERMANENTLY CLOSED. IS
THERE SUCH A SURVEY BEING DONE
TO DETERMINE IF THEY ARE REALLY
PERMANENTLY CLOSED BECAUSE WHAT
WE'RE DOING IS THAT WE ARE.
LOSING THIS EXPERIENCE- FROM
THESE FROM THE THESE WORKERS
THESE FACILITIES. IT'S GOING TO
BE LOST UNLESS WE'RE ABLE TO AS
YOU SAYING GAUGE THEM AND- AND
IT CHANGE THE WORK FORCE. IN
SUCH A WAY THAT WE WEAKENED RE
HIRE THE MORE OR HELP THEM TO
REOPEN IS THERE SUCH A THING AS
AN EXIT INTERVIEW OR SOMETHING
OF THE SORT. IT'S A GREAT A
GREAT POINT ASSEMBLY MEMBER
THAT'S SOMETHING WE CAN
CERTAINLY LOOK AT A CLOSURE
INFORMATION IS A DIFFERENT
MECHANISM THAT THAT'S
COMMUNICATED TO OUR LICENSING
SERVER PROGRAM IS ESSENTIALLY
SAYING I'M NO LONGER GOING TO
BE A LICENSE OPERATOR I DON'T
WANT TO BE PART OF THE LISTING
ETCETERA. I HAD SOME WORK AT
PERMANENT COMPONENT THAT
DISTANCE CERTAINLY SOMETHING WE
COULD LOOK AT AS TO THE REASONS
WHY. EARLY ON IN THE PANDEMIC
WHEN WE HAD MANY PROGRAMS THAT
WERE IN THE TEMPORARY CLOSURE.
GROUP AGAIN AS WE HAD BEAT SO
OF COURSE WE HAVE OUR
PARTICULAR HEALTHCARE
WORKFORCE. WHO ARE ESSENTIAL
WORKERS THEY NEEDED CHILD CARE
SO THAT WAS THE FLEXIBILITY WE
WERE ABLE TO DO WITH THE POP
UPS BUT WE WERE ALSO WORKING TO
PARE. ABOUT EARLY LEARNING
PROFESSIONAL WHO WAS IN A
TEMPORARY CLOSE AT SITUATION
WITH. OTHER TEMPORARILY OPENS
AT CAPACITY THAT WE CREATED SO.
THAT FULLY APPRECIATE THE
COMMENT THAT ONE THAT I RETAIN.
MEMBERS OF THIS WORK FORCE WHO
ARE JUST TREMENDOUSLY VALUABLE
AND IMPORTANT ASTON IN THE
DEVELOPMENTAL TRAJECTORY OF OUR
CHILDREN- AND WE HAVE TO FIND
WAYS TO KEEP TRACK OF PASSED TO
BE- WITHIN OUR WITHIN OUR STATE
SO- CERTAINLY CAN FOLLOW UP ON.
ON SOME OPPORTUNITIES TO GET
MORE DATA AROUND. THE PROGRAMS
THAT ARE CLOSING IN THE REASONS
WHY. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
MISTER. OKAY THANK YOU. THANK
YOU LISTS NOW PROCEED WITH THE
NEXT ISSUE. GOOD AFTERNOON
COMMITTEE MEMBERS CARLOS ARE
YOU LETTER THAT THE DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE FIVE SO I JUST HAVE
A BRIEF OVERVIEW SENSE TWENTY
NINETEEN THE STATE HAS BEEN
BETH APPROXIMATELY FOUR HUNDRED
MILLION ON GOING TO EXPAND IN
SUPPORT NEARLY AT YOUR AGE AND
THEN CHILD CARE SECTOR. YEAH
THESE INVESTMENTS INCLUDE
FUNDING FOR ONGOING CHILD CARE
SLOTS SUPPORTING TWELVE MONTH
ELIGIBILITY IN THE CAL WORKS
CHILD CARE PROGRAMS AND
ELIMINATING PRO. THIRTY
NEGATIVE FROM THE CHEST MEANT.
THE STATE HAS ALSO. SEVERAL ONE
TIME INVESTMENT INCLUDING THE
BARGAINING FOR CHILD CARE
PROVIDERS THE MASTER PLANNED
FOR EARLY LEARNING AND CARE AS
WE SPOKE ABOUT EARLIER
SEPARATELY. THE POLICY COUNCIL
AND THE TRANSITION OF PROGRAMS
FROM THE DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION. TO THE DEPARTMENT OF
SOCIAL SERVICES. MOST RECENTLY
THE STATE HAS ALLOCATED NEARLY
FIVE HUNDRED MILLION FEDERAL
FUNDS TO HELP REDUCE LONG TERM
LOSSES TO THE CHANNEL CHILD.
CARE SYSTEM AS A RESULT OF THAT
OKAY NINETEEN PANDEMIC THE
TWENTY TWENTY BUDGET ACT. THAT
SHIFTED NEW ARE. IN THE CHILD
CARE PROGRAMS FROM C. D. E. S.
S. IS EFFECTIVE JULY FIRST- IN
THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET TWENTY
TWENTY ONE THE PROPOSAL ARE
SAFE FOR STATE OPERATIONS
THIRTY THREE POINT FOUR MILLION.
FOUR POINT NINE. IN GENERAL
FUND AND A HUNDRED EIGHTY FIVE
POINT SEVEN POSITIONS FROM CD
TO BE ACCESS TO ADMINISTER THE
CHILD CARE PROGRAMS FOR THEIR
THREE ONE BILLION OR ONE POINT
THREE BILLION GENERAL FUND WILL
BE SHIFTED TO SUPPORT PROGRAMS
FOR LOCAL ASSISTANCE.
TRANSACTION TO DSS WILL PROMOTE
A HIGH QUALITY AFFORDABLE ONE
UNIFIED EARLY CHILD. CARE
SYSTEM. AND MAXIMIZE E. R.
INTEGRATION FOR EARLY LEARNING
AND CHILD CARE PROGRAMS. AT
THIS CONCLUDES MY COMMENTS
HAPPY TO TAKE ANY QUESTIONS
THANK YOU. OKAY THANK YOU L. L.
THERE WERE L. A- WE DON'T HAVE
ANY COMMENTS FOR THIS ISSUE BUT
WERE AVAILABLE FOR QUESTIONS.
THANK YOU SEE THE E. MISTER
CHAIR MEMBERS THEY'RE NOT
AMERICAN DEPUTY SUPERINTENDENT
AT THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION ON BEHALF OF STATE
SUPERINTENDENT OF PUBLIC
INSTRUCTION TEMPERAMENT THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET ALLOCATES A
TOTAL OF FOUR POINT FOUR
BILLION TO EARLY LEARNING AND
CARE PROGRAMS ACROSS CD AND CDS
THAT. WELL THERE IS A DECREASE
IN THE TOTAL BUDGET AMOUNT FROM
LAST YEAR DUE TO THE REMOVAL OF
ONE TEN FEDERAL FUNDS WE
APPRECIATE THE ADDITIONAL ONE
HUNDRED AND EIGHTY NINE MILLION
INVESTMENT IN CURRENT GOING
STATE SOURCE THAT SPECIFICALLY
WE APPRECIATE THE ADDITIONAL
TWENTY ONE POINT FOUR MILLION
IN THE CURRENT YEAR PROP SIXTY
FOUR PLANS FOR A PEACE STYLE.
AND THE ADDITIONAL FORTY FOUR
MILLION AND PROP SIXTY FOUR FOR
ADDITIONAL. EIGHTY SPOTS IN THE
PROJECT YEAR. WELL WE ALL A
PRETTY. RECEIVING A
COLLABORATIVE PROGRAMS WE
RECOGNIZE THAT OUR EARLY
LEARNING PROGRAMS DID NOT
RECEIVE A CALL LAST YEAR. IN
LIGHT OF THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSAL AROUND KEY TWELVE. AS
WELL AS HOW MUCH ARE PROGRAMS
ARE STRUGGLING WHAT AT THE
LEGISLATURE TO ALSO ALLOCATE
THE SEEM COLLABORATIVE EARLY
LEARNING CARE AND KEEP TWELVE.
WE WOULD ALSO LIKE TO KNOW THATWE BELIEVE WE HAVE SUFFICIENT
RESOURCES AND CAL WORKS YOU
JUST YOU AND THREE. BUT ARE
HAPPY TO GO DEEPER INTO THAT IF
IT'S HELPFUL. AND PER PRESCHOOL
AS WE MOVE FORWARD THROUGH THIS
BUDGET PROCESS THINK ABOUT THE
FUTURE FISCAL PROGRAMS. AND HOW
TO BEST SUPPORT THEM WE ARE
COMMITTED TO BRINGING BOARD
MASTER PLAN PIECES TO INFORM
THE FUTURE OF OUR PROGRAMS AND
ENSURES NEW TRANSITIONS. RESULT
IN TTK AND K. SUPPORT FRANKLY
STEP IN BILINGUAL PROGRAMS AND
STRONGER ALIGNMENT. THREE K.
THROUGH THIRD GRADE TO HELP
SUSTAIN EARLY INTERVENTION
SUPPORT. ALSO AS WE'VE
MENTIONED IN PREVIOUS HEARINGS.
WE THINK THERE ARE KEY
OPPORTUNITIES TO TAKE BUT THE
T. K. PROPOSALS IN THE PROJECT
TO SUPPORT THE GOALS OF THE
MASTER PLAN AROUND THAT P.
THREE ALIGNMENT. FOR EXAMPLE
OPENING UP THE PROFESSIONAL
DEVELOPMENT GRANT TO THE
CALIFORNIA STATE THE PROGRAM AS.
WELL AS FIFTY K. AND K. ONE
CRITICAL PIECE THAT WILL NEED
ADDRESS THE STATE. TO KEEP
CURRENCY A THE PEACE FROM GOING
OUT BUSINESS. AND SUPPORT THE
GOALS THE MASTER AND IS ADDRESS
THIS FTP GREAT WHICH IS BEHIND
THE T. K. RIGHT. AS WELL AS
BEHIND THE AVERAGE. RMR
REGIONAL MARKET RATES ARE
CAPTURE BASED PROGRAMS. WE'LL
BE TALKING ABOUT THIS MORNING
ANOTHER PANEL. THANK CHEN BUT
CHáVEZ IT'S ABOUT FOUR
THOUSAND LAST. FOR CSU TEAM
REIMBURSEMENT AS IT IS. FOR A
DATABASE PROGRAM. WITHOUT
HIGHER RATES ARE PART WILL
STRUGGLE TO HELP THE STATE MEET
THE GOALS OF THE MATH PLAN.
STRUGGLE TO MEET CONTRACT
REQUIREMENTS IN STRUGGLE TO PAY
QUALIFIED TEACHERS. ESPECIALLY
IN LIGHT OF THE ADDITIONAL
CHALLENGES HAS AYE QUEBEC.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU SO MUCH
AND I'M HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS YOU MIGHT. OKAY THANK
YOU. THANKS BAKER. THANK HAS
ONE MORE. GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR
JENNIFER CHOI WITH THE
DEPARTMENT SOCIAL SERVICES
NOTHING WE NEED TO ADD AT THIS
TIME BUT HAPPY TO HELP ITS
RAINY. THANK YOU. OKAY THANK
YOU I'M SURE A FEW QUESTIONS SO
OF QUESTION NUMBER ONE WE'VE
HEARD THIS LOUD AND CLEAR FROM
OUR- FOR MARK COMMUNITY
COLLEGES AND ALSO FROM OUR
PROVIDERS FOR EASY AS FAR AS
THE COLAB AND- LACK OF A OF AN
EQUITABLE COLOR BETWEEN OUR K.
TWELVE DISTRICTS WITH L. C. F.
F. AND- AND EARLY THERE ARE.
HARD OUR YOUNGEST LEARNERS WHAT
YOU CALLED EARLIER ASSEMBLY
MEMBER VITAS LITTLEST. LITTLEST
LEARNERS AT THE NEW THAT'S A
NEW WORD FOR THE DAY- AND SO I
MEAN CLEARLY THAT THAT THE COST
OF ELECTRICITY AND RENT AND
STAFFING AND YOU KNOW EVEN
STUFF LIKE MILK AND SO FORTH
COSTS THE SAME EVEN IF YOU'RE
A- COMMUNITY COLLEGE- AT. THAT
INTENSITY OR AN EARLY
EDUCATION- PROVIDER OR SCHOOL
DISTRICT AND WE HAVE THESE TWO
COLA SO. WHAT IS THE RATIONALE
FROM DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
ABOUT THIS AND DO YOU DO WE ARE
GOING HOLDING HELP SAID THEY'LL
BE AN ADJUSTMENT. IN THE MAY
REVISE ABOUT THIS. THIS IS
SERRA BURNER THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE ALSO I WOULD JUST NOTE
THAT WE DID IMPLEMENT IN THE
BUDGET YEAR A ONE POINT 5% COAL
FOR CHILD CARE PROGRAMS- TO THE
EXTENT THAT THE SUPER COOL
APPLIED TO- ELEAZAR NOT TO THE
CHILD CARE PROGRAMS IT'S NOT
SOMETHING THAT. IS PART OF OUR
PROPOSAL AT THIS TIME BUT WE'LL
CERTAINLY TAKE IT BACK WITH US
FOR FURTHER CONSIDERATION WE DO
RECOGNIZE THAT THE COST OF
DOING BUSINESS THIS YEAR FOR
CHILD CARE PROVIDERS IS. IS
MUCH HIGHER THAN IT HAS BEEN TO
THE KOBE NINETEEN PANDEMIC A
LOT OF THESE FEDERAL FUNDS HAVE
BEEN USED TO ADDRESS POLICIES
AND DIRECT RELATION TO THE
COSTS THAT PROVIDERS ARE
FACING- SO WE CERTAINLY HEAR
YOUR CONCERNS AND WILL
CERTAINLY TAKEN INTO
CONSIDERATION. OKAY AND THEN
HOW ABOUT- THE- POTENTIAL
RESTORATION OF THE CUTS THAT
WERE MADE. LAST YEAR FOR CHILD
CARE INFRASTRUCTURE AND
CALIFORNIA STATE PRESCHOOL
PROGRAM EXPANSION AND
FACILITIES PROFESSIONAL ELEMENT.
CERTAINLY SO THOSE PARTICULAR
PROGRAMS AND IT WAS WORKFORCE
INFRASTRUCTURE AND EXPANSION OF
SLOTS FOR THE CALIFORNIA STATE
PRESCHOOL PROGRAM WHICH WAS
SWEPT- DUE TO THE BUDGET
REDUCTIONS- AS A RESULT OF THE
COCA NINETEEN PANDEMIC SO AT
THIS POINT WE'RE NOT PROPOSING
TO BRING THOSE PROGRAMS BACK
THE INTENTION BEHIND THOSE
PROGRAMS THOUGH TO EXPAND
OFFERINGS EXPAND EDUCATIONAL
OPPORTUNITIES FOR RULED A
pREMAINS IT'S STILL A PRIORITY
OF THE ADMINISTRATION- BASED ON
THE RESEARCH THAT CAME OUT THE
MASTER PLAN IT'S TAKING A
DIFFERENT SHAPE IN THE
TRANSITIONAL KINDERGARTEN
PROPOSALS THAT WE HAVE- BUT AT
THIS POINT THOSE PROGRAMS WERE
NOT PROPOSING TO. REINSTATE
FUNDING I GET THAT LET ME JUST
RESPECTFULLY PUSHED BACK ON
THIS AND WE'RE ON THE SAME PAGE
HERE WE BOTH WENT TO EXPAND
UNIVERSAL PRESCHOOL ACCESS
THROUGH T. K. BUT IN IN IN
DOING THAT TWO OF THE NEEDS OUT
OF THE GECKO OUR- FACILITIES
AND PROFESSIONAL DEVELOPMENT
SO. IT SEEMS THAT THESE THINGS
GO HAND IN HAND AND SINCE WE
DON'T HAVE THE BUDGET WELLS
LIKE WE DID- A YEAR AGO LAST
LAST SPRING NOR HAVE WE HAD IN
THE FALL IT SEEMS THAT THESE
THAT THESE TWO ISSUES ARE RIGHT
FOR TAKING A LOOK AND- AND
REINSTITUTING THEM AS
PRIORITIES IN THE STATE BUDGET
SO- AND THEN AS FAR. AS THE-
THE R. RATE INCREASES ARE ARE I
GUESS WE CAN WE'LL TALK ABOUT
THAT FROM THE PRACTICAL LEVEL
FROM THE PROVIDERS- IN A SECOND
BUT HERE WE HAVE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE AND SO. WHAT'S YOUR
WHAT'S YOUR PERSPECTIVE ON THAT
DO YOU THINK THE HAVE ANY
ACTION NOW YOU SAID YOU'RE-
TAKING A LITTLE BIT ABOUT.
THROUGH NEGOTIATIONS CHRIS
PERRY SAID. BUT NOT ALL
INDIVIDUALS. WHO BENEFIT FROM
INCREASED RATES. ARE PART OF
THE COLLECTIVE BARGAINING
PROCESS SOME GROUPS ARE PART OF
THAT SO- WHAT'S THE COMMITMENT
FROM THE ADMINISTRATION TO.
INCREASING RATES THE ARMAR SMR.
SO WE CAN MAKE THESE PROGRAMS
VIABLE AND ENSURE THAT WE DON'T
PAY THAT. WORKERS FAST FOOD
WAGES WHO ARE TAKE CARE OF OUR
LITTLEST KIDS. ON THE SERVER
NOW WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE SO I WOULD JUST NOTE
THAT ON TO THE EXTENT THAT WE
HAVE A CONVERSATION ABOUT RACE
IN THE FUTURE WE CERTAINLY
UNDERSTAND THAT- SUSTAINABLE
RATES AS A BENEFIT TO THE
FIELD- WE WILL CERTAINLY LOOK
TO CONVERSATIONS ABOUT THAT
KNOWING THAT AS WE- WORK TO
TRANSFORM THE SYSTEM THERE'S
GOING TO BE A LOT OF DIFFERENT
EFFECTS ON DIFFERENT PROGRAMS
AS WE'VE TALKED ABOUT HERE.
ALREADY IN THIS HEARING WITH
TRANSITIONAL KINDERGARTEN AND
STATE PRESCHOOL- WE KNOW THAT
THERE'S GOING TO BE CHANGES ON
THAT FRONT SO I WILL LOOK
FORWARD TO A CONVERSATION ON
THAT IT'S NOT A PARTICULAR PART
OF OUR GOVERNOR'S BUDGET
PROPOSALS AND I WILL HIT IT OFF
TO OUR DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL
SERVICES COLLEAGUES IF THEY-
WANT TO COMMENT FURTHER ON THAT.
I DON'T HAVE ANYTHING TO ADD.
OKAY THANK YOU. FURTHER
QUESTIONS OUR CONSUMERISM.
THANK YOU MISTER AT MY QUESTION
IS HOW LONG WILL IT TAKE TO GET
THE STIPENDS WHICH WERE
INCLUDED IN THE TWENTY TWENTY
ONE EARLY ACTION BUDGET PACKAGE
INTO THE HANDS OF OUR CHILD
CARE PROVIDERS. THAT CD. YET SO
LET'S DIRECT THAT TO C. D. E.
THANK YOU FOR THAT QUESTION
THAT I THINK I'D MENTIONED THAT
A LITTLE BIT IN ONE OF MY
CHANNELS ALREADY BUT GOING BACK
TO THAT IT AND WE'VE BEEN
WORKING WITH DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE AS WELL AS THE STATE
COMPTROLLER'S OFFICE. SAID THAT
WERE READY TO GO WE'VE HAD
STATEMENT ALLOCATIONS FOR
ABOUT. JUST OVER A THOUSAND ONE
HUNDRED EIGHTY CONTRACTS AND
SEVEN HUNDRED HUNDRED FOURTEEN
CONTRACTORS SO WE'VE COMPLETED
THAT PORTION. WORK PROVIDING IT
TO THE STATE COMPTROLLER'S
OFFICE THEY'LL TAKE ABOUT TWO
WEEKS ONE WHICH I'M NOT BUT
IT'S ONE OF THOSE THINGS WHERE
WE HAVE TO MANUALLY ENTER EACH
OF THE DATA FOR THE SEVEN
HUNDRED AND FOURTEEN STATEMENT
IN DEFENSE STYLE. SO THAT'S
WHERE WE ARE STATE
COMPTROLLER'S OFFICE WILL GET
IT AND THOSE PAYMENTS ACTUALLY
GO TO THE CONTRACTORS AND THEN
AFTER THE CONTRACTORS GET IT
GETS IN THE HANDS OF THE
PROVIDERS. SO WE'RE THINKING
THAT THIS CONTRACT- THAT'LL
TAKE ABOUT I WOULD SAY THREE TO
FOUR MORE. WEEKS TO GET THAT
OUT TO THE FIELDS. SO WE'RE
LOOKING BASICALLY AT ANOTHER
MONTH. SO OR SAYING.
COMPTROLLER'S OFFICE TAKES A
MINIMUM OF TWO WEEKS AND THAT'S
ON OUR EXPEDITED TIMELINE WITH
THEM. M. THAT GOES TO THE
CONTRACTO SO BEFORE THE CHILD
CARE PROVIDER RECEIVES IT
THAT'S GOING TO BE AN
ADDITIONAL PERIOD OF TIME IS
THAT RIGHT. THAT'S RIGHT AND
THAT'S AND WE'RE STILL WORKING
AT THE STATE COMPTROLLER'S
OFFICE FOR THEM TO BE OF THE
FACT THAT THAT WE CAN ACTUALLY
GET THE FUNDS OVER TO THEM. AND
I'M SURE THAT YOU YOU WOULD
AGREE WITH ME THAT WE'VE WE'VE
ALREADY LOST 30% OF OUR CHILD
CARE CAPACITY. THROUGHOUT THE
STATE AND IT IS CRITICAL THAT
pOUR CHILD CARE PROVIDERS
RECEIVED THIS PROMISED.
IMMEDIATELY AS SOON AS POSSIBLE
AND SO WHATEVER NEEDS TO BE
DONE. TO GET THAT EXPEDITED AND
I AM CERTAIN THAT YOU ARE
WORKING ON IT BUT I JUST WANTED
TO. ELEVATE THE ISSUE BECAUSE
WE WE'VE ASKED SO MUCH OF THEM.
AND IT WE NOW NEED TO GET THE
FUNDING THAT HAS BEEN PROMISED
TO THEM THANK YOU. THANK YOU. I
JUST MAY ASK QUICKLY I JUST
WANT TO KNOW- THE DEPARTMENT OF
SOCIAL SERVICES AGAIN CHEN
TORIA THE PARCHMENT OF SOCIAL
SERVICES NEAREST MINISTERING
BEST I CAN FOR STAGE ONE AT A
CAGR. PROGRAMS AND CERTAINLY
SHARE YOUR URGENCY AND-ART
EDUCATION ART WORK. HOURS IT'S
POSSIBLE. THE ADMINISTRATION IS
SLIGHTLY DIFFERENT FOR THE
STAGE ONE PROGRAM AND WE ARE IN
THE MEETING I HAVE THE RECEIPT
AT THE STATE AND- THE SOMETIME
IN APRIL. AT THE COMMUNITY
COLLEGE DISTRICT CHALFORD
COMMITTEE COLLEGE FOUNDATION
IS- ACTUALLY- ADMINISTERING
THAT DEMANDS- ON OUR BEHALF OR
THAT EACH ONE ADMINISTRATION
JUST WANTED TO ADD THAT EXTRA
PIZZA FOR UNIQUE AND SHARE
YOUR- SENSE OF URGENCY WHAT
WE'RE GETTING. THOSE ON ABOUT
THE- THANK. OKAY THANK YOU SO
BY US IN REGARD TO CAO- GIVE
THE DEATH IMPACTS WILL BE NINE
HI HAD ON LOW WAGE EARNERS IN
HIGH RATES OF AND LYFT WHY ARE
WE FOR A SAVE OF A FOURTEEN
MILLION AND THE COW WORKS CHILD
CARE PROGRAMS. I BELIEVE THE
DEPARTMENTS. OF SOCIAL SERVICES
MY HAVE YOU ADDRESS DEPARTED
FINANCER DFI EITHER EITHER ONE
EITHER ONE. WHOEVER ANSWERED.
AB I CAN GET STARTED AND THEN
IF MISPERTON WANTS TO ADD
ANYTHING APARTMENT OF FINANCES
PERSPECTIVE THAT WHILE I'M
THERE'S A FEW THINGS GOING ON I
THINK WHEN IT'S IMPORTANT TO
NOTE THAT THE OVERALL ESTIMATES
ARE WORKS HE SPOKE AT ARE
ACTUALLY TRENDING LOWER THAN WE
HAD ORIGINALLY ANTICIPATED I'M
NOT JUST FOR CHILD CARE BUT FOR
THE CALVET RAM AS A WAR-
SOMETHING THAT MAY BE DUE TO
THE STIMULUS PAYMENTS AND THE
UNEMPLOYMENT PAYMENTS THAT HAVE
STATE DOCKS AND WE NEED- BUT WE
HAVE BEEN INVESTIGATING. THAT
TREND- AS WELL AND SO THAT'S
ONE THING ANOTHER THING IS THAT
THERE ARE SOME CHANGES BETWEEN
THE TRANSITION BACK WORKERS IN
MACAU WORK STAGES PROGRAM AS
MANY OF. YOU MAY KNOW THERE ARE
THE THREE STAGES. STAGE ONE THE
END. STAGE EVERY SEAT CHILD AND
THEN WHAT'S A OF DEEMED STABLE.
THEY TRANSITION TO STAGE THE
RULES SO SOME RECENT POLICY
CHANGES INCLUDING B. AND MEDIA.
INTEREST ELIGIBILITY- HAVE
CHANGED HOW LONG FAMILIES ARE
STAYING IN STAGE ONE. SOME
COUNTIES HAVE ALSO CHANGED
THEIR DEFINITIONS OF STABLE
WHICH HAS RETAIN SOME FAMILIES
LONGER IN SPEECH FORM. IN ORDER
TO TRY TO DETERMINE THAT ASPECT
AND HOW MUCH THAT IS
CONTRIBUTING TO THE STAGE TO
SHOWCASE WILL CHANGES WE HAVE
ACTUALLY JUST RECENTLY RELEASED
A SURVEY- AND WE ARE EXPECTING
THE RESULTS OF THAT SURVEY
NEEDS TO INFORM US AND WE
SHOULD HAVE SOME ADDITIONAL
INFORMATION THAT WE CAN SHARE.
BY THE END OF MARCH SO JUST
WANT TO PROVIDE THAT CONTEXT-
IN CASE THAT IS HELPFUL STAR
AND THEN IF THIS. PERSON HAS
ANYTHING SHE WANTS TO ADD. SO
LET HER ADDED. AFTERNOON CARL
SAGAN AT THE OF. WE ANTICIPATE
THERE WILL BE STAGE TWO STAVING
AND STATE THREE D. SPACE ON THE
MOST RECENT AVAILABLE LOS TWO
AS CONTINUE TO DECREASE SENSE
TWENTY NINETEEN STAGE THREE HAS
CONTINUED TO INCREASE FOR THE
LAST THREE FISCAL YEARS WE
BELIEVE WE HAVE BUDGETED TO
COVER STAGE THREE COSTS. THANK
YOU FOR. AND THEN- TWO. M. IN
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE L. A. L.
IS. DEPARTMENT EDUCATION AND
SOCIAL SERVICES WOULD YOU
RECOMMEND THAT WE EXPAND
ACCESS- TIED TO INCOME AND
EARLY INTERVENTION SUPPORT FOR
CAO WORKS. TO ALSO INCLUDE
CHILDREN THAT ARE ENGLISH
LEARNERS THAT THEY ALSO RECEIVE
PRIORITY AND THE WAY THESE
PROPELLERS PROGRAMS OUR ACTS-
ACCESS. TO HELLO- COURTESY
LETTER DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE-
TO THE EXTENT THAT THE PRIORITY
FOR THE LAST- LEGISLATURE WHILE
WE'RE HAPPY TO HAVE FURTHER
CONVERSATIONS WITH YOUR STAFF
THANK YOU. AND THE L. L. HAVE
AN OPINION ON- WHETHER IT WOULD
BE BENEFICIAL TO EXPAND ACCESS
BEYOND INCOME AND EARLY
INTERVENTION SUPPORT. TO
CHILDREN THAT ARE ENGLISH
LEARNERS LEARNERS THAT WE KNOW
THAT IF YOU CAN AND ENTER
KINDERGARTEN HAVING BEEN IN
PRESCHOOL ESPECIALLY FOR
ENGLISH LEARNERS THAT THERE ARE
SIGNIFICANT SIGNIFICANT GREATER
OUTCOMES IN READING AND
MATHEMATICS. FOR ENGLISH
LANGUAGE LEARNERS WHAT IS ALEJO
THANK. YES THEY ARE CORTES WHAT
THE L. A. L. WE DON'T HAVE A
SPECIFIC RECOMMENDATION ON ON
THIS PROPOSAL OR OR THIS
CONCEPT AND WE'RE HAPPY TO WORK
WITH YOU TO SUPPORT TO SUPPORT
YOUR PRIORITIES. THANK YOU AND
IF ANYONE ELSE WENT AWAY AND
THERE HAVE I HAVEN'T TWO MORE
QUESTIONS. IT'S OKAY IF YOU
DON'T. SO EARLY CHILDHOOD
EDUCATION PROGRAM SPACE
ADDITIONAL ONGOING COSTS
INCLUDING THE MINIMUM WAGE
INCREASE THAT WENT INTO EFFECT
ON JANUARY FIRST IS IT
MINISTRATION CONSIDERING AN
AUGMENTED COLA FOR EARLY
LEARNING FOR EARLY CHILDHOOD
EDUCATION PROGRAMS LIKE IT HAS
PROPOSED BERG FORGET YOUR
TWELFTH. THIS IS SERVER TO THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE- THAT
THAT'S SUPER COOL- CONCEPT THAT
WOULD SUBSIDE TO ELEAZAR PART
OF OUR PROPOSALS FOR CHILDCARE
AND EARLY LEARNING I'M BEYOND
THE ONE POINT 5% CALL THAT
THEY'RE SEEING IN THE BUDGET
YEAR- BUT AGAIN WE'RE HAPPY TO
TAKE YOUR CONCERNS BACK BUT- I
THINK I THINK WHAT IT YOU KNOW
IT MAKES SENSE IS. THE QUITE
LITERALLY THE COST OF LIVING
GOES UP AND THE COST OF DOING
BUSINESS FOR PROVIDERS- AND
IT'S PART OF YOU KNOW THEIR
ABILITYTO RETAIN YOU KNOW
QUALITY EARLY LEARNING
PROFESSIONALS SO I COULD
APPRECIATE THAT CONSIDERATION-
AND LASTLY. THE ADMINISTRATION
CONTINUES TO- PRACTICE
INITIATED. THE PRACTICE AND
ISSUED IN TWO THOUSAND NINETEEN
TWENTY OF USING CANNABIS TAX
REVENUES PROP SIXTY FOUR TO
FUND CHILD CARE SLOTS. ARE
THESE RESOURCES ALLOCATED
VIRTUAL FOR CHILD CARE SLOTS
AND COUNTIES WERE CANNABIS.
TAXES ARE NOT GENERATED. YEAH
FREE WRITER. THE. THE SERVER IN
OUR DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE SO
IT'S NOT A SPECIFIC TO THAT
LEVEL IN TERMS OF WHERE IT GOES
TO CERTAIN COUNTIES THE
PROGRAMS ARE STILL ARE SORRY
THE FUNDING IS SLOTTED FOR THE
ALTERNATE PAYMENT PROGRAM TO
REFLECT THE NEED THAT WE'VE
SEEN IN THAT PROGRAM THIS YEAR
PARTICULARLY- BUT TO YOUR
QUESTION IT'S NOT A SPECIFIC TO
CERTAIN TOWNS. GOT IT THANK YOU.
YEAH I JUST LASTLY TO ON THE
PROP SIXTY FOUR YOU WE'VE WE'VE
HAD A DEBATE LAST YEAR'S ABOUT
THIS BECAUSE WHEN SIXTY FOUR
WAS ON THE BALLOT THEY TALKED
ABOUT HE GOING TO FIND AFTER
SCHOOL PROGRAMS. AND WE LEFT
CHILD CARE PROGRAMS AND AFTER
SCHOOL PROGRAMS SO ON A ROB
PETER TO PAY PAUL AND- ARE
USING. THESE TO FIND-
ADDITIONAL- A. P. SLOTS- AND HE
I GUESS IS A QUESTION BY A P.
COULD. HAVE CENTER BASED IN
DATABASE BUT WE ARE DOING THAT-
AND IN LARGE PART I THINK TWO
YEARS AGO BECAUSE WE WERE TIGHT
THE MONEY WE WANTED TO EXPAND
THAT. IS DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
AT ALL THINKING- SPECIALLY AS-
PROP SIXTY FOUR REVENUES GROW.
TO LOOK AT THE INTENT OF THOSE
TV COMMERCIALS AND- CERTAIN I
CAN BRING THEM THEY HAD
GOVERNOR'S THE GOVERNOR
GOVERNOR NEWSOM CAMPAIGNING FOR
IT AND HE SAID IN HIS WORDS.
PASSED PROP SIXTY FOUR IT'S
TIME TO TAX AND REGULATE
MARIJUANA AND FOUND WORTHY
PROGRAMS LIKE AFTER SCHOOL.
THOSE THOSE ARE THE EXACT WORDS
OF THE TV COMMERCIAL- SO. IS
THERE A INTENT TO FOLLOW
THROUGH WITH THAT COMMITMENT TO
FIND AFTER SCHOOL AS WELL AS
CHILD CARE OF PROP. SIXTY FOUR.
THANK YOU SIR BERNARD THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE SO. THE
FUNDS THAT WE RECEIVE THE
CURRENT YEAR- AND THE ONES FOR
BUDGET YEAR ARE INAPPROPRIATE
TOWARDS THE ALTERNATE PAYMENT
PROGRAM. WHICH I THINK YOU
MENTIONED A LITTLE BIT DO YOU
FIND THAT SCHOOL AGE CHILDREN
AS WELL- THIS IS A REFLECTION
UPON THE NEED IN THOSE PROGRAMS
THIS YEAR THAT WE'VE SEEN WITH
CHILD CARE PROVIDERS- FACING A
HIGHER COST OF BUSINESS TO CARE
FOR SCHOOL AGED CHILDREN- SO TO
THAT. TO THAT SENSE ARE WE ARE
CONTINUING ON THAT INTENTION-
IF MY DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL
SERVICES CALLING WANT TO
COMMENT MORE ABOUT BUDGET YEAR.
I WOULD PASS IT OFF TO THE.
THIS IS THERE A NUMBER OF
ORGANS AND THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION I WON'T
SPEAK SPECIFICALLY TO YOU THAT
PROP SIXTY FOUR PERSON EVENT.
BY JUST TO BUILD ON WHAT USE
THAT ASSEMBLY MEMBER MCCARTY.
OUR AFTER SCHOOL EDUCATION AND
SAFETY PROGRAM OR A SENSE
THIRDS G. THREE EIGHT. AND
CONTINUES TO HAPPEN BUT
SIGNIFICANT NEEDS IN OUR LAST
REQUEST FOR FUNDING ROUNDS WE
HAD THREE TIMES THE ARE. VERSUS
THE AVAILABLE FUNDING FOR
EASTER. AND OVERCAME TRYING HIM
OUT REQUESTED FOR TWENTY FIRST
CENTURY COMMUNITY LEARNING
CENTERS. WE SERVE NEARLY ONE
MILLION CHILDREN. I AND KNOW
THAT THEY NEED AND DESIRE FOR
ENRICHING. AFTER SCHOOL AND
SUMMER PROGRAMS IT'S FAR FAR
BEYOND THAT NEARLY A MILLION
CHILDREN. ABOUT WHAT EVALUATION
FOUND THAT. PARTICIPATING
CHILDREN ATTENDED. THAT WORK IN
OUR AS PART. THEN IT'S SCHOOL
FOUR TO SEVEN DAYS MORE. THAN
SIMILAR NON. SHARES AT THAT
SCHOOL. SO WE REALLY BELIEVE
IT'S AN INVESTMENT THAT HELPS
OUR CHILDREN STANDS WILL DO
BETTER IN SCHOOL AND PROVIDES
THE NECESSARY CARE THAT
FAMILIES NEED. IT WAS
HIGHLIGHTED IN THE MASTER PLAN
AS A COMPONENT POSSIBILITY
AROUND LOOKING AT T. K. AND K.
THROUGH THIRD AND EATING
SOMETHING SPECIFIC TO SUPPORT
CHILDREN. I THINK YOU MENTIONED
THAT ASSEMBLY MEMBER MCCARTY
FACT YOU CAN EAT EVEN IF IT'S A
SCHOOL DAY DOESN'T ACTUALLY FIT
THE FULL DAY OF A WORKING
FAMILY. AND SO WHERE COULD EASE
THIS COMMAND TO FIRE REALLY
SUPPORT THAT SCHOOL SITE IN
PROVIDING A MORE ROBUST. DAY
FOR FAMILIES WHO ARE WORKING.
OKAY THANK YOU I WITH THAT WE
WILL. HOLD THIS OPEN AND TAKE A
LOOK AGAIN AFTER. C. E. AT
STAKEHOLDER DISCUSSION AND
RECOMMENDATIONS WE HAVE A
PANELIST A GRAB OF A PANEL OF
PROVIDERS I AND- ENTITIES IN
THE FIELD THEY CAN SHARE THEIR
INSIGHT ON EASKEY IN TWENTY
TWENTY ONE SO WE'RE GONNA START
WITH JESSICA GET UP WITH THE
CHILD CARE ALLIANCE OF LOS
ANGELES. THANK YOU GOOD
AFTERNOON SURE MCCARTY AN
ASSEMBLYMEMBERS AND JESSICA. AM
I PUBLIC POLICY ASSOCIATE FOR
THE CHILD CARE ALLIANCE OF LOS
ANGELES AND I'M HERE TODAY ON
BEHALF OF THE STATE WHAT YOU
SEE COALITION. AS IT'S BEEN
MENTIONED THE COVER NINETEEN
PANDEMIC HAS DISRUPTED
EVERYTHING ABOUT HOW OUR
CHILDREN ARE CARED FOR. BUT IT
HASN'T DISTRICT ARE CARE FOR
OUR CHILDREN. NOW MORE THAN
EVER PEOPLE UNDERSTAND THAT
CHILD CARE IS ESSENTIAL IT'S
ESSENTIAL NOT ONLY FOR FAMILIES
AND THE EDUCATION OF THE
DEVELOPMENT OF CHILDREN BUT
ALSO FOR EMPLOYERS AND OUR
STATE'S ECONOMIC. ECONOMIC
HEALTH. WOMEN PARTICULARLY
BLACK IN LINE NEXT WOMEN HAVE
LOST THE MOST DURING THIS
ECONOMIC DOWNTURN. WHEN
FAMILIES DON'T HAVE ACCESS TO
CHILD CARE IT'S WOMEN WHO ARE
LEAVING THE WORKFORCE TO CARE
FOR THEIR CHILDREN. IN EQUITY
USING HOW CHILD CARE IS FUNDED
AND SUPPORTED HAS FOR TOO LONG
MEANT THAT FAMILIES WITH LOW
INCOME STRUGGLE TO FIND.
AFFORDABLE AND RELIABLE CARE
ESPECIALLY FOR BABIES AND
TODDLERS. AND PROVIDERS MOST
WHO ARE WOMEN OF COLOR. HAVE
NOT BEEN PAID ENOUGH TO MAKE A
LIVING WAGE. THE EXISTING
INEQUITIES AND THE PANDEMIC
HAVE CALIFORNIA'S HEALTH CARE
SYSTEM ON THE VERGE OF COLLAPSE.
TO ADDRESS THE CHILD CARE
CRISIS THE SEQUEL THEY XIN IS
RECOMMENDING THE FOLLOWING.
FIRST WE DO THANK THE
ADMINISTRATION AND THE
LEGISLATURE FOR THE ADDITIONAL
RESOURCES AND THE RELIEF THAT
HAS BEEN PROVIDED THROUGHOUT
THE CURRENT BUDGET YEAR. FOR
THE TWENTY TWENTY ONE TO TWENTY
TWENTY TWO BUDGET WE NEED
SIGNIFICANT INVESTMENT NOT JUST
FROM FEDERAL FUNDS BUT
INTENTIONAL STATE FUNDS TO. WE
URGE YOU TO ADOPT STRICT-
INVESTMENTS TO STRENGTHEN AND
EXPAND A COMPREHENSIVE CHILD
CARE SYSTEM THAT IS ACCESSIBLE.
AFFORDABLE EQUITABLE MEETS
FAMILIES NEEDS MPS PROVIDERS A
LIVING WAGE. SO WHAT DOES THAT
LOOK LIKE. FIVE HUNDRED
MILLION. AN ONGOING FUNDING FOR
CHILDCARE VOUCHERS AND SPACES
THREE HUNDRED EIGHTY MILLION
AND ONGOING FUNDING TO BRING
THE REGIONAL MARKET RATE AND
THE STANDARD REIMBURSEMENT
RATES UP TO THE TWENTY
EIGHTEEN. ARMAR SURVEY LEVEL.
OF TWO HUNDRED AND THIRTY THREE
MILLION TO WAY FAMILY FEES
THROUGHOUT THE PANDEMIC. FIVE
HUNDRED AND FIFTY MILLION IN
ONE TIME FUNDING OVER FOUR
YEARS TO RESTORE THE FACILITIES
AND PROFESSIONAL DEVELOPMENT
BLOCK GRANTS. THAT WOULD DEFINE
IT LAST YEAR SO THAT PROVIDERS
HAVE THE RESOURCES TO REOPEN IT
SO THAT WE CAN RECRUIT NEW
PROVIDERS TO REPLACE THOSE WHO
UNFORTUNATELY HAVE PERMANENTLY
CLOSED. THIRTY ONE MILLION IN
ONE TIME FUNDING TO MODERNIZE
TECHNOLOGY SYSTEMS VERY FAMILY
FRIENDLY SYSTEM. AND UP TO FIVE
MILLION IN ONE TIME FUNDING FOR
THE DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL
SERVICES. TO DEVELOP AN EQUITY
INDEX. WHEN THE SIGNAL INFLUX
OF ONE TIME GENERAL DOLLARS AND
FEDERAL. FUNDS THESE ARE
REASONABLE REQUEST TO ENSURE
THAT CALIFORNIA WORKING
FAMILIES CAN RETURN TO WORK.
AGAIN CHILDCARE PROVIDERS ARE
ESSENTIAL THEY HAVE STEPPED UP
TO SERVE OTHERS CENTRAL WRKERS
AND HAVE WORKED TIRELESSLY TO
KEEP OUR ECONOMY GOING. THE
CHILD CARE SYSTEM CONTINUES TO
SURVIVE BECAUSE OF BLACK IN
LINE NEXT WOMEN. AND IT'S TIME
THAT WE STEP OUT FOR THEM. AS
YOU WORK TO BUILD A BUDGET THAT
REFLECTS OUR VALUES LET'S MAKE
SURE. THAT WE ACKNOWLEDGE THE
VALUE OF WOMEN'S WORK. THANK
YOU FOR YOUR TIME AND NOW I
WILL PASS IT ON TO MY COLLEAGUE
DEBORAH QUARTERLY. MY NAME IS
DEBORAH QUALIFY IS THAT OKAY.
YEAH I AM A MEMBER OF THE CHILD
CARE PROVIDERS UNITED MY DAY
CARE IS OPEN TWENTY FOUR HOURS
A DAY SEVEN DAYS A WEEK I HAVE
PARENTS WHO WORK IN THE NURSING
IN NINETEEN ALL DISTRIBUTION
WAREHOUSES AND OTHER FRONT LINE
JOBS. THE THANK COLBERT
NINETEEN HAS TAKEN A TOLL IS AN
UNDERSTATEMENT I'VE HAD. ONE OF
THE FIVE ZERO TASK PROBLEMS
POSITIVE THE COSTS ASSOCIATED
WITH KEEPING MY DAYCARE ESTATE
PROFITABLE HAVE BEEN A
FINANCIAL STRAIN MOST OF MY DAY
CARE IS TAKEN UP BY
FACILITATING DISTANCE LEARNING
CLASSES AS WELL AS WORKING WITH
THE LITTLE ONES I THANK YOU FOR
KIDS. TEMPORARILY MOVED IN WITH
ME BECAUSE THEIR PARENTS WORK.
IN NURSING HOMES HI. THEREFORE
THERE LIVES. WE GOT ONE OF MY
THAT PUBLIC LEAVING BEHIND A
FOR YOU OLD IN BOY THIS MAKE
HAVE MADE ONE THING CLEAR ARE
ALREADY WILL CHECK CARE SYSTEM
WHAT THE PREPARE TO GET WITH
THE THANK OVER NINETEEN CREATE
DEVASTATION FOR OVER. FIVE
THOUSAND FIVE THE CLOSE THERE'S
BILLBOARDS. AND OVER FIFTY
THOUSAND KICKED THE MOVE THE
CHILD CARE I THANK ALL THE THIS
TO YOU- IF YOU CAN BE SURE THAT
THIS BUDGET DOES KEEP IN ONE
STABILIZE CHILD. AND KILL IT
DOWN. TO A STRONG. THIS
INCLUDES RIGHT NOW FOR PROVIDE
TO BE TO SEE OPEN DURING A
DIFFICULT TIME. AND PROVIDER
WHO HAVE BEEN TO CLOSE TO ME
OKAY WAITING ALL FAN BE AND
REIMBURSE PROVIDERS. EXTEND
CURRENT CALL THE PROJECT.
THOUSAND TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO
IT'S GOING YEAR INCREASE
REIMBURSED RATES ANY CLOTHING.
BENEFITS FOR PROVIDE THANK YOU
RETIREMENT HEALTHCARE PLAY TIME
ALL WHAT CARE ACT THAT EIGHT
PEOPLE. FINALLY THERE WOULD BE
MORE DEVASTATING I'VE BEEN THAT.
JOHN PROVIDERS SHOULD HAVE TO
BAD AND WHEN NOT FOR HELP TO
CONTINUE OFF. THE VERY OF IT
STATE. BUYERS TO DO STEP UP AND
THANK YOU. THANK NOTTHE THING
MERRY- IT'S NOT A FROM PARENTS
VOICES. YEAH THANK YOU FOR MAKE
ME FOLLOW MISTER. THANK YOU-
HUH I NATION'S PARENT. A DAY OF
I'M OF THIS IS HAS REAL HARM
THAT'S FONG FOR DOM ON THE
BACKS OF BLACK AND LATINO. WE
HAVE RECOMMENDATIONS UNDO THAT
HARPER ASK IF WAIVE ALL FAMILY
FEES ONE OF STARTS TO EARN A TO
FIVE DOLLARS DOLLARS A MONTH IN
GROSS PAY THEY START TO PAY MY
FEE THEIR K. AS INCOME RIGHT
THEIR FEES RISE. WE HAVE
MEMBERS ARE SUCH WORKERS FORCED
ONTO PAYMENTS WITH TEACHING SO
THEY CAN AFFORD THE THREE
HUNDRED DOLLARS IN CHILD CARE
FEES THEY PAY A MONTH SO THEY
CAN KEEP THEIR SUBSIDY A MAGIC
RISK IN A LECTURE CITY TO KEEP
YOUR CHILD CARE. THERE'S A
FARMWORKERS COUPLE IN FRESNO
WHO SAW THEIR FEES JUMPED FROM
TWO HUNDRED DOLLARS TO FOUR
HUNDRED DOLLARS A MONTH BECAUSE
SCHOOLS REMAINED CLOSED THEY
COULDN'T AFFORD IT MOM QUIT.
HER JOB AND TOOK THE KIDS OUT
OF CARE. THE STATE IS CALLED.
SICK ABOUT SIXTY EIGHT MILLION
PER YEAR IN FEES FOR MOSTLY
WORKING MOTHERS OF COLOR TO
SUBSIDIZE THIS PROGRAM. IN SOME
CASES CHILD CARE PROVIDERS
RECEIVE LOWER PAYCHECKS AND
MUST COLLECT THE FEES FROM
PARENTS TO MAKE UP THE
DIFFERENCE. MANY PROVIDERS
RECORD THEY DON'T EVEN TAKE THE
FEET BECAUSE THEY SEE THAT THE
FINANCIAL TOLL IT TAKES ON THE
FAMILY. AND THEN THEY SUPPRESS
THEIR OWN INCOME. SIXTY MILLION
AS A DROP IN THE BUCKET FOR THE
STATE BUT IT'S BREAKING THE
FINANCIAL STABILITY OF WORKING
WITH IT. YOU CAN DO THIS HARM.
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT HAS
GIVEN US A SHORT WINDOW TO TAKE
ACTION TO WAIVE FEES FOR ALL
FAMILIES THAT. THE FEES WERE
WAIVED IN THE BEGINNING OF THE
PANDEMIC BUT SINCE SEPTEMBER
TWENTY TWENTY ESSENTIAL WORKERS
AND THOSE USING IN PERSON CARE
CONTINUE TO PAY. THOSE WERE
PROTECTED US FROM THE VIRUS
SHOULDN'T FEEL THE ECONOMIC
PAIN OF THESE FEEDS. THE
BENEFIT OF WAIVING FEES IS THAT
IT'S IMMEDIATE RELIEF UNLIKE
OTHER STIMULUS BENEFITS THERE'S
NO APPLICATION PROCESS NO ONE
CAN DENY YOU. YOU DON'T HAVE TOFIND THE RIGHT DOOR OR THE
RIGHT WORKER TO HELP YOU GET
IT. SO WE ARE ASKING FOR YOU TO
WAVE A HUNDRED TWENTY FIVE
MILLION. AND I'M SORRY WE ARE
ASKING YOU TO PROVIDE A HUNDRED
TWENTY FIVE MILLION TO WAIVE.
THE FEES THROUGH OCTOBER TWENTY
TWENTY TWO. THE SECOND HALF IS
TO MEET THE ACCESS DEMANDS OF
FAMILIES WHO ARE WAITING FOR
CARE. AS SCHOOLS IN THE ECONOMY
RE OPENED FAMILIES WILL NEED
CHILD CARE TO GET BACK TO WORK.
86% OF THE KIDS ON THE WAITING
LIST OUR KIDS OF COLOR AND THEY
NEED US TO SEE THEM. THE
CHOICES YOU TAKE IN THIS
COMMITTEE WILL HAVE A
GENERATIONAL IMPACT IF YOU
DON'T ACT NOW. FIVE HUNDRED
MILLION AN ONGOING FUNDS TO
EXPAND ACCESS THAT JESSICA HAD
MENTIONED- WE HAVE AN IDEA
ABOUT WHAT YOU CAN DO WITH ONE
TIME FUNDS. IN ORDER TO ADDRESS
THE ACUTE NEEDS OF GENERATION
COPE AND URGENCY. THE KIDS BORN
AND BEING RAISED DURING THE
PANDEMIC. WE'VE HEARD A LOT
ABOUT T. K. IN THIS HEARING BUT
WE ALSO NEED SOLUTIONS FOR
INFANTS AND TODDLERS. WHO'VE
EXPERIENCED A YEAR OF
ISOLATION. PLAYGROUNDS AND
PARKS CLOSE SANDBOXES ANTI AND
HOW THAT IMPACTED THEIR
DEVELOPMENT AND WE KNOW THAT
BRAIN DEVELOPMENT IS AT ITS
MOST RAPID IN THE EARLIEST
YEARS. BY TARGETING CHILDCARE
VOUCHERS AND SLOTS AND
PRIORITIZING FAMILIES WITH
INFANTS AND TDDLERS. JENNIFER
YOU CAN HAVE A FRESH START.
GETTING INTO CHILDCARE PROGRAMS
WHERE THEY CAN PLAY AND BE WITHTHEIR PEERS. WHICH COULD
REVERSE THE HARM OF ISOLATION.
IF THEY HAVE ACCESS TO CARE
OVER THREE YEARS. WE CAN FOLLOW
THEM AS INFANTS AND TODDLERS
AND THEN WATCH THEM ENTER.
OTHER PROGRAMS FOR FOUR YEAR
OLDS AND KINDERGARTEN AND
BEYOND. WE CAN HAVE A REAL TIME
STUDY OF THE IMPACT AN
INTERVENTION THAT ACCESS TO
QUALITY AFFORDABLE CHILDCARE.
HAD IN THEIR LIVES. WE LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING WITH THE
COMMITTEE TO UNDO SYSTEMIC
RACIAL HARM. AND TURN IT INTO
HEALING AND- FAMILY SUCCESS.
THANK YOU AND I WILL PASS IT.
TO MY COLLEAGUE ERIC SONNENFELD.
HELLO GERMAN A COMMITTEE
MEMBERS THANK YOU FOR SPENDING
YOUR TIME TODAY TO DISCUSS.
THESE VERY IMPORTANT ISSUES. AS
MENTIONED WITH ALL OF OUR OTHER
PANEL MEMBERS THE EARLY
LEARNING CARE SYSTEM WAS ON THE
BRINK OF COLLAPSE WHEN CALLED
THE NINETEEN HIT US. AND WE
BARELY SURVIVED IN YOUR
CURRENTLY STILL. BARELY
SURVIVING AT THIS POINT. WHAT
I'D LIKE TO BRING THE
COMMITTEE'S ATTENTION TO IS.
NOT AT THIS POINT FOR THE
VOUCHER BASED SIDE OF THE HOUSE
BILLS FOR THE SENATE SIDE. TO
CONTINUE TO HOLD HARPER I WAS
FOR TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO IS AN
AND IMMEDIATE NEED. FOR THE
SERVICE WORLD. THE IMPACTS OF
COOPER NINETEEN FAMILIES NOT
WANTING TO BRING THEIR CHILDREN
TO OUR CENTERS OR- FOR-
CHILDREN WHO CANNOT ATTEND OUR
CENTERS BECAUSE OF LOCAL PUBLIC
HEALTH OR STATE PUBLIC.
GUIDELINES RELATED TO GROUP
SIZE. SO I REALLY ENCOURAGE THE
STATE LEGISLATURE. TO CONTINUE
THE HOLD HARMLESS INTO 2122%
BASED CONTRACTORS. WHICH WILL
ALLOW US TO STABILIZE
OURSELVES. ENSURE THAT WE- ARE
RETURN CHILDREN AND FAMILIES TO
CARE SAFELY. AND EFFECTIVELY.
ALSO AS PART OF TODAY'S A
CONSIDERATION IS RATE REFORM.
REFORM IS A HUGE REQUIREMENT
THAT IS NEEDED. BECAUSE WE
REFORM FOR NOT ONLY THE BUDGET
BASED SIDE WHICH WE'VE HEARD
ABOUT US FIRST FOR THE SENATE
BAYSIDE CREATES EQUITY. THE TWO
SYSTEMS OF THE NEXT DELIVERY
SYSTEM WE HAVE IN CALIFORNIA.
REFORM IS CRUCIAL TO ANY
FOUNDATIONAL CHANGES THAT ARE
PROPOSED EVEN IN THE MASTER
PLAN OR ANY PLANLEGISLATURE
MAY CONSIDER IN THE FUTURE. IT
ENSURES PROPER WAGES. IT
ENSURES STABILIZATION OF THE
WORK FORCE IT ALSO ENCOURAGES
FOLKS TO BE MAINTAINED IN THE
WORK FORCE. BECAUSE WITHOUT
RATE REFORM. OUR COSTS WILL
EXCEED THE AMOUNT OF
REIMBURSEMENT WE RECEIVE FOR
EACH CHILD. AND WITH THE RISING
COST OF MINIMUM WAGE PERSONS
SPECIFICALLY- IN ELEAZAR AND IF
FOR THOSE PRIVATE NONPROFITS
WHO ARE THINKING ABOUT GIVING
OR CURRENTLY GIVING HEALTH AND
WELFARE OR RETIREMENT BENEFITS
TO THEIR EMPLOYEES. THOSE RATE
REFORMS TO HEAR IT FOR QUALITY
FOR OR INCENTIVIZING FOR OTHER
THINGS THAT WE ALL WANT TO FEEL
IS BEDROCK. AS PART OF REFORM
ALSO COLD. LEARNING RECEIVE
SOMETHING MORE THAN A DIET COLA
WE MUST RECEIVE RECIPROCAL.
BECAUSE OUR COSTS ARE THE SAME
COST AS EVERYONE ELSE'S COSTS.
SO IF K. TWELVE OFFICIATING IN
TWO POINT 31% INCREASE. REALLY
LEARNING SHOULD RECEIVE THE
SAME. WE HAVE SOME THAT SAME OF
SCHOOL K. TWELVE S. WE ALSO
HAVE SOME DIFFERENT OBSTACLES
THAT K. TWELVE DOES NOT HAVE.
ALSO WAS REMINDED COMMITTEE
CHIU ENCOURAGE THE FUNDING
FLEXIBILITY BETWEEN THE CCG ARE
NCCPG CONTRACTS ONCE YOU SHIFT
TO DSS. HAPPENS ON JULY ONE
THAT IS CRUCIAL TO ENSURE THAT
THE NEXT DELIVERY SYSTEM SERVES
CHILDREN AND FAMILIES IN THEIR
LOCAL COMMUNITIES IN THE BEST.
POSSIBLE SETTING. ALSO I WANT
TO REMIND THE COMMUNITY THAT
INCREASE BASIS FOR THAT
CONTRACT PROGRAMS THAT WERE
REMOVED BECAUSE OF THE
ANTICIPATED CALLED THE
NINETEEN. BUDGET SHORTFALL
SHOULD BE RESTORED. AND LASTLY
IN THIS VEIN TO CREATE A
UNIVERSAL EXPERIENCE FOR FOUR
GOALS. BEFORE THAT IS FULLY
ROLLED OUT I WOULD LIKE TO
REMIND LEGISLATURE THAT THEY
SHOULD REINSTATE THE PARENTAL
CHOICE. BETWEEN C. S. B. P. AND
THE CLERK T. K. PROGRAM TO
ALLOW PARENTS TO CHOOSE IN
THEIR COMMUNITY WHICH OPTION
SUITS THEM BEST. UNTIL A FULL
PLAN IS ROLLED OUT. AND WITH
THAT I WILL TURN OVER THE
BALANCE OF MY TIME TO MR NOBLE
MORGAN THANK YOU. THAT LEADS
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS
THAT THERE NEVER WORKING AGAIN
DEPUTY SUPERINTENDENT AT THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION. ON BEHALF OF STATE
SUPERINTENDENT OF PUBLIC
INSTRUCTION TO ANY GOVERNMENT.
WHEN WE LOOK AT EARLY LEARNING
CARE WE KNOW THERE ARE MANY
NEEDS AND NOTHING ELSE IN FACT
IF THE PANELISTS BEFORE ME MADE
VERY COMPELLING. ME THAT CAN.
HE'S SO ATHLETIC IN THE- AND-
IT WOULD STAY AT THEIR- AS THEY
TOLD US ABOUT THE IMPACT IN
THEIR OWN PROGRAMS AND ON THEIR
OWN FAMILIES. I'VE ALREADY
DISPATCHED THEM IN THE NEEDS
ARE CONTRACTORS THAT SHARED
RELATED TO COVET NINETEEN
RESPONSES. AND ONCE AGAIN
ECHOING THE PRIOR PANELISTS.
INCLUDE WAITING TO BE IN THE
TEENS EXTENDING THE HOLD
HARMLESS FOR DIRECT CONTRACTED
PROGRAMS INTERVENTION PROGRAMS.
AND ADDITIONAL STATEMENTS OR
OTHER MECHANISMS TO SUPPORT THE
ENTIRE FIELD SAID THAT WE ALSO
SUPPORT THE PRIVATE MARKET. BUT
AS WE LOOK TO THE SYSTEM AS A
WHOLE AND WE FOCUS ON
STABILIZING AT RIGHT NOW WE
ALSO NEED TO REMEMBER THE
IMPORTANCE OF CREATING
EQUITABLE ACCESS TO HIGH
QUALITY PROGRAMS. THAT RESEARCH
DEMONSTRATES PROVIDE THE
FOUNDATIONAL LEARNING
EXPERIENCE IN THE EARLY YEARS.
LINKED TO CLOSING OPPORTUNITY
AND ACHIEVEMENT GAPS THAT FUELS
THE INEQUITIES ACROSS THE
EDUCATIONAL SYSTEM AND BEYOND.
PRELIMINARY RESEARCH BY WESTON
ED IN UC BERKELEY BEAR HAS
FOUND THAT CHILDREN AND THE
CALIFORNIA STATE PRESCHOOL
PROGRAM. IN ESTATE THAT'S RATED
AT FIVE UNDER THE QUALITY
COUNTS CALIFORNIA READING MATH
MATRIX EXHIBIT GREATER LEARNING
AND DEVELOPMENT THANK THOSE IN
TIER FOUR TIER THIRTY PROGRAMS
ACROSS ALL DESIRED RESULTS
DEVELOPMENTAL PROFILE. ARE DEAR
TO KEEP GETTING. THEIR RESEARCH
ALSO CLEARLY INDICATES THAT ARE
TO ONE LANGUAGE LEARNERS
BENEFITED THE MOST. AND IT WAS
AN ENORMOUS INCREASE FROM
ACCESS TO THAT KIND OF QUALITY
CALIFORNIA STATE. OPERA GRAHAM
SPECIFICALLY THEY FOUND THAT
GAPS IN LEARNING AND
DEVELOPMENT WERE NEAR OUR FOR
DUAL LANGUAGE LEARNERS IN ITS
HEREBY BENDING EACH YEAR
THROUGH THE PROGRAM. THIS MEANS
THAT ALL OF OUR PROGRAMS MEET
THOSE RESOURCES AND SUPPORTS IT
YOU CAN REACH THOSE HIGHER
LEVELS OF QUALITY AND REALLY
SUPPORT ALL OF OUR EARLIEST
LEARNERS. MEASURE TO BACKSEAT
ON THE CALIFORNIA'S DECREASED
COPART RAN WITH YOUR OFFICES TO
THIS HEARING. AND YOU'LL SEE
THAT WE HAVE OPPORTUNITIES. TO
LEVERAGE ACCESS TO HIGH THE
RESULT TO EQUITY CHILDREN AND
PARTS. WE ROUGHLY THAT'S
HUNDRED THOUSAND DREAM YEAR
OLDS ARE A LITLE TO SEE. P.
TWENTY SEVEN PER OF THE
ELIGIBLE THREE FOUR YEAR OLD.
ARE SERVED IN IT ONE NINETEEN
S. OR SERVE OTHER EARLY MORNING
SO SETTING. AS WE MOVE FORWARD
WITH WANT TO LOOK AT DATA TO
DRIVE. AND- PROGRAMS. HE OF
THIS WILL BE A THE YES KEEP
KEEP RATES I WASN'T AS AT HAD A
BIT TO TALKING DIET. COLOR.
BENTSEN DOWN OUR PANEL IS THE
FTP RAY IS FAR BEHIND FIFTY K.
RATE AND THE REGIONAL MARKETS
RIGHT. WHEN WE FOR WORST THAT I
CHILDREN ARE IN THE STATE. THE
ESTIMATE AT DAILY REACH MARKET
R. INCLUDING YOUR- COSTS
REPORTS CARE. FOR A SPAN BASED
RECENTLY CHINA THE ARE IS
THIRTY FOUR FOR HI. THAN THE
FULL DAY YES PPD ENTERED ME IN.
RATE FOR A CHILD HOME PROVIDING
CARE FOR PEACE AGED. FAVORITE
BY PERCENT HIGHER THAN OUR DAY
YES HE RATE WHICH EMPEROR
LICENSE IT'S- BASED CARE. THE
R. IS. PERCENT HIGHER THAN THE
PART DATE YES KEEP. STATE
STANDARD REIMBURSED RIGHT
FASTER JUST SO. THAT AS WE LOOK
AT A- THAT'S WHAT TO MEET STILL.
AS WELL AS DO BUSINESS WITH THE
STATE WHICH MEANS INCREASE JUST
NOT COST. THAT THERE MAY DOES
NOT SUPPORT. INDEED TO YES HE
AND G. K. SUPPORT. WE WOULD
LIKE TO SEE ENHANCE FUNDING THE
EARLY AT. PROGRAM WHICH IS
ARTICLE MORE AND PROGRAMS THAT
THE STATE IS THIS BUDGET ABOUT
YEARS WHEN THE BY. BUT WE
WEREN'T ABLE TO YOUR TO ME WE
HAVE FORTY TWO APPLICANTS ARE
ABLE FIND AT. AND I WHO WERE
EIGHT TO HER. THE IS NEEDED
AVAILABLE PLANS BY- OVER A
HUNDRED AND TWENTY MILLION AND
EVEN OUR CURRENT. ARE NOW FLANK
THAT THEY HAVE ADDITIONAL
SYSTEM EQUIPMENT AND
PROFESSIONAL DEVELOPMENT NEEDS
AS THEY MISTER IMPLEMENTATION
OF THEIR GRANTS BUT THEY'RE
ALSO ABLE TO SHARE WITH US HOW
THEY ARE CREATING MORE
INCLUSIVE PROGRAMS AND
SUPPORTING CHILDREN WITH
DISABILITIES WITH AN EXCITING.
BUT THERE ARE OTHER. TYPICALLY
DEVELOPING PEERS. I AS WE AT X.
AND REALLY SUPPORT YES HE- AND
THE REST THIS EARLY LEARNING
AND CARE SYSTEM. WE ASK ARE
THOSE WHO WERE DRESSED THE
NEEDS OF THE WORKFORCE PATHWAYS
BROWN AND- PROVIDING ADDITIONAL.
IN THE- AS WELL AS THE THIS
NEEDS ACROSS THE STATE. WHEN WE
WANT TO MAKE AT ANOTHER PLUG
FOR THAT AFTER SCHOOL EDUCATION
AND SAFETY PROGRAMS EXIST WHICH
AS I SHARED IN THE PREVIOUS
PANEL. WHAT HEARD AND OUR
MASTER PLAN PIECE IN USING A
MODIFIED ASUS RICHIE KEITA
THIRD AS A WAY TO ENSURE FULL
pUNIVERSAL THE SCHOOL SYSTEM AND
ENSURE EQUITABLE ACCESS BY LOW
INCOME WORKING FAMILIES TO
TRANSITIONAL KINDERGARTEN.
OTHER SUPPORT. THAT ALL I HAVE
FOR YOU TODAY BUT I'M HAPPY TO
ANY QUESTIONS THAT YOU MIGHT
HAVE THANK YOU. OKAY THANK YOU-
FALL START OFFERED FOR
QUESTIONS FROM THE FIELD AND SO
THANK YOU TO THE FOR THE FIRST
TIME WELL ALL THE SPEAKERS BUT
SPECIALLY THE FIRST THAT THREE
WHO WHO HAVE YOU KNOW VOICES
FROM REALLY THE TRENCHES
THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA. I ANT
TO ASK THE THIRD QUESTION HERE
AND ON THE AGENDA WHICH
HOPEFULLY WON'T HAPPEN UNTIL
CENTER LEYVA TOOK UP HER. BILL
REFER REFORMING THE
REIMBURSEMENT RATES- THIS
MORNING AND AS WE KNOW WE HAD
THAT I HAD THE BILL AST YEAR
AND WE TEND TO DO SOME OF THAT
IN THE BUDGET. SO WE WANT TO
ASK WHAT WOULD HAPPEN IF WE
DIDN'T MAKE. SIGNIFICANT
PROGRESS ON MODERATE REFORM.
AND CONTINUED WITH THE EXISTING
ARE MARIN S. R. OUR RATES IN
CALIFORNIA. FOR. THE NEGATIVE
JUDGMENTS NOT AS WE'RE NOT
GONNA LET THAT HAPPEN BUT JUST
HYPOTHETICAL WAY. THE
CHAIRPERSON THIS IS OUR TIME
FELT LIKE COUNTS EDUCATION AS A
CURRENT CONTRACT FOR. IF DE UM
S. R. R. IS NOT ADJUSTED OR
EVEN THE HALLMARKS NOT JUST IT-
FUTURE COSTS WILL OUTSTRIP OUR
ABILITY TO OFFER OUR PROGRAMS
CURRENTLY WE HAVE ROUGHLY EIGHT
HUNDRED STATE PRESCHOOL SLOTS.
IN OUR COMMUNITY THAT WE
OPERATE- WE WOULD HAVE TO
SIGNIFICANT LOOK AT. OUR
ABILITY TO CONTINUE SERVING
THAT NUMBER OF CHILDREN. AS OUR
COSTS INCREASE. IN THIS IS
THEIR LEVEL WORKING WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION WE
THINK WE NEED ARISE AND
RELINQUISHMENT L. AS MR
SONNENFELD JUST SUGGESTED THAT
AS CONTRACTORS CAN'T AFFORD TO
OPERATE THAT THE FTP PROGRAM
ANYMORE DAVID RELINQUISH IT
WHICH MEANS WE WOULD LOSE
ACCESS TO HIGH QUALITY
PRESCHOOL. IN THOSE
NEIGHBORHOODS AND COMMUNITIES
WE ALSO KNOW THAT THAT HAS
PLAYED INTO THE LACK OF ABILITY
TO TAKE UP THAT TIME AS WE
RESTART THESE OVER THE YEARS
THAT PROGRAMS FOR THE STRUGGLE
WITH KNOWING THAT IF THEY
ACCEPT THAT AND TAKE ON A
CONTRACT WITH THE DEPARTMENT
BUT THEY WILL THAT STRUGGLE TO
ACTUALLY OPERATE IT BECAUSE IT
DOESN'T COME CLOSE. TO COVERING
THE COST OF THE PROGRAM. IT CAN
ALSO NAY YES FOR FAMILY GATE IT
FROM DAY FOR. HAVE MINIMUM WAGE
CONTINUES TO RISE FAMILY
DAYCARE PROVIDERS WILL NOT BE
ABLE TO PAY THEIR ASSISTANCE
THEREFORE DON'T BE MORE. MORE
QUALIFIED PROVIDERS LEADING THE
FIELD SO THAT HAVE A DIRECT
EFFECT ON FAMILY DAYCARE. AND
THE CHILDREN THAT WE SERVE FOR
THE STATE. OKAY THANK YOU I
WANT TO OWN IT- ASK ONE MORE
QUESTION HERE AND THEN I'LL
LEVINE I ASK THIS QUESTION A
LAST PANEL TO THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE. AND- DIDN'T GET A
SATISFACTORY ELIGIBLE ANSWERS
LOOKING FOR BUT THEY HAVE A JOB
TO DO SO I ASSUME THAT WE WILL
GET A DIFFERENT ANSWER HERE-
LAST YEAR WE HAD OVER TWO YEARS
AGO WE FOCUSED ON INCREASING
MONEY FOR FACILITIES. AND
PROFESSION OF ELEMENT LAST
YEAR'S BUDGET WE TOOK THAT TOOK
THAT MONEY. OUT WHAT WAS THE
OUT COMMERCE SINCE A LOST
OPPORTUNITY FOR THESE
FACILITIES STOLLER'S AS WELL
AS- PROFESSIONAL DEVELOPMENT.
RESOURCES. SO LET'S START WITH
CDCR DOUBLE MORGAN WITH THE
TASK LET'S ASK YOU TO ADDRESS
THAT. THANK YOU CHAIR. I THINK
I HIGHLIGHTED IT BRIEFLY WE
ACTUALLY KNOW THERE WAS QUITE A
BIT OF DEMAND FOR THE
FACILITIES GRANT THAT WE WERE
WORKING ON AND WE HAD GOTTEN TO
THE POINT WHERE WE ARE ABOUT TO
RELEASE THAT. WHEN WE KNEW THAT
THE FUNDS WERE GOING TO BE
SCRAPPED ANY RESPECT FOR A
REALLY GOOD REASON WE
UNDERSTAND THE FISCAL SITUATION
THE STATE BUT IN LAST YEAR.
IT'S JUT THAT THE FISCAL STATE
TURNING AROUND AND LOOKING VERY
DIFFERENT CURRENTLY WE THOUGHT
THAT'S A REALLY CRITICAL AREA
TO INVEST IN AND KNOW THAT EVEN
WITH THE FUNDS THAT WERE
DEDICATED TO IT THAT DEMAND WAS
ANY EXCEED THAT AVAILABILITY.
WOULD SAY THE SAME FOR THE
WORKFORCE. PATHWAYS GRANT AND
WE WERE ABLE TO TAKE WHAT WAS
FORMALLY CALLED EACH. AND
FUNDED BY CTR QUALITY FANS AND
TRANSFORMED THAT SAID THAT IT
WAS MORE AFFORDABLE AND MORE
PROGRAMS GET ACCESS IT BUT IT
WAS ONLY TWELVE MILLION
DOLLARS. AND THAT DOESN'T
NEARLY MEET THE NEEDS OF WHAT
THE DEMOCRATS. AND I THINK I
WILL. ALSO CHEST KNOWING THAT.
ALL OF OUR- AND ALL OF OUR-
NEED ADDITIONAL. THE WORKFORCE.
DIDN'T ADDRESS COME. BUT DID
PROVIDE OPPORTUNITIES AND
SUPPORTS INCREASED. KNOWLEDGE
EXPERTISE. AND ACCESS TO BOTH
HIGH QUALITY TRAINING
APPRENTICESHIP MODELS. AND
ACTUAL UNIT SAID THAT PROVIDERS
COULD GO ON AND GET A DEGREE.
AND AS WE LOOK AT SOME OF THE
THINGS IN THE MASTER PLAN.
AROUND A UNIVERSAL PRESCHOOL
SYSTEM ONE OF THE COMPONENTS IS
TO SUPPORT COMMUNITY BASED
PROGRAMS. ALSO COME UP AND MEET
THE SAME STANDARDS. SO FOR THE
FIELD TO MEET THE SAME
STANDARDS WE WILL NEED TO
INVEST IN THE WORK FORCE. TO
PROVIDE THE SUPPORT SO THAT
THEY CAN THEN MOVE THAT'S. IN
NEED THOSE HIGHER STANDARDS.
OKAY OKAY THANK YOU THAT'S MY
FINAL QUESTION SO REMEMBER BY
ADONIS- I JUST HAVE ONE
QUESTION HERE RATHER IT MIGHT
BE MORE OF A RHETORICAL
QUESTION BUT IF ANYBODY WANTS
TO WEIGH IN- HOW CAN SOME OF
WHICH I THINK ARE REAL THESE
REALLY GREAT BUDGET REQUESTS
AND RECOMMENDATIONS- HOW CAN
THEY HELP MAKE CHILD CARE MORE
AFFORDABLE. FOR THE MIDDLE
CLASS BECAUSE WE TALK A LOT
ABOUT- THE OUR MOST VULNERABLE
OR LOW INCOME FAMILIES- SPECIAL
NEEDS- ENGLISH LANGUAGE
LEARNERS BUT WHAT I THINK WE
HAVEN'T ADDRESSED THE DEEPLY
ENOUGH IS THAT THE REALITY THAT
FOR MANY MIDDLE CLASS FAMILIES
THEY MADE TOO MUCH MONEY TO
QUALIFY FOR ANY STATE AID OR
LOCAL COUNTY AID. BUT THEY
DON'T MAKE ENOUGH TO BE ABLE TO
AFFORD YOU KNOW FIVE SIX TWELVE
HUNDRED DOLLARS IN CHILD CARE
OR PRESCHOOL BUT- FEES SO HOW
DID THESE REQEST AND HOW ARE
WE FOCUSED ON HOW CAN WE FOCUS
ON WHAT RECOMMENDATION RENT
RECOMMENDATIONS YOU HAVE. TO
MAKE CHILD CARE ACCESS TO CHILD
CARE MORE AFFORDABLE FOR THE
MIDDLE CLASS. HI THIS IS MARY-
WITH PEP BOYS THE ALL TAKE A
STAB- THANK YOU ASSEMBLY WOMAN
YOU'VE ASKED INCREDIBLE
QUESTIONS AND WE'RE EXCITED TO
HAVE YOU ON THE SUBCOMMITTEE IS
WELL- I THINK THE CHALLENGE WE
FACE IS. AND THAT'S HOW I
STARTED MY PRESENTATION WHICH
SEVERELY UNDERFUNDED THE SYSTEM
FOR FAR TOO LONG AND SO WE HAD
TO MAKE CHOICES. ON WHO. YOU
KNOW IS QUOTE UNQUOTE DESERVING
AND I THINK WHAT WE'RE SEEING
AT THE FEDERAL LEVEL IS A
INDICATION THAT. THEY WANT TO
EXPAND ACCESS TO QUALITY
AFFORDABLE CHILDCARE FOR ALL
FAMILIES AND SO WE'RE WE'RE
STARTING TO SEE. MORE FEDERAL
DOLLARS COME IN AS WELL AS THE
POTENTIAL OF LONG TERM FUNDING
TO SUPPORT CHILD CARE FOR
FAMILIES WHO MAKE UP TO-
SOMEWHERE IN THE RANGE OF A
HUNDRED AND 50% OF ESTIMATES.
AND THAT WOULD REALLY CAPTURE A
LOT OF THE MIDDLE CLASS
FAMILIES THAT YOU'RE SPEAKING
ABOUT. BUT UNTIL WE GOT THOSE
FEDERAL INVESTMENTS IN UNTIL WE
GET THE REAL STATE INVESTMENTS.
TO BOND THE SYSTEM WE'RE GOING
TO HAVE TO MAKE SPACES AND AT
LEAST WITH OUR FAMILY FEE
PROPOSAL- THAT IS ABOUT MAKING
CHILD CARE AFFORDABLE FOR ALL
FAMILIES. AND EVENTUALLY FOR
FAMILIES WHO STAY ON LONGER AT
THE HIGHER AND- WE WOULD NOT.
WE WOULD ASK FOR NOTE THAT THEY
WOULD NOT CHARGE MORE THAN 7%
OF THEIR INCOME. AND THAT'S HOW
YOU KEEP IT AFFORDABLE FOR ALL
FAMILIES AND SO. AS WE GET THIS
MOMENTUM BACK FROM THE FEDERAL
LEVEL WILL BE ABLE TO REACH
MORE FAMILIES KEEP IT
AFFORDABLE. AND STOP. YOU KNOW
HAVING TO MAKE THESE HARD
CHOICES AROUND DO WE YOU KNOW
INCREASE WAGES FOR PROVIDERS OR
DO WE INCREASE AND. MAKE CHILD
CARE MORE AFFORDABLE. THEY YOU
GREAT GREAT. AND I APPRECIATE
ALL OF THE WORK THAT YOU KNOW
EVERY SINGLE ONE OF- THE
PROVIDERS ON TODAY HAVE SHARED
WITH US THEY'VE- I'VE BEEN
THERE I'VE SHARED YOUR STRUGGLE
AND I'M COMMITTED- TO THIS
BECAUSE BECAUSE IT IS. THE
FOUNDATION OF OUR SOCIETY SO I
JUST APPRECIATE YOUR TIME AND
THANK YOU FOR JOINING US TODAY.
THANK YOU AYE I JUST WANTED TO
FOLLOW UP AND MAYBE AT- FOLLOW
UP ON THAT QUESTION. AND MAYBE
S. SARAH NEVER MORGAN TWO TWO
ADDRESSES SO. YEAH THAT'S A
CONTINUED ISSUE THAT WE FACE IN
THIS COMMITTEE WHETHER IT'S THE
MIDDLE CLASS SCHOLARSHIP EARLY
EDUCATION. THERE ARE PEOPLE WHO
ARE- THEY'RE THERE TO- RICH TO
AFFORD THE FREE BUT THEY'RE TOO
POOR TO PAY A THOUSAND BUCKS A
MONTH WHICH IS WHAT IT COSTS TO
GO TO UCLA THE SAME THING AS A
PRE K. PROGRAM ITSELF. IF
YOU'RE A MIDDLE CLASS FAMILY
LIVE IN A HIGH COST AREA. I
USED TO SAY ALL THE OTHER AREAS
LIKE SOCAL IN THE BAY AREA BUT
NOW HERE IN SACRAMENTO YOU CAN.
BE A FAMILY MAKING IT OUT A
HUNDRED THOUSAND DOLLARS A
YEAR. AND WHEN YOU LOOK AT YOUR
MORTGAGE AND ALL YOUR BILLS AND
EVERYTHING YOU DON'T HAVE THAT
EXTRA MONEY SO ONE THING THAT
WE TRY TO DO TWO YEARS AGO WE
STARTED LAST YEAR IS IN THE
STATE PRESCHOOL PROGRAM. IF
YOUR IN THAT I THINK WE CALL
THE CATCHMENT AREA LIKE IF
YOU'RE IN A- IN THE AREA THAT'S
HIGH. CONCENTRATION OF LOW
INCOME STUDENTS THANK YOU
EVERYBODY FROM THAT AREA WOULD
BE ELIGIBLE AND THAT WOULD SAVE
ON THE PAPERWORK TO. SO IT'S
NOT A PANACEA BECAUSE MAYBE
THERE'S SOMEBODY WHO DOESN'T
LIVE IN ONE OF THOSE AREAS BUT
WE THINK IF YOU LOOK UP AND
DOWN CALIFORNIA. THOSE ARE THE
AREAS WHERE YOU COULD YOU COULD
REACH. A LOT OF FAMILIES THAT
MAKE JUST TOO MUCH TO BECOME
ELIGIBLE. FOR STATE PRESCHOOL
AND THE AND THE FRUSTRATING
THING AS WELL IS THAT EVERY
YEAR. WE WOULD PUT MONEY BACK
YOU KNOW ONE THE MOST
DISAPPOINTING ABOUT THIS JOB.
IS DONE CHILD CARE AND KEPT CAL
GRANT EVERY YEAR IT'S LIKE FELT
NOT ENOUGH WE'RE GONNA SEND IT
OVER HERE SO I ALWAYS THINK
THAT MONEY IS GOING TO.
DEPARTMENT OF CORRECTIONS OR
SOMEWHERE ELSE IT'S NOT WHAT
WE'RE ALL ABOUT SO. IT'S BEEN
TO FOR YOU KNOW HELPING MAKE
SURE WE SERVE MORE KIDS BUT
ALSO. THE KIDS TO FAMILIES WHO
JUST MISSED OUT SO BUT IF WE DO
THE TRANSITION A TRANSITIONAL
KINDERGARTEN OF COURSE. THOSE
MONIES- AND THAT ELIGIBILITY
WILL BE FOR EVERYBODY
REGARDLESS OF INCOME BUT
CORRECT ME IF I'M WRONG THOUGH-
SERRA THAT. IF UNDER THE
EXISTING. SYSTEM PROGRAM AND IF
WE SWITCHED THE THAT WAS TO
COVER FOR ALL SIX. THREE YEAR
OLD. WE CAN CONTINUE WITH THAT
POLICY IN THAT CATCHMENT AREA.
AND ALLOW MORE MIDDLE CLASS
FAMILIES. TO BECOME ELIGIBLE
FOR THE STATE PRESCHOOL
PROGRAM. BOTH PART DAY AND FULL
DAY. THAT IS CORRECT THAT
ADMINISTRATORS STARTED THIS IS
THEIR NUMBER WORKING WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION. IT HE
ADMINISTRATION AND LEGISLATURE
COULD BANG DECIDE TO HAVE THIS
FUNDS CONTINUE IN STATE
PRESCHOOL AND CONTINUE WITH THE
EXPANSION THAT WAS STARTED LAST
YEAR. SO BEYOND THAT CATCHMENT
AREAS THE MASTER PLAN ALSO
CALLED OUT CHILDREN WITH
DISABILITIES. AND WE ARE
RECOMMENDING THAT CHILDREN
WITH. INDIVIDUAL FAMILY SERVICE
PLAN AS WELL AS INDIVIDUALIZED
EDUCATION PLANS. SO THAT. YOUNG
OLDER TWO GIRLS IS THE
TRANSITION FROM AN IFSC TO AN
I. E. P. IN THE SYSTEM. THE
THAT ELIGIBILITY AND ABILITY TO
PARTICIPATE IN THE CALIFORNIA
STATE PROGRAM WOULD CREATE AS
THE SPACE. WITH EARLY
INTERVENTION COMPONENTS TO
RELEASE THE COURT FOUND. THAT
WE WOULD EXPAND RECOMMEND
EXPANDING BOTH BY CONTINUING
THE CATCHMENT AREA. AND ALSO
INCLUDING CHILDREN WITH
DISABILITIES AS AN AUTOMATIC
ELIGIBILITY AND THAT FITS WITH
THE MASTER PLAN ALSO. YEAH AND
JUST TO CLARIFY WE WOULD HAVE
TO DO ANYTHING DIFFERENT IN
STATE LAW IT IT. IT WOULD IT
WOULD HAVE TO THE NO CHANGES
WOULD BE NEEDED JUST. CONTINUAL
WHAT THE CURRENT LAW IS. RIGHT
OKAY THANK YOU I THANK YOU FOR
THE I'M THE PRESENT. THIS WAS
VERY. AND WE WILL HOLD THIS
ISSUE OPENED AND CERTAINLY
REVISIT. THIS WITH THAT ROBUST
EASY PACKAGE FROM THE ASSEMBLY
AFTER THE MAY REVISE. ISSUE
NUMBER FIVE FINAL ISSUE THE DAY
THIS IS RELATED TO A
TRANSITIONING CHILD CARE. FROM
THE DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION TO
THE DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL
SERVICES. SOWE'RE GONNA START
WITH BERMAN SOCIAL SERVICES-
DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION AND
FINALLY THE L. A. L. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR KIM JOHNSON
DEPARTMENTS SOCIAL SERVICES-
AND REALLY APPRECIATE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO TALK A LITTLE
BIT ABOUT THE WORK WE'VE BEEN
DOING. ON THE TRANSITION WHICH
WILL BE EFFECTIVE JULY ONE IF
THIS YEAR I WOULD JUST WANNA
FIRST AT PRECIADO AT DEPARTMENT
EDUCATION AND THEIR TEAM WHO
HAVE BEEN PROVIDING US WITH
QUITE A BIT OF THEIR TIME AT
SUPPORTING THE ONBOARDING TO
ENSURE THAT WE ARE HOLDING TRUE
TO PRIORITIES THAT WE JOINED
SHARE AROUND. AT YOUR INITIAL
DISRUPTION IN CONTRACTS OUT
CERTAINLY HEARD FROM YOUR PRIOR
PANEL THAT MAKING SURE THAT
THEY'RE SPENDING FLEXIBILITY
BETWEEN THE FUNDING STREAMS
THAT EXIST TODAY ARE REPORTING
CETERA WE HAVE I USE ALSO WHEN
I THINK THAT. THAT COURSE OUR
TEAM BUT ALSO. ALL OF THOSE. OF
THOUSAND OF INTO THE ACROSS
CALIFORNIA ELEVEN GAUGE WITH US
OVER THE COURSE OF THE LAST
SEVERAL MONTHS. I PROVIDING
INPUT HELPING US STEER OUR
PRIORITIES HAVING FOCUS GROUPS
ON CONTRACTS ON EQUITY ON A
NUMBER OF ISSUES THAT AT THOSE
HOLD DEAR IN TERMS OF WANTING
TO BOTH MAINTAIN. AND WHAT'S
WORKING IN THE EXISTING SYSTEM
IT WHERE WE WANT TO ALWAYS
CONTINUE TO IMPROVE. ACROSS
WHAT WE'RE DOING SO I JUST
AGAIN APPRECIATE ALL THE
ENGAGEMENT OF STAKEHOLDERS
ACROSS THE WAY WE HAD SOME
CONVERSATION EARLY CHILDHOOD
POLICY COUNCIL MEETINGS. AND
OTHER FORUMS- ACROSS THE STATE
SO I WE ARE EXCITED ABOUT THE
OPPORTUNITY WE CERTAINLY. WE
HAVE A COUPLE OF DIFFERENT-
MEMBERS OF THE TEAM HERE AT THE
DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL SERVICES
THAT WILL SPEAK TO SOME OF THE
SPECIFICS OF WHERE WE ARE. AT
THE FOCUS OF YOUR QUESTIONS
NEED CHEN THAT WHICH DOES A
GREAT JOB OF OUTLINING SOME
PLACES THAT WE ARE WE JUST
RECENTLY RELEASED THE
TRANSITION PLAN. TRAILER BILL
LANGUAGE THAT LOOK AT THE
COMPONENTS ARE COMING TOGETHER
I WE WILL BE READY FOR THIS
TRANSITION IN JULY. I IT
CERTAINLY IN THE PLACES WHERE
WE WANT TO MAKE SURE THEY GET
THERE IS NO DISRUPTION TO THE
PRINCIPLES. WANT TO KEEP THINGS
LIKE CERTAIN CLOSE OUTS OF.
FINANCIAL BOOKS ARE REPORTING
EXTENDER THAT YOU'LL HEAR MORE
ABOUT SO AGAIN ADMITTEDLY
GRATEFUL FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
TRULY EMBEDDED ENGAGE THIS
ACROSS THE HEALTH AND HUMAN
SERVICES ARRAY. HUGE AGAIN
APPRECIATION FOR THE CONTINUED
CONNECTION TO EDUCATION AS WELL
SO I WITH. THAT I WILL TURN IT
OVER TO CHEN CHOI. THANK YOU
DIRECTOR JOHNSON. AGAIN ADD
TEMPERATURE IN THE THAT
DIRECTOR AT THE- OF. SORT I'M
JUST ONE AFTER YOU JUST TEACHER
AND THEN- ALSO OFFER THE
OPPORTUNITY MY COLLEAGUE MISTER
FIVE. OFFICER TO DO THE SAME-
SO HE- PRESBYTERIANS THAT YOU
HAVE FOR THE SPRING TWO LESS
THE SPECIFIC PROGRAMS THAT OUR-
SCHEDULED TO TRANSITION FROM
THE DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION TO
THE DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL
SERVICES. AFFECTIVE JULY. ONE
TWENTY TWENTY ONE. THOSE
PROGRAMS WILL- OUR COMMUNITY
CARE LICENSING PROGRAMS AT THE
DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL SERVICES
ALONG WITH THE EMERGENCY CHILD
CARE BRIDGE PROGRAM FOR FOSTER
CHILDREN THE CAL WORKS STAGE
ONE CHANNEL CARE PROGRAM. AND
ARE CAL WORKS IN NUTRITION
PROGRAMS IN A NUMBER OF OTHER
SAFETY NET PROGRAMS THAT SERVE-
THE FAMILIES WERE ALSO
RECEIVING SUBSIDIZED CHILDCARE-
DIRECTOR JOHNSON MENTIONED.
WHATEVER TOP PRIORITIES WITHIN
THIS TRANSITION IS TO ENSURE
THE CONTINUITY OF SERVICES AND
SUPPORTS ACROSS THE SYSTEM AND
THAT THERE IS NO DISRUPTION TO.
TO CARE BEING RECEIVED INTO THE
PROVIDERS THAT BACK HERE- AS A
RESULT OF THE TRANSITIONS THAT
WE ARE HOLDING THAT AND THE
HIGHEST PRIORITY WE DO ALSO
WANT TO TAKE ADVANTAGE OF
OPPORTUNITIES TO INTEGRATE THE
SYSTEM AND TO BUILD ON OUR
SUCCESSES. WHERE THERE ARE
OPPORTUNITIES FOR IMPROVEMENT.
SO WE HAVE BEEN WORKING VERY
VERY CLOSELY WITH CDP ROUTE
THIS TRANSITION AS DIRECTOR
JOHNSON MENTIONED. AND WE'RE
VERY GRATEFUL FOR THAT
PARTNERSHIP WE HAVE A NUMBER OF
INTERNAL WORKGROUPS. AB CD HAS
BEEN DOING A NUMBER OF WALK
THROUGHS FOR US OF. HE DETAILED
LEVEL SO THAT CAN BE READY TO
OPERATIONAL DUTIES AS OF JULY
ONE AND IN SOME CASES EVEN AND
PREPARING FOR THAT BEFORE HIM.
WE HAVE A WORK GROUPS ON THE
TOPICS OF FACILITIES AND SPACE
PLANNING INFORMATION TECHNOLOGY
SUPPORTS CONTRACTS FISCAL
POLICY DEVELOPMENT. HUMAN
RESOURCES LABOR RELATIONS THE
LADY'S LICENSING AUDITING AND
AUDITING AND MONITORING- AND WE
ARE MEETING MONTHLY WITH THE
STAFF WHO WILL BE TRANSITIONING
OVER FROM CITY. TO CITY AFFECT
AS A WHOLE IN ADDITION TO ALL
OF THAT DAILY AND WEEKLY
MEETINGS THAT ARE HAPPENING
BETWEEN OUR TEAMS AT VARIOUS
LEVELS. WE ALSO HAD A COUPLE A
BIT OF SIGNIFICANT ENGAGEMENT
WITH- THE STAKEHOLDERS
THROUGHOUT THIS TRANSITION SO
THAT WE CAN BE SURE TO HEAR A
PRIORITIES AND- I THINK WHAT WE
CAN ACCOMPLISH TOGETHER SO WE
HAVE A DEDICATED PUBLIC WEB
PAGE- FOR THE TRANSITION IT WAS
LAUNCHED IN AUGUST OF TWENTY
TWENTY THERE'S- FEEDBACK FORMS
AND SURVEYS IN ENGLISH AND
SPANISH. WE'VE RECEIVED LOTS OF
FEEDBACK VIA THOSE FORMS SO FAR
WE ALSO HAVE QUARTERLY
STAKEHOLDER MEETINGS WE'VE HAD
OVER A THOUSAND PARTICIPANTS AT
A TIME JOIN THOSE MEETINGS SO
FAR. WE'VE HAD IT TOPICS
SPECIFIC TO OUR LISTENING
SESSION. ON CONTRACTS ON THE
ISSUES SPECIFIC TO RURAL AREAS
ON EQUITY ISSUES AND A WHOLE
CHILD WHOLE FAMILY APPROACHES
TO MEETING CHILDREN AND
FAMILIES NEEDS. WE HAVE SOME
ADDITIONAL THESE LISTENING
SESSIONS ALSO PLANS. AND IN
ADDITION WE HAVE PROVIDED
QUARTERLY LEGISLATOR REPORTS-
SO THAT WE CAN BE SURE TO KEEP
YOU ALL INFORMED OF THE
TRANSITION- PROGRESS AS THIS
YEAR HAS GONE UP. SO IT'S
DIRECTOR JOHNSON MENTIONED WE
DID ALSO RECENTLY RELEASED THE
DRAFT OF THE TRANSITION PLAN
SOME EXCERPTS OF WHICH ARE IN
YOUR MATERIALS FOR THE HEARING.
THE COMMENTS ON THAT PLAN OR DO
YOU ON MARCH SIXTEENTH WITH
THAT FINAL PLAN DUE TO ALL OF
YOU BEFORE APRIL FIRST SO WE
ARE- ON TRACK TO PROVIDE. TO
PROVIDE THAT FINAL PLAN ON TIME
AND WE ARE LOOKING FORWARD TO
CONTINUING TO REFLECT THE
COMMENTS. THAT WE ARE CURRENTLY
RECEIVING- WHAT WE DO ALSO.
HAVE THE OF THE APPOINTMENT OUR-
TO. OF THE CARE DEVELOP
DIVISION WHICH IS A NEWLY
FORMED OF ITS OWN WITHIN THE
DEPARTMENT. DR BUFFET HIGH MAY
MYLAN IS JOINING US WITH THAT
RICH AND DEEP AND LONG HISTORY
IN THE EARLY CARE AND EDUCATION
FIELD AND WE'RE VERY FORTUNATE
TO HAVE HER- ONBOARD NOW. AS WE
PREPARE FOR JULY ONE- AS THE
DIRECTOR ALSO MENTIONED HE DID
PREVIOUS- TRAILER BILL EARLIER
THIS WEEK AND IS AT IT IS
VOLUMINOUS IN THE NUMBER OF
PAGES BUT AB. TECHNICAL IN
NATURE SO THAT TRAILER BILL IS-
ACCOMPLISHING THE MOVE OF A
SIGNIFICANT NUMBER OF CODES AND
STATUTES FROM THE EDUCATION
CODE TO THE WELFARE AND
INSTITUTIONS CODE. TO REFLECT
THE CHANGE IN- ADMINISTRATION
OF THE PROGRAM. SO WE VERY MUCH
LOOK FORWARD TO CONTINUING TO
ENGAGE WITH WITH ALL OF YOU IN
THE LEGISLATURE AND WITH
STAKEHOLDERS TO ENSURE THAT WE
ARE COMPLETELY PREPARED FOR
SMOOTH OPERATIONS- IN ADVANCE
OF AND ON JULY ONE AND THAT WE
CAN ACHIEVE OUR SPECTACLES. THE
FUTURE AFTER JULY. TO THAT END
THEY TO WANT TO OPERATE
OPPORTUNITY FOR MY- AND CHAT.
IS OUR G. OPERATING OFFICER
SHARE JUST A COUPLE OF KEY KEY
HIGHLIGHTS ON A FEW OPERATIONAL
ASPECTS OF THE TRANSITION AS
WELL. GOOD AFTERNOON. SALINAS
CHARITY PROPERTY OFFICER
I JUST WANT TO EMPHASIZE A
COUPLE CRITICAL AREAS THAT WE
HAVE BEEN WORKING CLOSELY WITH
DVD THE TRANSITION PLANNING- AS
PREVIOUSLY MENTIONED THE
IMMEDIATE PRIORITY FOR US IS
THE CONTINUITY OF OPERATIONS
PARTICULARLY THE SERVICES FOR
FAMILIES AND TIMELY CONTRACTS
AND PAYMENTS. TO SUPPORT THE
WORK FORCE AND ENSURE THAT
THERE'S NO DISTRACTION SO WE
HAVE BEEN WORKING CLOSELY WITH
DEFEAT TO IDENTIFY SCHEDULES OR
TIMELY AND SUCCESSFUL EXECUTION
OF THOSE CONTRACTS HAEMANTHUS.
REPORTING AND OTHER RELATED
REQUIREMENTS AS WELL AS
IDENTIFYING WHAT IT WHAT ARE
THE MOST EFFICIENT PROCESS
NEEDS TO COMPLETE THE BUDGET
CYCLES WITHOUT DESTRUCTION. AT
THE LATEST UPDATE IS THAT OUR
CONTRACT RENEWAL LANGUAGE HAVE
BEEN DRAFTED TO REFLECT THAT
RESPONSIBILITY TRANSFERRING TO
SEE CSS. AND IS CURRENTLY IN
THE REVIEW PROCESS WITH THE
REQUIRED OVERSIGHT AGENCIES. SO
WE- ANTICIPATE THAT CONTRACT
WILL BE EXECUTED ON TIME FOR
JULY ONE AND THAT CONTRACTORS
WILL BE ABLE TO RECEIVE HIM IN
DANCES AS THEY USUALLY DO. THE
OTHER CRITICAL TO EMPHASIZE IS
R. I. T. T. SYSTEMS SO WE HAVE
IDENTIFIED THAT THOSE SYSTEMS
ARE CRITICAL FOR THE CONTINUITY
OF THE OPERATIONS OF BOTH
DEPARTMENTS. DO YOU HAVE
PROGRAMS THAT ARE DEPENDENT ON
THE EXISTING DATA SYSTEMS AND
OUR CONTRACTORS DIRECTLY INPUT
DATA INTO THE SYSTEMS AS WELL.
SO WHILE THE I. T. SYSTEMS NEED
TO REMAIN AT THE EACH INSURE
THAT THERE'S NO DISTRACTIONS WE
ARE WORKING TOGETHER ON DATA
SYSTEMS ACCESS. AND TESTING TO
ENSURE THAT THE STOCK THAT ARE
TRANSFERRING OVER PROCEED WOULD
HAVE REMOTE ACCESS TO THE
SYSTEMS AND ABLE TO PERFORM. AT
THE DATA AND CONTRACT
PROCESSING AND THEY USUALLY DO.
AT HOME SO I'M I'M- SO I WILL
LET IT UP QUESTIONS OR IT OVER
TO THE NEXT MOST YES NEXT
PLEASE. THANK YOU SO MUCH GOOD
AFTERNOON YET AGAIN TEARS
MEMBER HAS THEIR NUMBER MORGAN
DEPUTY SUPERINTENDENT AT THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION ON BEHALF OF STATE
SUPERINTENDENT OF PUBLIC
INSTRUCTION. OVER THE LAST YEAR
THE CITY HAS BEEN CORDONING THE
CDS THAT TO DETERMINE HOW TO
SUCCESSFULLY IMPLEMENT THE
TRANSITION WHILE MINIMIZING
DISRUPTION TO CHILDREN FAMILY
AND OUR PROGRAMS AND
CONTRACTORS. BEFORE I GET AGAIN
I HAVE TO GIVE A REALLY HUGE
THANKS AND KUDOS TO MY CD TEAM
WITHOUT THEM AND THEIR DEEP
DEDICATION TO CHILDREN AND
FAMILIES MANIFEST WOULD BE
SUCCESSFUL. THEY ARE WORKING
DAY AND NIGHT TO REALLY ADDRESS
ALL OF THE NEEDS DESPITE NOT
RECEIVING ADDITIONAL RESOURCES
TO ADDRESS THE TRANSITION HE
HAS COMMITTED SIGNIFICANT TIME
AND ATTENTION TO SUPPORTING IT.
I'D LIKE TO BRIEFLY COTTON
PIECES WE'VE DONE AROUND THAT
TREND SESSION TO GIVE YOU A
SENSE OF THE SCOPE OF THE WORK.
IN SOME INSTANCES STAFF HAVE
BEEN SUBJECT TO A 3240%
INCREASE IN WORKLOAD TO
ACCOMMODATE THE NECESSARY STEPS
TO PLAN AND EXECUTE THE
TRANSITION. WHILE ALSO
ADDRESSING THE PRIORITIES
RELATED TO THE TO THE PANDEMIC
AND GETTING ADDITIONAL FUNDS
OUT TO THE FIELD. AND RECEIVING
A NEARLY 10% HE KEPT
THEMSELVES. OVER ARCHING AT CD
WE HAVE SHARED HUNDREDS OF
DOCUMENTS AND HOSTED DOZENS OF
MEETINGS IN AN EFFORT TO GET
CDS THAT THE INFORMATION ABOUT
THE PROGRAMS AND SYSTEMS
TRANSITIONING. ACTIVE JULY
FIRST TWENTY TWENTY ONE. MORE
SPECIFICALLY CDS DEVELOPED
MATERIALS AND JOINED AND
PRESENTED AT MORE THAN SIXTY
CREAMY. WALK THROUGH
PRESENTATIONS AND PRIVATE
MEETINGS ON A BROAD RANGE OF
ISSUES WE'VE IDENTIFIED
DEVELOPED AND PROVIDED NEARLY A
THOUSAND FILES THAT INCLUDE
PROCEDURES MANUALS PROCESS
THESE. CHARTS TRAINING AND A
COMPREHENSIVE TRANSITION
INVENTORY THAT IDENTIFIES AND
DESCRIBES A HUNDRED AND SEVENTY
FIVE SERVICES AND FUNCTIONS AND
INCLUDES OVER A HUNDRED NEEDING
ONE ATTACHMENT. PROCESS EVEN
RESOURCES. I DIPLOMA ABOUT MISS
CHANCES WE MIGHT TO AREAS WHERE
AN INNER. AGREEMENT ARMOR
ENGINE FUNDERS. MAYBE NOT NEED
TO MAKE TO. SIX POST JULY.
ESPECIALLY IN THE AREA WITH THE
THAT MAY NOT BE TO IMPLEMENT IN
TERMS OF DATA AND PAYMENTS. IN
ADDITION CITY KERR. AND CAN TO
THE TRANSITION THE ENCINITAS
THAT'S RECENTLY POSTED AS WELL
AS TO THE ORDERLY TRANSITION
REPORT. ONLY PROVIDED
SIGNIFICANT TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE ON THAT SHRINK THEIR
BALANCE AS WELL AS PROVIDING
OUR OWN TO ENSURE THAT THAT
COMPONENTS RELATED DISTINCT
SPEAKER PROGRAM REMAINS IN
EDUCATION BECAUSE- I. WORKS
WITH THE TRANSITION TOGETHER
WITH CDS THAT THERE ARE SEVERAL
AREAS WHERE DECISIONS IN OUR
SOLUTION STILL NEEDING I WOULD.
CSS WITH A KEY DECISION
DOCUMENT WE CONTINUE TO WORK
WITH THEM I FEEL LIKE THEY
PROBABLY SAY WE INCREASE THE
NUMBER OF MEETINGS SO THAT WE
CAN ADDRESS SOME OF THESE HIGH
LEVEL SOLUTIONS AND DECISIONS.
IT SEEMS THAT EVERY TIME THEY
LAND ON ONE DECISION THERE'S
ABOUT FIVE TO MORE MAYBE TWENTY
THINGS THAT ARE. UNDERNEATH
THAT THAT THAT HAVE TO BE
DECIDED. THEY WILL WORK. THIRTY
TWO TWO DEPARTMENTS AFTER THE
TRANSITION. THAT- SO THOSE
DECISIONS ON HOW TO DETERMINE
THE WHICH TO PARK WILL BE
RESPONSIBLE FOR THE PAYMENTS
THE BEGINNING OF THE TRANSITION
THOSE ARE ALL KEEPING THAT WILL
HAVE TO DEAL WITH. ANOTHER
ISSUE STILL PENDING BECAUSE
WHICH DEPARTMENT WILL BE
RESPONSIBLE FOR THE FEDERAL
REPORTING FOR THE FIRST FISCAL
YEAR AS THESE EXPENDITURES WILL
CROSS THE STATE FISCAL YEARS
AND FEDERAL FISCAL YEARS.
ANOTHER CHALLENGE THAT THE
TRANSITION IS THAT CURRENT THE
CONTRACTORS TRANSFER FUNDS
BETWEEN THEIR CTR WHICH- INFANT
TODDLER IN SCHOOL AGE DIRECT
CONTACT IT PROGRAMS AND THE
CALIFORNIA STATE SCHOOL.
PROGRAM CONTRACTS. IN THE- GEN
THIS YEAR HE WILL BE WITH. AND
THAT'S EASY TO WILL BE THE YEAR
THAT. INVOLVED DISCUSSION WITH
THE OF FINANCE AND CDS. THAT
VEHICLE A LOT TO CAR AFTER THAT
TRANSIT HAS YET TO BE
DETERMINED. ADDITIONAL THERE
ARE CONCERN ABOUT PROGRAM AND
NOT PART OF FEDERAL YEAR. WHICH
ENDS SEPTEMBER THIRTIETH AND
THE NECESSARY YEAR AND ACTIVITY.
FINALLY WE WANT TO THANK ALL OF
YOU GET ANOTHER AND ADDRESSED
ITEM WHICH IS HELLO THIS DCF
QUALITY PLANS CAN CONTINUE TO
SUPPORT THE CALIFORNIA STATE
PRESCHOOL PROGRAM. AFTER THE
TRANSITION YES HE REPRESENTS
ABOUT 42% CALIFORNIA'S
SUBSIDIZED EARLY NOT CONSISTENT
SO WE FELT THAT IT'S CRITICAL
THAT CD HAS A PORTION OF THE
SCENE. YEAH ALL THE PLANS THAT
CAN THEN BE DEDICATED TO
SUPPORTING THE PROGRAMS THAT
SUPPORT SO MANY OF CALIFORNIANS
YOUNG CHILDREN. WE KNOWS THE
STP WILL CONTINUE TO NEED
RESOURCES TO SUPPORT
PROFESSIONAL DEVELOPMENT CHILD
ASSESSMENTS THE PRESCHOOL
LEARNING FOUNDATIONS AND OTHER
RESOURCES. SB YEAH QUALITY
FUNDS ARE ALLOCATED TO SEE EACH
IN NINETEEN THAT SUPPORTS THIS
YES HE WILL MEET ANOTHER
FUNDING SOURCE TO ENSURE
PROFESSIONAL DEVELOPMENT AND
RESOURCES. THAT SUPPORT
ALIGNMENT TO WORKING A GARDEN
STANDARDS. GOVERNING CONTINUE.
I A RESULT OF THESE OUT I. AND
AS WE HAVE TIME WORK THROUGH
THE TRANS AND IS WHAT TEACHER.
SIXTEEN PROGRAM. AND A HUNDRED
NINETY STAFF ANOTHER STATE A-
WE SHARE SOME THAT CONCERN TO
THE- ABOUT CONTINUE THAT THAT.
AS IT'S CURRENTLY NAMED
ESPECIALLY AROUND ISSUES
RELATING TO THE INTERACTIONS
BETWEEN THE STATE'S FISCAL
PROGRAM AND THE GENERAL CHILD
CARE OR C. C. R. PROGRAMMING.
AS WELL AS THE CHILD I DON'T
CARE THE PROGRAM AND THE SEVEN
OTHER CHILD NUTRITION PROGRAMS.
OVERALL DIRECT CONTRACTED
PROGRAMS ARE ADMINISTERED VERY
DIFFERENTLY THAN BACHELOR
PROGRAMS AND HELPED ME
EDUCATION QUALITY STANDARDS.
THANKS THE TRANSITION AND SPLIT
UP DIRECT SERVICE PROGRAMS MORE
BURDENSOME FOR THOSE IN THE
FIELD THAT ADMINISTERS THE SB
THREE PLUS ANOTHER DIRECT
CONTRACT PROGRAM. THE NEED TO
REPORT AND BY DEDUCTIBLES ET
NCSS. AND IT'S ALSO MORE
EXPENSIVE FOR THE STATE AND
STATE STAFF RESOURCES WILL BE
NEEDED TO SUPPORT. PROGRAMS
AROUND MONITORING TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE AT. POSTI IN CDS
THAT. THE CONCERN THAT WE HAVE
IS THE INABILITY TO FULLY
TRANSPARENT HAD START.
PARTNERSHIP AS IT'S A- FEDERAL.
SPENCER OF BEING TO DO CITY IS
THAT. WILL HAVE TO AND IN TO
WIN AMONG. IN ORDER FOR CD TO
CONTINUE OPERATING IT. RATHER
THAN NEEDING TO RELINQUISH THE
GRANT AND HAVE OTHERS
COMPETITIVELY UP THANKS FOR.
MOVING INTO THE STATE COMPONENT
AT THE TRANSITION AND OTHER
CONSIDERATIONS. CD WILL NEED
SIGNIFICANT STAFF RESOURCES TO
CONTINUE OUR CURRENT EVENT
MODIFIED SUPPORTS TO OUR
CONTRACTORS. WHILE MANY
PROGRAMS WILL BE TRANSITIONING
TO CDS THAT. AS WELL AS THE
MATCH ASK MAJORITY AT THIS CD
EIGHTEEN ADMINISTERING THE
EARLY LEARNING CARE PROGRAMS.
CITY WHAT ACTUALLY CONTINUE TO
SUPPORT 90% OF ITS CURRENT
CONTRACTORS. WILL HAVE SIX
HUNDRED AND EIGHTY NINE
CONTRACTORS THAT IMPLEMENTS THE
S. B. HE- DOWN FROM THE SEVEN
HUNDRED FIFTY NINE CURRENTLY
THAT WE START. SIMILARITY ABOUT
FROM THAT THIRTY THREE HUNDRED
LOCAL EDUCATIONAL AGENCIES AND
CONTRACTORS. OPERATE OUR
FEDERAL CHILD NUTRITION
PROGRAMS THIS CD WILL CONTINUE
TO SUPPORT NEARLY TWO THOUSAND.
AT THOSE THIRTEEN. OVER TWELVE
THOUSAND MEALS AT. OVER TWELVE
THOUSAND YOUNG SITES. IN
ADDITION BECAUSE MANY CRACKS
WILL HAVE RELATIONS WITH BOTH
CD AND CD. OKAY WHAT NEW
RELATED TO. THE MONEY DATA
SHARING A TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE
ACROSS OUR TO STATE AGENCIES.
DECISIONS TRANSFERRING TO THE
CDS THAT HAVE BEEN IDENTIFIED
YOU DEFINING AND CONNECTION.
ONE OF THE QUESTIONS THAT WAS
ON THERE WAS AROUND MY WITH CD
STILL NEED THEM. THE MAJORITY
OF THE POSITIONS THAT HAVE
SUPPORTED OUR EARLY LEARNING
CARE PROGRAMS HAVE BEEN
SUPPORTED BY THE CEO OR THE
CHILD CARE DEVELOPMENT BLOCK
GRANT. AND NOT HAS BEEN
IDENTIFIED TO TRANSFER TO CBS
THAT THE MAJORITY OF STATE
OPERATION FUNDING FOR ALL OF
THAT REALLY KEEN FOR NAPPIES
AND SUPPORTED BUT CHILD CARE
YEAH YES THE- SERVICE DIRECTLY
WE HAVEN'T HAD MUCH GENERAL
FUND IN THIS PART OF THE
SYSTEM. THE SAME PER THE CNCF
HE ARE THEIR CHILD ADULT CARE
FOOD PROGRAM THE FEDERAL STATE
ADMINISTRATIVE FUNDS CAN BE
USED TO SUPPORT THE COLLECTIVE
OF THE MEAL PROGRAMS THAT CD
HAS BEEN OPERATING SAID THAT
TRANSITION AND IT WAS OUT THE
CHILD ADULT CARE FOOD PROGRAM
TO BE A STANDALONE. AND IT
SPENDING THAT HAS BEEN
SUPPORTING THE MONITORING OF
ALL OF THIS OTHER MEAL PROGRAMS
THAT CD IS. THAT CORRECT. THANK
YOU SO FOR THAT HAVE ITS
ARTISTIC TODAY. AND AT. THAT
SPEAKER GOES I'M HAPPY ANSWER
ANY QUESTIONS THAT YOU MIGHT
HAVE. THEY YOU LASTLY A LA
WHICH I KNOW HOW SOME. COMMENTS
THIS- IS. THANK IT AFTER
AGAINST QUIRKS LEGISLATE
ANALYST OFFICE SO THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET PROPOSES-
SHIFTING THREE BILLION AND
LOCAL ASSISTANCE FROM SEAT TO
SEAT YES ASK THE BUDGET ALSO
SHIPS THIRTY TWO MILLION AND
STATE OPERATIONS PROCEED TO BE
ACCESS AND LASTLY THE BUDGET
THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET INCLUDES
THIRTEEN MILLION I'M GOING
GENERAL FUND TO BACK FILL SOME
OF THE POSITIONS BEING PROPOSED
TO TRANSFER TO DEATH. THE
ADMINISTRATION OF THE WOULD NOT
HAVE SUFFICIENT STAFF TO
MINISTER THE PROGRAM FOR ME TO
EAT WITH A LOCAL STATE
OPERATIONS. BEING SHIFTED TO
THE S. WE THAT TO DATE THERE A
LOT OF UNKNOWN IN. ABOUT TREND
OR THE MINUTE THE- TO SIX
ADMINISTERED ITS PROGRAMS BY
JULY FIRST FOR EXAMPLE THE FULL
COST OF THE TRANSITION RIGHT.
ARE UNCLEAR OF THE MINISTRATION
NOTED IT'S CONTINUING TO ASSESS
THE RESOURCES AND STAFFING
NEEDED. WE WOULD NOTE THAT THE
COSTS WE ARE AWARE OF. THE
THIRTEEN MILLION TO BACK FILL
POSITIONS ACCEDI E. ARE MUCH
HIGHER THAN ANTICIPATED. GIVEN
THAT INCLUDES SEEDS- THE COST
OF THE PROPOSAL THE
ADMINISTRATION TO LAST YEAR DUE
TO COST CONCERNS. THE LAST
THING WE NOTE REGARDING THE
COST OF THE PROPOSAL IS THAT
THESE COSTS ARE ASSOCIATED WITH
BUT BEING ABLE TO MAINTAIN THE
SAME LEVEL OF STATE
ADMINISTRATION. BUT NOT HAVING
THAT ADMINISTRATION HAPPENING
WITHIN. THE HAVING BUT WITH
WITHIN A DIFFERENT STATE. THE
COSTS ARE NOT ASSOCIATED WITH
ANY SPECIFIC IMPROVEMENTS. TO
STATE LEVEL ADMINISTRATION. BUT
WE RECKON THE LEGISLATURE
APPROVED THIS TWENTY OF OUR OF
THE TWENTY TWENTY ONE BUDGET.
YOU THERE FOR WE KNOW SO FAR
THE LEGISLATURE MAY WANT TO
RECONSIDER CONTINUING WITH THE
TRANSITION PLAN AND HAVE
SEVERAL OPTIONS. THE FIRST
OPTION IS TO STOP THE
TRANSITION THE LEGISLATURE
COULD DECIDE TRANSITIONING
CHILDCARE AND CFCF FEATURED YES
THAT. IS NO LONGER A PRIORITY
AND THIS WOULD FREE UP THIRTEEN
MILLION AN ONGOING GENERAL AND
RELATIVE TO THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET PROPOSAL THAT WOULD BE
AVAILABLE TO SUPPORT
LEGISLATIVE PRIORITIES. THE
SECOND OPTION IS FOR THE
LEGISLATURE- IT COULD DELAY THE
TRANSITION SO THIS WOULD ALLOW
THE ADMINISTRATION TO FOCUS ITS
ENTIRE INTENTION ON THE
PANDEMIC RESPONSE. AND PLAN FOR
THE TRANSITION ON A SLOWER TIME
LINE. WE CAN DELAY THE
TRANSITION UNTIL YEAR AFTER THE
CALL THE NINETEEN EMERGENCY
DECLARATION HAS ENDED WOULD BE
A REASONABLE APPROACH. THE
THIRD OPTION IS TO MODIFY THE
SCOPE OF TRANSITION. THE
LEGISLATURE COULD REDUCE THE
NUMBER OF PROGRAMS. YES ASK IF
THE LEGISLATURE TAKES THIS
APPROACH WE RECOMMEND KEEPING
CA CFP ACCEDE GIVEN THE COSTS
ASSOCIATED WITH SHIFTING THIS
PROGRAM SPECIFICALLY. AND THE
LEGISLATURE COULD FURTHER
MINIMIZE THE SCOPE OF THE
TRANSITION BY ALSO SHIFTING
CERTAIN CHILD CARE PROGRAMS GSS
SUCH AS- JUST SHIFTING POWERS
CHANNEL CHRISTY JUST TWO AND
THREE WITH THE REST OF THE
CHILD CARE PROGRAM FOR ME AT
THE E. TAKING A SMALLER SET OF
PROGRAMS COULD BE MAPPED MORE
MANAGEABLE FOR THE
ADMINISTRATION. THE LEGISLATURE
CONSIDERS MAINTAINING THE SAME
LEVEL OVERSIGHT. HAS AND WE
HAVE SINCE MORE TECHNICAL
ORIENTED RECOMMEND THAT OUR IN
HOUSE TO THE END. THE LAST
THING WE KNOW. WELL OUR
ANALYSIS WAS COUPLE BEFORE
ADMISSION REALLY EXTRA. THE
PLAN WE WERE THE DRAFT PLAN IN
REMAIN COULD ABOUT WHERE THE IN.
IN THE FOR AND THE DETAIL IT
HAS THE ABLE TO SHOW SOME. THIS
CONCLUDES REMARKS AND I'M HAPPY
HE PUT. OKAY THANK YOU- I A FEW
QUESTIONS BUT I START WITH.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER RACE. THANK
MISTER I I'VE GOT SAY THAT I
I'M GLAD TO SEE THAT. IS LAST
YEAR I ENTERED AB SIX. WITH THE
OF. HAVING THIS TRANSFER AND-
WE WERE PLEASED TO SEE THE GUY
THROUGH THE BILL LANG- WAS ABLE
TO DO THIS IT I THINK IT'S
IMPORTANT TO NOTE REASON. FOR
THIS AND HAVE AND I IF I MAY RE
JUST CENTER MISTER CHAIR HAVING
ALL CHILD CARE PROGRAMS
ADMINISTERED WITHIN ONE AGENCY
IS INTENDED TO ALLOW FOR
GREATER COLLABORATION INCLUDING
IMPROVED ELIGIBILITY PROCESSES
ACROSS THE VARIOUS DEPARTMENTS
AND PROGRAMS IN SUPPORTING THE
NEEDS OF YOUNG CHILDREN AND
THEIR FAMILIES. I THINK THIS
YEAR I'VE INTRODUCED AB THREE
NINETY THREE TO TWO ALSO HELP
WITH THE SPECIFICS I'M SO GLAD
TO SEE THE PLAN THAT HAS BEEN
PUT TOGETHER. I DO HAVE A FEW
QUESTIONS HOWEVER. AT FIRST I
THOUGHT I WOULD LIKE TO KNOW
WHEN THE ADMINISTRATION WILL
PROVIDE THE TRAILER BILL
RECOMMENDATIONS FOR THE CO
TRANSFERS. AND REGULATORY
AUTHORITY NEEDED TO FOR THE
TRANSITION. THANK YOU ASSEMBLY
MEMBER ESTATE IT'S ACTUALLY
POSTED YESTERDAY SO ADD THAT TO
THE BILL LANGUAGE JUST ABOUT
LIFE IN ON THAT DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCES WEBSITE. WELL THAT'S A
BIT ANSWER I COULD HAVE
RECEIVED THANK YOU- THE ANOTHER
QUESTION. WHY YOU CALIFORNIA'S
PRESCHOOL REMAINING WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION WHAT IS
THE RATIONALE FOR BIFURCATING.
THESE TO EARLY EARNING AND
CARE PROGRAMS A STATE PRESCHOOL
AT CD AND CHILD CARE IT CDSS
AND WHAT ADMINISTRATIVE AND
OTHER TYPES OF BURDENS DOES
THIS PLACE ON PROVIDERS. I'M
GOING TO START THIS AND WITH
DEFERRED OFF MY COLLEAGUES ON
THE PANEL HERE THIS AFTERNOON
TO GET CAN JOHNSON DEPARTMENT
SOCIAL. I WOULD SAY A PART OF
THE- STATE PRESCHOOL REMAIN
WITH THE PART YOU CASE IS.
PARTIALLY SOURCE WITH PROP
NINETY EIGHT AT ALL. MANY THE
THINGS THAT YOU THIS HAS
TALKING HERE TO SEE RELATED TO
THE DIRECT CONNECTION I WOULD
KINDERGARTEN INTO ADDITIONAL
WORK THAT BEEN IT'S BEEN WAY I
WOULD SAY THAT OUT YOU CAN DIM
EITHER BUT CERTAIN REPORT OF
THE SLASH YEAR AT THE
DEPARTMENT EDUCATION. SOCIAL
SERVICES WORK TO IN MANY FORM
WHETHER THEY WORK GROUPS FOR ON
IMPROVEMENTS AS AT CAL WORKS
CHILD CARE STAY MASTER PLAN
EARLY CHILDHOOD POLICY COUNCIL
ARE ALSO. AND PLACES WHERE
THESE HAVE I'VE BEEN IN. IN ON
BASIS FROM YEARS AND WE HAVE TO
COMMIT SECOND THAT- AS I IN IN
THE OPENING REMARK OF ALL
MAKING SURE THAT WE'RE THINKING
VERY. ABOUT THE CONNECTION OF
BEACH CARE ABOUT THE PROGRAM
THAT THE DEPARTMENT SOCIAL WILL
BE. AND THEIR CONNECTION I ONLY
TO PRE K. C. K. BUT ALSO THE
LARGE CAKES PUBLIC EDUCATION
SYSTEM. A PROGRAM IN THE
TRANSITIONAL KINDERGARTEN
PROGRAM. AND THEN IT TO
KINDERGARTEN FIRST SECOND AND
THIRD GRADE. THAT HE GETS
REALIGNMENT IS ACTUALLY EVAN
AND SPACE STRATEGY TO ENSURE
THAT CHILDREN HAVE THE ACT
EARLY INTERVENTION AND SUPPORT
THAT THEY NEED. AND THAT THEY
CONTINUE ON WITH THOSE. WE ALSO
HAVE THE- SPECIAL EDUCATION
PROGRAMS SO AS YOU LOOK AT
WHERE THREE AND FOUR YEAR OLD
AND FIVE YEAR OLDS ARE HAVE
DISABILITIES. THEY'RE ALSO IN
OUR EDUCATIONAL SYSTEM AND WE
THINK THAT CONTINUING WITH THE
S. P. P. ALLOWS FOR THOSE
INCLUSIVE PROGRAMS BE EXPANDED
SO THAT MORE CHILDREN WITH
DISABILITIES CAN BE IN AN
INCLUSIVE PRESCHOOL SETTING.
WITH THEIR PEERS. THANK YOU I
AND I DO WANT TO SAY THAT I
HAVE REALLY APPRECIATED THE
COLLABORATION BETWEEN THE TWO
DEPARTMENTS. IN TRYING TO MAKE
THIS AS SMOOTH A TRANSITION AS
IT POSSIBLY CAN. ALWAYS KEEPING
OUR- WHAT WAS IT THE LITTLEST
OF LEARNERS IN MIND AS WE GO
THROUGH THIS. I APPRECIATE ALSO
THAT TO FROM THE VERY BEGINNING
WITH SPEAKER ANTHONY RENDON'S
BLUE RIBBON COMMISSION AND THE
RECOMMENDATIONS THAT INCLUDED
MUCH OF WHAT WE'RE DOING HERE-
IT'S GOOD TO SEE THAT THE THAT
THE WORK THAT WAS DONE.
ESPECIALLY WITH SO MANY
STAKEHOLDERS IS WHAT IS BEING
IMPLEMENTED. AND I ALSO
APPRECIATE THE COMMENTS EARLIER
ABOUT ALL THE MEETINGS WITH
STAKEHOLDERS. BECAUSE IN THE
END AND THAT'S WHO WE NEED TO
INCLUDE IN ALL OF THIS. R.
ANOTHER QUESTION. ACCORDING TO
SOME STAKEHOLDERS THE CHILD
CARE CONTRACTING PROCESS BEGINS
IN MARCH. WHERE ARE THE
DEPARTMENTS IN A TRANSFERRING
THIS RESPONSIBILITY. TO BOTH MY
COLLEAGUE AT THE DEPARTMENT'S
VISION AND ALSO OUR CHIEF
OPERATING OFFICER WE CHATTED
PROVIDE SPECIFICS. THIS IS
THEIR NUMBER MARKING AT THE
DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION THEN WE
HAVE TO START THIS PROCESS
EASIER ACTUALLY AS WE LOOK AT
OUR CONTRACT AND GETTING THEM
OUT TO THE FIELD AND BEEN
WORKING VERY CLOSELY WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL SERVICES.
AND OUR TEAM HAS BEEN UPDATING
ALL OF THIS CONTRACT THAT THEY
WILL GO OUT THAT REFLECT THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT SOCIAL
SERVICES INSTEAD OF EACH OTHER
CD WILL BE THE ONE THAT SENDS
THEM OUT. AND WE'RE ALSO
WORKING ACROSS OUR TO
DEPARTMENTS ALONG WITH THEIR
LEGAL TO OFFICE AS- YOU UPDATE
A FACE SHEET THAT WILL GO OUT
AS ART OF THAT. SO THAT WHOLE
PROCESS IS BEING UPDATED
SOMEONE TO REFLECT THE
TRANSITION BUT SHOULD BE
FOLLOWING THE SAME TIME LINE
ITEM IT. FOLLOWS EVERY YEAR.
THANK YOU MY PHONE COURSE-
MISTER CHAIR. BUT GIVEN THE
SIGNIFICANT ADDITIONAL WORKLOAD
RELATED TO THE PANDEMIC FOR ALL
STATE AGENCIES BUT HERE MOST
PARTICULARLY FOR THE PARTNER
SOCIAL SERVICES. IS THERE A
NEEDED TO EXTEND THE TIME LINE
FOR THE FULL TRANSITION OF
CHILD CARE PROGRAMS TO DSS.
PRECHECK THE QUEST SENATE
APPRECIATE THE HEAVY LIFT TO
GET ACROSS ACROSS ALL ENTITIES
WE DO IT- IN SERVICE TO WHAT WE
SIGNED UP FOR SO I GET NOW AS
AS I MENTIONED WE'RE ON TRACK
FOR THE TRANSITION THEY HAD THE
TWO COMPONENTS THAT I MENTIONED
RELATED TO RECORDING- IN SOME
FINANCIAL CLOSE OUT THOSE ARE
THE DATA SYSTEMS THAT WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT WHAT WE'RE
WORKING THROUGH THOSE DETAILS
AND AGAIN THAT. THAT THAT
CONVERSATION CONTINUING WE'RE
GETTING THE INPUT RIGHT NOW TO
THE DRAFT TRANSITION PLAN THAT
WE'VE OUTLINED I WE ARE ON
TRACK FOR THE JULY ONE
TRANSITION. WONDERFUL IS THAT
THAT'S ANOTHER ONE OF THOSE
QUICK ANSWERS THE ANSWER IS NO
WE DON'T NEED MORE TIME. THANK
YOU SO MUCH FOR THE HARD WORK
IT MEANS A LOT TO OUR CHILDREN
THANK YOU. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR THANK YOU I JUST WANT TO
FOLLOW UP ON SOME OF YOUR
QUESTIONS- ASSEMBLY MEMBER
REYES AND- YEAH THIS WAS A HOT
ISSUE- LAST YEAR. LAST YEAR TWO
YEARS AGO I SAW A BLUR- YEAH
AND- I WASN'T IN SUPPORT OF IT
AS A HIGH PRIORITY. OF THE
ADMINISTRATION AND I KNOW IT'S
KIND OF I FEEL BAD AFTER IT'S
KIND OF A TURF THING I SEE
SOCIAL SERVICE AND SENIOR ALL
GREAT PEOPLE FOCUSING ON OUR
FAMILIES AND OUR KIDS. AND IT'S
NOT REALLY ABOUT THE TURF OF
WHO OVER OVERSEAS IT BUT WHAT'S
BEST FOR. THE FAMILIES AND
HOW'S THAT ALIGN WITH PROGRAMS
IN CALIFORNIA AND I THINK. THE
DSS SHIFT ESPECIALLY WITH THE
WITH WITH CHILD CARE FOCUSED ON
MORE COORDINATION WITH ALL
SORTS OF ASPECTS OF THE WHOLE
FAMILY AND NO THAT'S BEEN A BIG
PIECE. OF THE GOVERNOR'S MANTRA
I WILL NOTE THAT THIS STATE
PRESCHOOL PROGRAM. I THINK THE
ARGUMENT THAT CERTAIN OF ON
WORKING MADE HIS IS THE ONE
THAT'S SO COMPELLING ONE IT'S
FUNDED UNDER PROP NINETY EIGHT
IT'S REALLY A SCHOOL BASED ONE.
SO KEEPING IT UNDER THE SCHOOL
UMBRELLA I THINK MAKES A LOT OF
SENSE BECAUSE- A LOT OF
PROGRAMS ARE AT ELLIE'S ANYWAY
ARE AT SCHOOLS- NEW RESEARCH
SHOWS HAVING ALIGNMENT WITH.
THE P. THREE THREE IS THE WAY
TO GO TO HAVE A SEAMLESS
TRANSITION HAVE THOSE YOUNGEST
LEARNERS- STEP UP AND GET RID
OF THAT OUT AT THE OPPORTUNITY
GAP OPPORTUNITY GAP. AND SO
HAVING. US FURTHER COORDINATE
BETWEEN- STATE PRESCHOOL AND T.
K. N. FIRST SECOND AND THIRD
GRADE- PROBABLY MAKES THE MOST
SENSE WITH WITH WITH CD- YOU
KNOW I APPRECIATE WHAT L. A. L.
HE IS- IS RECOMMENDING- I'M NOT
SURE IF WE'RE GOING TO. RE
LITIGATE THAT WE HAVE. OTHER
ISSUES AND I KNOW THIS IS A
PRIORITY TO OF ADMINISTRATION
AND- WE STARTED THROUGH THE
EFFORTS I'M I JUST WANT TO
MAYBE ADDRESS SOME OF THE- TO
SOME OF THE SPECIFIC ISSUES.
I'M WE HAVE INCREASED- AND A CD
IS DONE A LOT OF WORK IN THIS
TRANSITION AND I FEEL LIKE
THEY'RE- YOU KNOW DOING OTHER
WORK AND THEN GIVING IT OVER TO
SEE EASE- MESSER DSS SO. ARE WE
PROPERLY- KALRA PAYING FOR
INCOME. STILL THE- FOR. TO DO-
OF THEIR WORK NEEDED THAT'S
THAT'S QUESTION NUMBER. ONE
EFFORT IN MY COLLEAGUES AT THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE RELATED
TO ANYTHING THAT RELATES TO THE
DEPARTMENT THAT'S BUDGET. HI
THIS IS SERRA BURNER ON WITH
THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE- I
APOLOGIZE CAN YOU REPEAT YOUR
QUESTION. YES I JUST WANNA MAKE
SURE THAT WE ARE. THEY WERE
TAKING CARE OF THIS CD E. NEEDS
AS FAR AS THIS TRANSITION. HERE
AS FAR AS MAKING SURE EVER
ADDRESSING THEIR OVERTIME I
KNOW PEOPLE ARE WORKING AROUND
THE CLOCK TO WORK ON THIS AND
TO MAKE SURE THEY HAVE.
ADEQUATE STAFFING TO TAKE CARE
OF THIS. YES SO OF PART OF THE
FEDERAL FUNDING THAT WE HAVE IN
TERMS OF- RECOGNIZING THAT CD
IS DOING SUCH A TREMENDOUS JOB-
ON THIS TRANSITION-
ADMINISTERING THE PROGRAMS
GETTING OUT THESE FEDERAL FUNDS
FOR UNCLE THE NINETEEN RESPONSE
DOES INCLUDE SOME STATE
ADMINISTRATION DOLLARS. ON TO
THE EXTENT THAT WE ARE LOOKING
AT THEIR NEEDS FOR THE BUDGET
YEAR- AND WHAT THEY WILL BE
NEEDING IN TERMS OF STOPPING-
TO SHORE UP SOME OF THEIR
PRESCHOOL NEEDS- THAT WILL BE
REMAINING WE ARE CONTINUING
CONVERSATIONS WITH THEM- AND
REFINING SOME OF OUR ESTIMATES-
IN. ALIGNMENT WITH. THEIR STAFF
TO SELL. ON THERE THERE'S MORE
TO COME ON THAT BUT WE'RE
CONTINUING TO WORK WITH THEM TO
ADDRESS THEIR VARIOUS NEEDS.
OKAY THANK YOU AND THEN AS FAR
AS- THE NEW THEN THE LAST
QUESTION IN THE BILL ON PAGE.
EIGHT THAT THE POSITIONS THAT
WENT TO CD FOR THE FOR THE
CHILD CARE PROGRAMS EVERTEC
BUDGET TWO YEARS AGO. OUT WHAT
HAPPENS TO THE SAID DISARM STAY
WITH. SEEDEATER A ARMOR BONTA
DSS. YES SO THERE'S A FEW
POSITIONS THAT- ARE MOVING OVER
ON AND THEIR SON THAT CITY HAS
IDENTIFIED NOW WILL BE SAYING
AND THEN THERE'S EVEN MORE THAT
CITY HAS IDENTIFIED ON THAT
THAT WE NEED TO CONTINUE TO
WORK ON ON STATE PRESCHOOL- SO
A LOT OF THAT IS OUTLINED IN.
THE ECP THAT'S BECAUSE OUR
WEBSITE- AND AGAIN WHERE WE'RE
CONTINUING TO REFINE SOME OF
THE SYSTEMS YEAH AND LASTLY YOU
KNOW THIS SEEMS LIKE A GROWN UP
PROBLEMS IT'S A SACRAMENTO
PROBLEM WHICH BUREAUCRAT IS
GOING TO YOU KNOW FOCUS ON
PAPERWORK AND CONTRACTS AND SO
FORTH IN THE BIG PICTURE IS A
TRY TO MAKE OUR PROGRAMS
BETTER. TO CUT RED TAPE TO MAKE
IT EASIER FOR PROVIDERS AND FOR
FAMILIES SO HOW WE'RE DOING ON
THAT TO MAKE SURE THAT THIS IS.
THAT THIS ACHIEVES THE GOALS
THAT WE- SO- WE STARTED THIS A
YEAR AGO. THAT CAN CAN JOHNSON
OUR MISSILE SERVICES JUST A
NUMBER OF PLACES HERE ID SAY
THAT WORD AGAIN FOCUSED ON
THAT- YOU KNOW WE ARE CERTAINLY
WITHIN THE DEPARTMENT HAVE HAVE
HAVE THE EXPERIENCE OF-
FREQUENTLY TRYING TO ENSURE
THAT IN THE IN THE INDIVIDUAL.
ESPECIALLY INDIVIDUALS AND
HOUSEHOLDS AND FAMILIES
EXPERIENCING POVERTY CAN GET
CONNECTED TO THE ROBUST ARRAY
THAT WE HAVE BUILT IT'S
PARTICULARLY CRITICAL FOR US TO
DO THAT IN TIMES LIKE THAT SO
AT THE MOST AS SPECIFIC EXAMPLE
I CAN GIVE AT THAT AT THIS-
EFFORT WOULD BE THE WORK WE'VE
DONE ON THAT WHAT'S CALLED THE
VERIFICATION HAVE WHICH IS.
ESSENTIALLY SUPPORTING THE
CONCEPT THAT BOTH IN TERMS OF
ENROLLING INTO PROGRAMS WHETHER
IT'S ACCESS TO WORK HOW WORKS
PROGRAM OUR CALFRESH PROGRAMMER
COULD ASSISTANCE PROGRAM OR ITS
US A TRUCKER SUBSIDY THAT'S
HAPPENING AT ONE TIME IN ONE
PLACE AND ALSO IN TERMS OF
MAINTAINING THAT SERVICE AT THE
BACKEND ESSENTIALLY IS DOING
THE WORK TO MAKE SURE THAT THE
INCOMING INFORMATION IS UPDATED
ACROSS ALL SYSTEMS THAT. AT ANY
OTHER CHANGES IN CIRCUMSTANCES
ARE COMMUNICATED AND THE BURDEN
IS NOT ON BOTH THE FAMILY TO DO
THAT- BUT ALSO NOT ON THE
PROGRAM ADMINISTRATOR SO AT
BATS AT EXAMPLE WE REALLY ARE
TRYING TO STREAMLINED PROCESS
SEES I HAD TO MAKE THIS- EASIER
HAVE PROCESS FOR THE FAMILY BUT
ALSO FOR THOSE WHO ARE
ADMINISTERING. THESE PROGRAMS
ACROSS THE STATE. OKAY THANK
YOU QUESTION OF MY FINAL. AB
FOR THE- NOW. SEEING WILL VISIT
THE AFTER THE MAY REVISE- WITH
THAT WE WILL NOW PROCEED WITH
OUR PUBLIC COMMENT THIS IS
ALWAYS A VERY POPULAR HEARING
FOR PUBLIC COMMENT AND- USUALLY
WE HAVE A PACKED ROOM SO IT'S A
BIT DIFFERENT. THESE THESE DAYS
SO WE HAVE A OPPORTUNITY
PARTICIPATE. THE R- EIGHT
HUNDRED NUMBER SO THE NUMBER IS.
THE SAME MUCH MYSTERY. YEAH
HERE IT IS OKAY IT'S.
1-877-692-8957. 977-692-8957
AND IS IT DIFFERENT COLOR FROM
YESTERDAY SOME GUIDANCE IN THAT
ONE SO TODAY'S PUBLIC ACCESS
CODE IS. 437-131-5437 ONE THREE
ONE FIVE. OKAY WE'LL BEGIN WITH
OUR PUBLIC COMMENT WE'RE GOING
TO ASK OUR SPEAKERS TO KEEP
YOUR COMMENTS TO ONE MINUTE OR
LESS. SIXTY SECONDS OR LESS.
PLEASE BEGIN. AND ARE WE TAKING
OUR PUBLIC COMMENT ON THE PHONE
AT THIS TIME YES I'M SORRY ON
THE PHONE NO ONE'S NO ONE'S
HERE IN THE AUDIENCE EIGHT I
JUST WANTED TO MAKE SURE IT
WASN'T IN THE ROOM THANK YOU
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU
HAVE PUBLIC COMMENT YOU MAY
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO ON YOUR
TELEPHONE KEYPAD. IF YOU ARE
USING A SPEAKER PHONE PLEASE
PICK UP THE HANDSET BEFORE
PRESSING THE NUMBERS AGAIN FOR
PUBLIC COMMENT PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO AN OPERATOR WILL GIVE YOU
A LINE NUMBER AND I WILL
ANNOUNCE YOU BY YOUR LINE
NUMBER AT THAT POINT IF YOU CAN
PLEASE STATE YOUR NAME IN
ASSOCIATION FOR LEGISLATIVE
RECORD OUR FIRST STEP PUBLIC
COMMENT FROM LINE NUMBER FORTY
SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD LINE FOR
SIX. GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS
TURNING COLBERN'S THE
CALIFORNIA ALTERNATIVE PAYMENT
PROGRAM ASSOCIATION. OUR FIRST
STOCK CAPISTRANO REPORT THE
CHAIR COMMENTS EARLIER TODAY
ABOUT SUPPORTING MONEY
EARMARKED. THREE DO NOT GO AND
BASS AND BACK TO THE GENERAL
FUND. ADDITIONALLY WE
WHOLEHEARTEDLY SUPPORT THE ASK
OF THE ECG COALITION WE'VE
ALREADY SUBMITTED A LETTER I
JUST WANT TO UNDERSCORE THE
NEED TO HOLD HARMLESS AND
STABILIZE CHILD CARE PROVIDERS
IN CENTERS. AND REIMBURSE THEM
BASED ON ENROLLMENT NOT
ATTENDANCE. POLICY WAS
IMPLEMENTED DURING THE PANDEMIC
I WOULD BE ABSOLUTELY
DEVASTATING TO PROVIDERS IF IT
IS ALLOWED TO LAPSE ON JUNE
THIRTY THANK. YOU YEAH. WITH
SOME. AND WE HAVE PUBLIC
COMMENT FROM LINE NUMBER THIRTY
DEADLINE THREE ZERO PLEASE GO
AHEAD THE LINE IS OPEN. CAN
REALLY ROSENBERGER WITH THE C.
P. U. S. C. I. UNITY W.
COLLABORATION- WE ARE
PRESERVING THE CONVERSATION
I'VE HAD TODAY WE THINK IT'S
NECESSARY THAT WE PROVIDE
EMERGENCY STABILIZATION FUNDING
AT ALL I'M GOING DOLLARS TO
HELP REBUILD THE CHILD CARE
INDUSTRY. ABOUT THE POOR KIDS
FAMILIES AND PROVIDERS
SPECIFICALLY WOULD LIKE TO SEE
A THIRTY P. KOBE DAYS AGO OF
ADDITIONAL CRISIS HEY. WE ALL
FAMILY B. THROUGH OCTOBER
TWENTY TWENTY TWO AND REIMBURSE
PROVIDERS I HAVE ALREADY PAID
INTO THAT IDOL EXTENDING ALL
COVERED HIM POLICY BUT FOR YOUR
TWENTY TWENTY TWO. ADDITIONALLY
THE EFFORTS MADE TO RE OPEN AND
GROW SO THAT WE CAN HELP THOSE
THAT CLOSE THAT ONE THREE OPEN
RE OPENING WITH A FUNDING AND
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE
IDENTIFYING UNDERSERVED AREAS
AND PRIORITIZE AND RECRUITING
NEW PROVIDERS AS WELL AS
TRAINING DOLLARS. TO RETAIN AND
EXPAND PROVIDERS STATEWIDE WE
ALSO LIKE TO SEE DOLLARS GO FOR
GREATER ACCESS TO CHILD CARE
FOR INFANTS AND TODDLERS AND
BOB TURNED A PAYMENT PROGRAM TO
BEGIN A LONG TERM COMMITMENT
OVER TWO MILLION CHILDREN WHO
ARE ELIGIBLE. ARE NOT RECEIVING
CARE AND FINALLY WE WOULD URGE
FUNDING TO GO TO REIMBURSEMENT
RATE INCREASES AND SO THAT THEY
CAN GET. TWENTY TWENTY ONE
DOLLAR THANK YOU. WE HAVE
PUBLIC COME FROM LINE NUMBER
THREE FOUR. PLEASE GO AHEAD
LINE THREE FOR. THE LINE OPEN.
HELLO MY NAME IS BLOWN UP WITH
PARADISE I AM TO EXPRESS MY
SUPPORT FOR INVESTMENT TO THE
EARLY CARE AND EDUCATION FIELD
SPECIFICALLY IT'S A HOLD
HARMLESS FOR THE TWENTY TWENTY
ONE TWENTY TWO YEAR. TO
MAINTAIN FUNDING WHICH REDUCED
CAPACITY DUE TO SOCIAL
DISTANCING WILL WAIT REFORM TO
INCREASE AND REGIONALI STATE
REIMBURSEMENT RATES AS WELL AS
RECOGNIZE HIGH QUALITY EACH
YEAR FORTY FIVE PROGRAM. WE
MUST INCREASE THE ESTARá RATES
TO MEET THE RMR RATE AT MINIMUM
I BOTH VOICE SUPPORT. FOR THE
ONE POINT 5% COOPER HERE AT
TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO HOWEVER
ALSO REQUEST THE ADDITIONAL TWO
POINT 31% TO RESTORED THE
TWENTY TWENTY TWENTY TWENTY ONE
THE FENDED POLAK. TO SUPPORT
THE FIFTEEN DOLLAR MINIMUM WAGE
INCREASE AND WE TRAIN OUR
WORKFORCE. ALLOW FUNDING
FLEXIBILITY TO TRANSFER CST PM
PPG ARE FUNDS BETWEEN CITY AND
CITY AT THAT. INCREASE SPACES
FOR DIRECT CONTRACTING PROGRAMS
TO RESTORE PREVIOUS CUTS AND
FINALLY ALLOW THE PARENTAL
CHOICE BEFORE YOU'RE OLD TO
ALLOW CHILDREN TO REMAIN IN IT
IF YOU READ THE FIRST YEAR
BEFORE KINDERGARTEN IF THE
FAMILY REQUESTS SO. MAKING SURE
THAT OUR CHILDREN RECEIVE HIGH
QUALITY CARE AND ACCOMMODATE
FULL TIME WORKING FAMILIES
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME TODAY
AND I BURKE. TO PRIORITIZE OUR
CHILDREN FAMILY. WE PUBLIC COME
FROM LINE NUMBER EIGHT SEVEN.
PLEASE AHEAD LINE EIGHT SAN THE
LINE IS OPEN. THANK YOU MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS POPPY THUNDER
LIKE MCCONNELL FROM THE COUNTY
WELFARE DIRECTORS ASSOCIATION.
WE APPRECIATETHE GREAT
CONVERSATION TODAY ON THESE
IMPORTANT ISSUES AND CRITICAL
SUPPORT FOR OUR FAMILIES AND
CHILDREN ACROSS THE STATE WE
ALSO APPRECIATE THE ROBUST
TRANSITION MEETINGS THAT ARE
COUNTY CHILD WELFARE STAFF-
SORRY COUNTY CHILD CARE STAFF
HAD BEEN INCLUDED IN WITH
REGARD TO THE SHIP FROM CDTV AT
THAT. WITH REGARD TO THE MASTER
PLAN THAT THE EXCITING TO SEE
SO MUCH GOOD WORK GOING TO THE
SENATE RECOMMENDATION. WE WOULD
LIKE TO KNOW THAT WE STRONGLY
BELIEVE THAT CAL WORK SPECIFIC
CHILD CARE AUTHORIZATION SHOULD
REMAIN AS IS THE NOT PEOPLE
THAT INTELLIGIBILITY
DETERMINATIONS THAT MAY BE DONE
FOR GENERAL CHILD CARE. COUNTY
HUMAN SERVICES AGENCIES
ADMINISTER THE TOTALITY OF
CALVERT'S OFFER TO WORK
SERVICES AND WORK CLOSELY WITH
FAMILIES TO ENSURE A PACKAGE OF
NEEDED SUPPORT INCLUDING CHILD
CARE IS APPROPRIATE IS BROUGHT
TO BEAR TO IT THAT THAT OUR
PARTICIPATION. CHILD CARE%
SHOULD REMAIN A PART OF THAT
WORK IN THE SAME MANNER IT IS
TODAY SO IT CAN BE INTEGRATED
INTO THE OTHER SERVICES WE
PROVIDE. TO THIS PROGRAM THANK
YOU FOR YOUR TIME. AND WE HAVE
PUBLIC COM FROM NUMBER. EIGHT
PLEASE GO AHEAD E. NUMBER
FAMILY ON BEHALF OF THE PPO
PARTNERSHIP BETWEEN AT THE ARE
YOU A U. D. W. WE APPRECIATE
HEARING TODAY IN THE
LEGISLATURE SUPPORT FOR INITIAL
COLLECTIVE BARGAINING AGREEMENT
REGARDING KOBE NINETEEN
RELEASE. BUT AFTER THE COMMON
FAITH MY COLLEAGUE AT THE ARE
YOU IN ARE YOU PREPARED TO
CORRELATE HIGHLY THE STRONG
NEED FOR IMMEDIATE ADDITIONAL
EVENT THANK YOU THE EASIEST
THING TO THINK LIKE CHILD CARE.
I LIKE HOW YOUR SUPPORT OF THE
FOLLOWING PROPOSAL WAITING
FAMILY FEES FOR OUR FAMILY FOR
TRUCKERS THAT BEAT OCTOBER
THIRTY FIRST TWENTY TWENTY TWO
EXTENDING OCTOBER NINETEEN
PAYMENT ON THE THIRD FISCAL
YEAR TWENTY TWENTY TO. INCREASE
THE REIMBURSEMENT RATE THE
CURRENT LEVEL IN FUNDING FOR AT
A MINIMUM FIFTY THOUSAND BAHT
INCREASE NUMBER CAPTURE
VOUCHERS TO CREATE GREATER ACT
THAT. FINALLY WE APPRECIATE ALL
THE HARD WORK BEHIND THE
TRANSITION COULD YET BACK THEN
LOOK FOR YOUR CONTINUED
DISCUSSION ON THIS ITEM I
THOUGHT ON THE OTHER. BUDGET
PROPOSAL TODAY THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. WE HAVE COMMENT FROM
NUMBER FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD
LINE NINE FIVE THE LINE IS OPEN.
NINE NINETY FIVE. PLEASE GO
AHEAD. MY NAME IS I AM AGHAST
AND I'M CALLING TO SPEAK ON
BEHALF OF THE YOUNGER. IN I
WANT TO GET INTO THE BUSINESS
OF PROVIDING UNIVERSAL PRE
SCHOOL TO CALIFORNIANS. YEAH
IT'S VERY HEARING. COME FROM.
ME BY. CALIFORNIA LOT ABOUT
CHILD CARE CAPACITY DURING THE
ENDEMIC. PERRANCE BRATCHER HAD
EACH OTHER IN CALIFORNIA HAS
THE ABILITY TO RE OPEN WITHOUT
CHILD CARE LITTLE CALIFORNIANS.
AND TO ME NO NO I WANT TO THANK
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BRIAN BURKE.
YOUR SITE I DID YEAH YEAH. I
DON'T ON THE COMMITTEE AND
THINGS LIKE WE- SOLD ORIGINALLY
BUYER ABOUT THEIR- I MIGHT ADD.
ONE LAST IN THE OF THE ADDRESS
WHEN. YEAH MY GOD THANK YOU
YOUR TIME THAT NICK. BAKER
THANK YOU. YOU'RE THINKING.
THANK YOU A BELIEVER REACHED
OUT WE DO HAVE THE EPUB COMMENT
FROM THE SEVENTY ONE PLEASE GO
AHEAD LINE SEVEN ONE THE LINE
IS OPEN. YES MY NAME IS JESSICA
MAGDALENO- MISTER SHARE AND
MEMBERS I AM A FAMILY CHILD
CARE PROVIDER WE CAN MEET
TWENTY YEARS IN THE FIELD I AM
WITH A CALIFORNIA FAMILY CHILD
CARE NETWORK AND THE CHILD CARE
BUSINESS INSTITUTE. I AM IN THE
ORANGE COUNTY AND WE SERVE
SIXTEEN CHILDREN AT THIS TIME
FOR THE ESSENTIAL WORKERS. AND
I WILL LIVE TV I WOULD LIKE TO
TALK TO YOU ABOUT THE CRITICAL
NEED OF RESTORE FUNDING FOR
CHILDCARE INFRASTRUCTURE. IT IS
CRUCIAL THAT CALIFORNIA INVEST
IN PHYSICAL INFRASTRUCTURE FOR
EARLY CARE AND EDUCATION. SAFE
AND HEALTHY AND QUALITY
LEARNING AND CARE EXPERIENCE
ARE ONLY POSSIBLE. IS PROVIDING
A SAFE HEALTHY AND QUALITY
ENVIRONMENTS CALIFORNIA MOST
PRIORITIZE INVESTMENTS IN EARLY
LEARNING FACILITIES THE HEALTH
AND THE SAFETY OF THE CHILDREN
AND THE ADULTS WHO EDUCATE THEM.
THE BAN ON IT THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. THANK YOU THANK YOU WE
HAVE PUBLIC COMMENT FROM MY
NUMBER NINETY FOUR PLEASE GO
AHEAD LINE NINE FOUR. GOOD
AFTERNOON I'M KERRY BEEN A
CHANGING TIDES FAMILY SERVICES
HAVE BEEN HUMBOLDT COUNTY AND I
WANT TO THANK. EVERYONE FOR THE
A ROBUST CONVERSATION IN THE
REALLY GREAT QUESTION THANK YOU
SO MUCH FOR MAKING YOURSELF. IN
ALL OF THE MIND YOU SAID THAT
SO ACCORDING TO EARLY
EDUCATION- WE DEFINITELY STAND
IN SOLIDARITY WITH THE EASY
COLLECTION PRIORITIES EVERY
FURTHER STAND IN SOLIDARITY
WITH THE REQUIRED YOU FIND WAYS
TO COME UP WITH DOLLARS TO WAIT
THE FAMILY GAVE HER PARENTS.
BUT WE WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT
NONE OF THAT IS SACRIFICING
DOLLARS THAT ACTUALLY. ARE
THERE TO. WATCH AND MAKE SURE
THAT FAMILIES ARE ABLETO
ACCESS ABOUT YOUR ATTENTION BE
TRADE OFF BETWEEN ONE OR THE
OTHER WE ALSO WANT TO RECOGNIZE
AND APPRECIATE THE EFFORT.
INDIVIDUAL DOLLARS IN THE
NUTRITION PROGRAMS THE FOOD
PROGRAM THAT YOUR CHILD CARE IT
CRITICALLY IMPORTANT FOR
FAMILIES AND FOR THE PROVIDERS
THEY SERVE THE FAMILY AND RIGHT
NOW THEY'RE VERY MUCH HURTING.
AND. ALSO TO ENCOURAGE AND-
SUPPORT FIFTY P. PER WHICH- AND
HAVE FOR ME MANY. SUPPORTED THE-
FOR PROVIDER. BECAUSE SUCH AN
IMPORTANT HER WE'RE GOING HAVE
TO RE. HERE 30% OF A PROVIDER
DON'T HAVE NOT REAL AND WE
ENSURE THAT WILL AT LEAST OF
THE SO WE NEED BE ABLE TO GROW
THAT I FIND. AT LEAST HOLDING
YOU THANK YOU SO MUCH I
APPRECIATE SPEAKING. WE COME UP
COMMENT FROM MY NUMBER FIFTY
THAT'S LINE FIVE ZERO PLEASE GO
AHEAD. YEAH BLINDSIDE ZERO NEAR
E. YES PLEASE GO AHEAD OF.
YEAH I MEAN THIS MOVIE OF THE
STORY OUR PLACES- THANKS TO
EVERYONE IN THIS COMMUNITY AND
TO ALL THE PANELISTS THANKS FOR
CARING FOR A LIBYA'S LEARNERS-
NOW WE NEED TO PUT OUR MONEY
WHERE OUR HEARTS ARE BECAUSE
THE STATE BUDGET SHOULD REFLECT
OUR VALUES AIRPORT MERRY GRACES
FROM HIGHLIGHTING THE FACT
THAT. FOR YEARS SO INCOME
FAMILIES A BIG HUNDREDS OF
MILLIONS OF DOLLARS COPAY. FOR
CHILD CARE TO FAMILY TREES.
IT'S THE IN THE AND SYSTEM. ONE
HUNDRED TWO MILLION STRUCK
FAMILIES WITH THE BEZELS ON THE
TRUMP'S NOTHING VERY BEEN GET
REBATES. FOR YEARS. VOICES BE
OFFERED TO PAY OUR FAIR SHARE
TO THE SLIDING SCALE SYSTEM.
NOW I REALIZE THAT THE LIMITING
THOSE FEES FOR FAMILIES LIKE
MINE. EARNING BELOW 1100% OF
ESTIMIZE MOST CREDIBLE WHEN WE
HAVE ENOUGH INVESTMENTS INCLUDE
THE LOWER MIDDLE EARNERS THEY
SHOULD. THAT BE MORE THAN 7% OF
THEIR INCOME. STILL BEFORE A
SELL OFF CHILD. USE I WAS
THINKING ON THE DOLLARS IN
FAMILY FOR. LET'S YEARS AGO
WHEN WE- BIGGER ABOUT. FOURTEEN
FOURTEEN. HUNDRED MONTHLY AFTER
PAYING RENT FOR A STUDIO. I WAS
CLOSE TO THREE HUNDRED TO PAY
FOR FOOD UTILITIES
TRANSPORTATION. KNOWING THAT
THE RICHEST OWNERS OF THE STATE
BASER TAXES AFTER DEDUCTIONS.
AND EVEN GET REBATES I THINK
THAT IT IS BUT CRITICAL. TO NOT
CHARGE FAMILY FEES FOR LOW
INCOME FAMILIES. SO WE-
SUPPORT. EXPANDING REGISTERED
VOTERS TO SERVE WAITING LISTS
FAMILIES THERE ARE OVER TWO
MILLION OF THEM WAITING. AND
SUPPORT OUR CHILD CARE
PROVIDERS SAID BETTER P. AND
SUPPORT. THEM TO KEEP THEIR
DOORS OPEN AND TO CREATE. NEW.
SUPPLY OF CHILD CARE THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. THANK YOU NICK WE
ARE NOT COMMON FROM NINE FORTY.
PLEASE GO AHEAD LINE FOR. THANK
YOU HEAR ME. YELLOW PLEASE
PROCEED THANK YES PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI MARTINEZ I'M UPON
BOTH THE NUMBER OF PATENTS
FISCAL IMPACT ON THE PARENTS OF
FIVE YEAR OLD BOY WITH SPECIAL
NEEDS AND VOTE FOR YOUR GIRL I
FOUND THE CHOCOLATE DIFFICULT
STUDENTS LAST YEAR BEFORE THE
PANDEMIC I WAS GOING TO PUNCH A
WORKER AND I HAD TO QUIT MY
JOB. EACH ONE AVAILABLE ON
AFFORDABLE CHILCARE SO NOW
MORE THAN EVER THE NEED TO BE
MORE CHOCOLATE PROFITABLE
FAMILY BE WAIVED BECAUSE THIS
PLANT DURING THE EIGHT
FINANCIAL PLANNING FOR ALL OF
THE EXPENSE OF THE COFFEE CUP
OF LIVING IN CALIFORNIA. AND A
VERY WELL AND WHAT THE
CONSEQUENCES OF THE PANDEMIC. A
LOT OF PEOPLE ARE HURTING.
HEALTH CHECK OF. NEED FINANCIAL
PROVIDE PARENTS LIKE MY HE
JOINED THE FOR BOTH ORDERS
AGAIN THE HORRIBLE AT PROBABLE
QUITE AND WILL TO HOW IT FROM.
AND POTENTIAL THREATS OUR- I
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME. THANK
YOU. WE PUBLIC COMMENT FROM
LINE NUMBER NINETY PLEASE GO
AHEAD AT NINE TWO. HI GOOD MY
NAME IS APRIL YANG AND I AM A
MEMBER PARA- AND I'M OFF ON A
CENTRAL WORKER PROVIDING CARE
FOR DISABLED PERSONS IN JUNIORS
I HAVE BEEN ON THE WAITING LIST
FOR FOUR LONG YEARS. STRUGGLING
WITH CONSISTENT CARE FOR MY
CHILD AND DOING THE BEST I CAN
TO SUPPORT MY FAMILY. SOME DAYS
I HAVE TO TAKE MY DAUGHTER TO
WORK OTHERS I CAN MEET WITH A
FRIEND OR FAMILY MEMBER WITH
THE KOBE CRISIS THERE'S BEEN
MUCH HARDER TRYING TO FIND
STABLE CARE. WITH THE STRAP OF
THE WORLD RIGHT NOW THE LAST
THING A PARENT SHOULD HAVE TO
WORRY ABOUT IT WHERE THEIR
CHILDREN WILL BE WHILE THEY'RE
WORKING. EARLY CHILDHOOD
EDUCATION IS AN IMPORTANT TIME
IN CHILDREN'S LIVES BECAUSE IT
IS WHEN THEY FIRST LEARNED HOW
TO INTERACT. WITH OTHERS AND
ALSO BEGIN TO DEVELOP ENTRANCE
AND LIKE. THAT WILL CONTINUE
WITH THEM AS THEY BECOME
ADULTS. WE WANT TO BUILD STRONG
FAMILIES AND HELP ECONOMIC
RESILIENCE AND INDEPENDENCE. WE
ARE ASKING THAT YOU WAIVE ALL
FAMILY FEET. ALTHOUGH SOME MAY
SEE A FAMILY BUSINESS MINIMAL
FOR SOMEONE WHO IS STRUGGLING
TO PROVIDE BASIC FAMILY NEEDS
IN OUR HOUSEHOLD THIS AMOUNT
USUALLY IMPACT THEIR LIFE. FROM
BRINGING FOOD TO THEIR TABLE
PAYING RENT O EVEN COVERING A
FAMILY EMERGENCY. AGAIN PUT OUR
FAMILY FIRST AND WAIT FAMILY
FEAST OCTOBER. TWENTY TWENTY
THANK YOU THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
YOUR TIME. WE A PUB COMMENT
FROM LINE ONE ZERO THREE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. THANK YOU GOOD
EVENING THAT THE CHARITY CALLED
NOURISH CALIFORNIA HELP LOOK AT
MY COMMENT THAT I AM FOR THE
CHILD CARE NUTRITION PROPOSAL
THERE'S A PRESS THE NEED FOR
ADDITIONAL FUNDING FOR
PROVIDERS TO SERVE MEALS AND
SNACKS CHILDREN IN THEIR CARE
DURING. AND FOLLOWING A CHILD
CARE PROVIDERS WHO STEP UP TO
THE CHALLENGE OF PROVIDING
EARLY LEARNING AND CARE TO
SUPPORT CALIFORNIA'S FAMILY
THROUGHOUT THE CALL THE CRISIS
BUT WE ARE TODAY EIGHT REPORTER
STILL FALLING SHORT. CHILD CARE
PROVIDERS EVER PREDOMINATELY
LOW WE CAN ATTACH A WORKFORCE
AND STILL DON'T HAVE ENOUGH
MONEY TO PAY FOR FOOD WE CAN
TELL ME YOUR REPORT ABOUT CHILD
CARE PROVIDERS RELYING ON FOOD
BANKS JUST TO GET BY. WE
SUPPORT THE EARLY CARE AND
EDUCATION COALITION PACKAGE OF
APPS AND ALSO RESPECT
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST THAT MAKE
MAKE CRITICAL INVESTMENTS TO
SUPPORT CHILD CARE MEAL SERVICE
AS PART OF PUBLIC NINETY RELIEF
JUST AS WITHOUT FOR SCHOOL
MEALS AND LAST YEAR'S BUDGET.
WE HAVE TO ENSURE THE CHILD
CARE PROVIDERS HAVE ALL THE
RESOURCES THEY NEED INCLUDING
FUNDING FOR MEALS FOR CHILDREN.
IN THEIR CARE. THANKS SO MUCH
THANK YOU. WE PUBLIC COMMENT
FROM LINE ONE ZERO. PLEASED
AHEAD- HI AFTERNOON MY NAME IS
NINA I NEED BECKETT DIRECTOR OF
EVERY CHILD CALIFORNIA I WOULD
LIKE TO LINE MY COMMENTS WITH
THE EPA COALITION REQUEST- AS
WELL AS WE'VE ALREADY PROVIDED
WRITTEN TESTIMONY BEFORE THAT
COMMITTEE HEARING TODAY I WOULD
LIKE TO TAKE A FEW MOMENTS JUST
TO HIGHLIGHT A FEW ADDITIONAL
ITEMS ONE WOULD BE THE HOLD
HARMLESS FOR TWENTY ONE TWENTY
TWO YEAR. I'M THIS IS
ABSOLUTELY CRUCIAL AS WE'VE
HEARD FROM OUR PROVIDERS
EARLIER TODAY ALSO PUT IN A
PITCH FOR RIGHT BEFORE FOR EACH
SEEKING ESTABLISHING A SINGLE
REGIONALI STATE REIMBURSEMENT
SYSTEM WOULD REALLY GO A LONG
WAY TO STABILIZE THE SYSTEM
THAT WE HAVE IN CALIFORNIA. AND
PAY FOR ON QUALITY PROGRAMS
WHILE RECOGNIZING REGIONAL COST
DIFFERENCES ALSO OPT FOR ON
INCREASE SPACES FOR DIRECT
CONTRACTING PROGRAMS AS WELL AS
INCLUDED IN THE LANGUAGE
EARLIER THE- INCREASES FOR THE
TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO EXCUSE ME
TWENTY TWENTY ONE BUDGET ACT
WERE REDUCED AS PART OF THE
BUDGET CUTS TO BE REQUEST WE
ASK THAT THOSE BE- REINSTATED
IN THIS. YEAR THANK YOU SO
MUCH. THANK YOU. WE HAVE PUBLIC
COMMENT FROM LINE ONE EIGHT
ZERO NINE PLEASE AHEAD. GOOD
EVENING MY NAME IS LAURIE FIRST
INVOLVED IN THE CHILD CARE
LAWCENTER I'M NEED SUPPORT
INVESTMENT TO A FAMILY FEES FOR
ALL FAMILIES DURING THE
PANDEMIC IN MEANINGFUL AND BACK
TO THE WHOLE SYSTEM ESPECIALLY
FOR CHILDREN ZERO TO THREE. WE
SUPPORT THE TRANSITION TO CDSS
AND THE EASY COALITION BUDGET
REQUEST. I WOULD LIKE TO
HIGHLIGHT THAT THERE'S ALWAYS
BEEN A CRITICAL NEED FOR CHILD
CARE ESPECIALLY FOR MOTHERS OF
COLOR MOST OF HIM HAVE ALWAYS
HAD TO WORK REALLY THE FOUNDING
OF THIS COUNTRY. OUR COUNTRY
HAS A LONG DOCUMENTED PATTERN
AND THEN USING PUBLIC FUNDS FOR
CHILD CARE IN RESPONSE TO
CRISIS SITUATIONS WHEN THEY
NEED FOR CHILD CARE AFFECTS
EVERYONE ESPECIALLY WHITE WOMEN
LIKE NOW THE STORE COOLEY AFTER
THE CRISIS IT'S BACK TO
BUSINESS AS USUAL. NOW WE HAVE
AN OPPORTUNITY TO MAKE A
MEANINGFUL ONGOING INVESTMENT
IN CHILDCARE AND TO ADDRESS THE
SYSTEMIC RACIST POLICIES IN
UNDER FUNDING IN OUR SYSTEM THE
FEDERAL DOLLARS ARE ALWAYS MUCH
APPRECIATED AND WILL GIVE US
THAT NEEDED BOOST TO HELP OUT
OF CRISIS MODE BUT WE ALSO NEED
ONGOING STATE INVESTMENT. WE
CANNOT GO BACK TO BUSINESS AS
USUAL. THANK YOU THANK YOU. WE
HAVE PUBLIC COMMENT FROM LINE
AT NINETY NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD EVENING COMPLY WITH
REPRESENTING CHILDREN NOW AND
WE REALLY APPRECIATE THE NUMBER
OF QUESTIONS AND COMMENTS TO
BETTER UNDERSTAND THE CURRENT
THEM CHALLENGES OUR LITTLEST
LEARNERS. GIVEN THE ADDITIONAL
NEW FEDERAL FUND COMPANY
CALIFORNIA NIGHT AT THE MILAN
WE NEED TO SUPPORT OUR CHILDREN
AND FAMILIES AND FUNDAMENTALLY
STABILIZE THE CHILD CARE SYSTEM
DURING THE PANDEMIC. AND UPDATE
THE REIMBURSEMENT RATE I'M MORE
SUPPORT ABOUT- PROPOSAL TODAY
THE DEBATING FAMILY FEAR
CALLING CHUCK CARE PROGRAM
HARMLESS NIXON ABOUT YOUR FOR
COMMERCIAL WORKERS. MEDICINE WE
BELIEVE IT'S CRITICAL TO
PROVIDE ONGOING FUNDING TO
BRING A REGIONAL MARKET RATE
INCLUDING FAMILY FRIEND AND
NEIGHBOR INVESTMENTS ATTENDED
REIMBURSEMENT RATES UP TO
TWENTY EIGHTEEN ARE MARKED
AVAILABLE. FOR ALSO- REPORT
ABOUT THE DEATH OF TRANSITION
OF- SOCCER PROGRAM THE READY TO
GET BACK AND APPRECIATE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER AT THE REMINDER
OF THE RATIONALE FOR THIS
TRANSITION- APPRECIATED THE
ROBUST COLOR PROFIT THAT THEY
PUT IN PLACE ENGAGE APPEAL IN
ORDER TO INFORM THE TRANSITION
OF. CHILD CARE FOR THEM AS WELL
AS PART OF LAST YEAR'S
AGREEMENT. AND REMAIN
OPTIMISTIC THAT THE
TRANSITIONAL SUPPORTED STRONGER
MARKETBEAT THAT EACH DECEMBER
BUT FAMILIES AND PROVIDERS.
LONG TERM THANK YOU. WE HAVE
PUBLIC COMMENT LINE NINETY ONE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI THANK YOU-
KATHY VAN OFF REFER B. AND-
ASSOCIATION OF UNIVERSITY
BERMAN CALIFORNIA. AND DO WE
ARE CALL I'M CALLING TO SUPPORT
THE WAIVER- CHILD CARE FAMILY
FEES. FOR FAMILIES ON THROUGH
OCTOBER THIRTY FIRST TWENTY
TWENTY TWO- THIS WILL PROVIDE
THE GREATEST AND MOST IMMEDIATE
RELIEF TO FAMILIES WHO ARE
PAYING WAY TOO MUCH- FOR CHILD
CARE AND HAVING THE STOCK PRICE
THAT THEIR BASIC NEEDS SO WE-
STRONGLY. THIS REQUEST AND
THINK ASSEMBLY WOMAN BRANCH FOR
HER LEADERSHIP ON THIS ISSUE-
WE ALSO WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT
THE FUTURE- THESE ARE THE ARE
FUNDED- THAT MADE YOU GO TO
CHILDCARE PROVIDERS- TO MAKE
SURE THAT THEY ARE MADE WHOLE.
WE DON'T WANT TO SEE THEM
SUFFER OR- HAVE ANY CHILD CARE.
AS IT DISAPPEAR. SO- THANK YOU
FOR YOUR TIME IN YOUR CAR AND
YOUR- AND YOUR LEADERSHIP
LEADERSHIP ON THIS ISSUE AND-
REALLY APPRECIATE THE QUESTIONS
AND DIALOGUE TODAY. AND WE HAVE
PUBLIC COMMENT FROM LINE NUMBER
NINETY EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HI GOOD AFTERNOON THIS IS
PATRICK MORE TERRORIST CUMPLIR
STRONG AMERICA WHICH IS
COMPRISED OF READY NATION AND
BY CONTESTING KIT. THANK YOU
ALL FOR THE GREAT CONVERSATION
TODAY AROUND TRACKER ACCESS
PORTABILITY AND THE
PRIORITIZATION OF SUPPORT FOR A
STATE INCREDIBLE AN INVALUABLE
CHILD CARE WORKERS WHO ARE
PREDOMINANTLY WOMEN OF COLOR.
ACCORDING TO WRITING NATION'S
ANALYSIS LACK OF RELIABLE CHILD
CARE FOR WORKING PARENTS OF
YOUNG CHILDREN COST THE STATE
ANYWHERE FROM SIX POINT EIGHT
BILLION. NINE POINT ONE BILLION
DOLLARS PER YEAR IN LOST
EARNINGS PRODUCTIVITY AND
REVENUE. THIS ISSUE IS NOT ONLY
DETRIMENTAL TO OUR ECONOMY BUT
ALSO POSES A PUBLIC SAFETY
ISSUE WELL. WE ALSO STAND IN
SOLIDARITY WITH THE UC
COALITIONS PRIORITIES AND IN
PARTICULAR WERE CALLING ON YOU
TO SUPPORT FIVE HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLARS IN ONGOING FUNDING FOR
CHILDCARE VOUCHERS TO IMPAIR
SPACES. THREE HUNDRED EIGHTY
MILLION AND ONGOING FUNDING
PARMAR RATE ADJUSTMENTS AND ONE
HUNDRED THIRTY THREE MILLION
DOLLARS TO A FAMILY. FEES DUE
TO THE PANDEMIC THANK YOU. AND
WE HAVE PUBLIC COMMENT FROM MY
NUMBER TWENTY TWO PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI THIS IS JENNIFER
ALLEN FROM LONG BEACH DAY
NURSERY SERVING OVER THREE
HUNDRED CHILDREN AGES ZERO TO
FIVE IN LONG BEACH. AND WORK
HERE TO COMMENT ON THE CRITICAL
NEED TO RESTORE FUNDING FOR THE
CHILD CARE INFRASTRUCTURE GRANT
PROGRAM IN THE TWENTY TWENTY
ONE TWENTY TWENTY TWO BUDGET.
WE'RE REQUESTING THREE HUNDRED
FIFTY MILLION INCLUDING THE
RESTORATION OF TWO HUNDRED
SIXTY THREE MILLION PREVIOUSLY
ALLOCATED IN THE TWENTY
NINETEEN TWENTY TWENTY BUDGET.
TO SUPPORT HOME BASED IN CENTER
BASED CHILDCARE FACILITIES. WE
HAVE A FOUR PHASE CIVILITY
EXPANSION PLAN AND ARE SHOVEL
READY TO BRING ANYTHING CARE
TOWARD CENTER LOCATED IN ONE OF
THE HIGHEST NEED AREAS IN LOS
ANGELES COUNTY. THE REQUESTED
THAT THE FUNDING FOR THE CHILD
CARE INFRASTRUCTURE GRANT
PROGRAM IS RESTORED THANK YOU.
WE HAVE PUBLIC COMMENT FROM
LINE AT ONE EIGHT ZERO FOUR
PLEASE GO AHEAD. I HAD THE
PROBABLY ONE OF THE EFFORT
NONPROFIT DIRECT SERVICE TITLE
BY PROVIDER WE HAVE TWENTY TWO
CHILD CARE CENTERS THROUGHOUT
SAN DIEGO COUNTY. ALL OPEN FOR
IN PERSON LEARNING YOU HAVE A
CAPACITY DISTRICT THIRTEEN
HUNDRED LOW INCOME ESSENTIAL
WORKER FAMILIES AND QUITE TWO
HUNDRED EDUCATED AND DEDICATED
PEOPLE. THEY ALREADY COLLEGE
DEGREE AND ARE GETTING PAID
MINIMUM WAGE OR CLOSE TO IT.
PLEASE SUPPORT THE CONTINUATION
OF THE HOLD HARMLESS THAT HAS
ALLOWED DIRECT CONTRACTED
CATTLE I CENTERS TO REMAIN OPEN
THIS YEAR SERVICE CENTER WORKER
FAMILIES IN PERSON. DIRECT
CONTRACT REIMBURSE YOU QUICKLY
DON'T BE HAS NARAL FISCAL
IMPACT TO THE STATE BUDGET YET
KEEP CENTERS OPEN AND FAMILIES
WORKING. WAIT COULD NOT
INCREASE IN THE LAST THREE
BUDGET THE MINIMUM WAGE
CONTINUES TO GO UP UNFUNDED
MANDATE MUST BE FULLY FUNDED SO
WE STOPPED INSANITY OF OUR
FUTURE SUBSIDIZED PROGRAMS BY
ACCEPTING. POPULATION THE- BOOK
OF YOUR TO ALLOW CHILDREN TO RE
IN THE S. P. P. AND OTHER WORDS
CAN. WITH OUR NEXT. SYSTEM FOR.
A FIVE YEAR. WITH ALL THE- T'S
NOT. RIGHT OFF YOU WILL BE THE
FIRST YEAR OF A TWO YEAR CAN.
COP ALSO LAST BUT NOT LEAST.
THE FACILITIES ONE TIME FUNDING
FOR TITLE FIGHT CENTERS CENTERS
REINSTATED THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
WE HAVE PUBLIC COMMENT FROM MY
NUMBER FORTY FOUR. ONE MOMENT
PLEASE THEY MUST ALIGN FORTY
FOR THE LINE IS OPEN FOR YOU
THINK YOU. THANK YOU ERICA
ERICSSON ON BEHALF OF YOUR
CALIFORNIA A STATEWIDE NETWORK
OF CHAMPIONS FOR CHILD CARE
FACILITIES AND MEMBER OF THE C.
QUALITY GIN. I WANT TO
HIGHLIGHT TO DATE THAT PART OF
THE STATE BY THE JUDGE REQUEST
OF THREE HUNDRED FIFTY MEDIAN
FOR FACILITIES INFRASTRUCTURE
FOR NON ALLEY A PROVIDERS
INCLUDING CENTER. BASED AND
HOME BASED PROVIDERS. THE
LOCATION WITH FOR THREE VERY
OUTLOOK TO THE EARLY LEARNING
AND CARE FOR STRUCTURE GRANT
PROGRAM AND ALLOW THE STATE TO
PROVIDE WE OPENING AND
SUSTAINABILITY GRANT. WHICH CAN
COVERT ACTIVITIES REPAIR
RENOVATION COSTS. THE PROVIDED
CAN OPERATE CERVANTES CHAU CHIU
RING FOLLOWING HEALTH AND
SAFETY PROTOCOLS. WE READ
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOU TO USE
THE BUDGET WINDFALL TO MAKE IT-
SHOW ONE TIME INVESTMENT.
BEFORE THE PANDEMIC 60% OF THE
CHILDREN THAT WE STATE IN CHECK
AT DESERT. BOTH BUT THAT MAKE
OUR HOLY FAITH MAY BE ATTACKED
AT DESERT EVEN IF WE HAVE BUT
OTHER THAN SOME AREAS THEY WILL
NOT HAVE ITS LOTS AVAILABLE. IF
WE FAIL TO ACTIVE INVESTMENT
THE MOST IMPACTED WILL BE BLACK
LEGEND THAT INDIGENOUS CHILDREN
AND FAMILY. AND OTHERS ALREADY
HARMED BY SYSTEMIC RACISM IN
ADDITION THE REJECTED. THANK
YOU FOR YOUR CONSIDERATION. AND
LEADERSHIP ABILITIES. A PUBLIC
COMMENT FROM LINE TWENTY FIVE
PLEASE GO AHEAD LINE FIVE. GET
OUT THIS IS OPEN COULD BEEN
DIRECTOR POWER COULD THREE. AND
THROUGHOUT THE PANDEMIC MANY
PROVIDERS THAT WE SERVE HAVE
STRUGGLED WITH LOWER ENROLLMENT
AND INCREASED COSTS RELATED TO
CLEANING AND PPV'S COMPLIES
WITH ALL THESE MODIFICATIONS
AND DISTANCE LEARNING. THESE
PROVIDERS THE MAJORITY OF WHOM
ARE WOMEN OF COLOR WHO BROKE WE
CARED FOR AND EDUCATED
CALIFORNIA'S CHILDREN WHILE
PUTTING THEIR OWN HEALTH AT
RISK. IT'S IMPERATIVE THAT THE
HOLD HARMLESS PROVISION BE
EXTENDED IN THE PROVIDER
REIMBURSEMENT RATES THE REYES
YOU LIVE IN THE TWO THOUSAND
EIGHTEEN ARMOR SURVEYS OF THE
PROVIDERS CAN REMAIN OPEN AND
THEY'RE DEMANDING A CRITICAL
WORK IS RECOGNIZED WITH A FAIR
WAGE SOMETHING THAT HAS BEEN
ELUSIVE FOR FAR TOO LONG. SHOT
THREE SIXTY ALSO SUPPORT TO SEE
WHAT YOU SEE COALITION BUDGET
PROPOSAL ONE OF THE ELEMENTS OF
WHICH IS A REQUEST FOR
PROFESSIONAL DEVELOPMENT HOURS.
BASED ON A SURVEY WE CONDUCTED
A NEARLY SIX HUNDRED EASY
EDUCATOR THE L. A. COUNTY WE
BELIEVE THERE IS A NEED FOR
PROFESSIONAL DEVELOPMENT ON
WORKING WITH DUAL LANGUAGE
LEARNERS AND ON TRAUMA INFORMED
CARE. AND WE RECOMMEND THAT
THESE BE ALLOWABLE USES OF ANY
NEW PROFESSIONAL DEVELOPMENT.
DOLLARS THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
YOUR TIME. WE HAVE PUBLIC
COMMENT FROM. TO FOUR. PLEASE
GO AHEAD. HELLO THIS IS TONYA
MAKE FOR CHILD PROVIDER MEMBER
THE GOVERNOR'S EARLY CHILDHOOD
POLICY COUNCIL AND PART OF THE
HOTEL EQUITY PARTNERSHIP THE
HOTEL EQUITY PARTNERSHIP IS A
GROUP OF COMMUNITY BASED
ORGANIZATIONS AND INDIVIDUALS
WHO ARE WORKING TO IDENTIFY
SYSTEMIC BARRIERS AND
OPPORTUNITIES FOR LOCAL LOW
INCOME COMMUNITIES OF COLOR WE
ALSO ADDRESSING HISTORIC UNDER
INVESTMENT. IN OUR STATE'S
BLACK LATINO AND INDIGENOUS
COMMUNITIES WE'RE ASKING THE
STATE TO MAKE A ONE TIME
INVESTMENT OF TWO HUNDRED AND
FORTY FIVE MILLION DOLLARS TO
ESTABLISH A WHOLE CHAO EQUITY
FUNDS SPECIFICALLY FIVE MILLION
DOLLARS TO CREATE AN EQUITY
NEEDS INDEX WHICH WOULD CAPTURE
HOLISTIC NEEDS OF CHILDREN AND
FAMILIES AND TO RE IMAGINE- ARE
OUTDATED SYSTEMS THAT CONTINUE
TO EXCLUDE. THE HIGHEST NEED
COMMUNITIES IT WAS A- CREATE
TWO HUNDRED AND NINE HUNDRED
AND NINETEEN MILLION DOLLARS
FOR TWENTY FOUR HOLD CHAO
WELLNESS HUBS WHICH WOULD
PROVIDE COMPREHENSIVE HEALTH
MENTAL HEALTH AND OTHER
WRAPAROUND SERVICES TO CHILDREN
AND FAMILIES. AND IT WILL OFFER
TWENTY ONE MILLION DOLLARS TO
PROVIDE ANTI BIAS TRAINING
COACHING AND OTHER
INTERVENTIONS TO ELIMINATE BIAS
AND CREATE WELCOMING SAFE
LEARNING ENVIRONMENTS THAT
EMBRACE ALL CHILDREN'S CULTURAL
RACIAL AND LINGUISTIC STRENTZ
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME AND WE
LOOK FORWARD TO YOU SUPPORTING
OUR PROPOSAL. THANK YOU. WE
HAVE PUBLIC COMMENT FROM LINE
NINETY SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
CALIFORNIA CHILDREN'S ACADEMY
WE ARE DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION
FUNDED INSTANT FATHER INCREASE
CALL CENTER BASED CONTRACTOR IN
LOS ANGELES COUNTY FOR THE
RECORD WE TOO ARE PART OF THE
EDUCATIONAL CONTINUA. AND IN
ORDER TO HELP THE- AND PROGRAMS
LIKE OURS PROVIDE THE PANDEMIC
AND THIS YEAR NEXT YEAR WE ASK
FOR THE HOLD HARMLESS. THE YEAR
TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO WE ARE
ALSO ASKING FOR FUNDING
FLEXIBILITY BETWEEN THE C-SPAN.
CARE CONTRACT ONE THIRTY THE
FUTURE CONTRACTS ARE MOVED TO
THE S. THAT. WE ALSO AND
FINALLY AFTER THE PARENTS OF
CHOICE TO ALLOW THE FOUR YEAR
OLD SHOULD REMAIN IN THE FTP.
I'M TRULY PROVIDE THE
FLEXIBILITY AND CONTINUITY OF
CARE FOR THE CHILDREN OF
CALIFORNIA THANK YOU SO MUCH.
THANK YOU AND WE- THANK YOU WE
HAVE PUBLIC COMMENT FROM LYING
NINETY SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD. YES
HI MY NAME IS SUSAN GILMORE AND
I'M THE FOUNDER AND CEO THE
NORTH BAY CHILDREN'S CENTER
WHICH IS A NONPROFIT
ORGANIZATION SERVING MORE THAN
SIX HUNDRED CHILDREN AT SIXTEEN
LOCATIONS IN MARIN AND SONOMA
COUNTY. IN TWO THOUSAND
SEVENTEEN WE LAUNCHED A CAPITAL
CAMPAIGN TO EXPAND OUR CHILD
CARE CAPACITY AND WE PLACE OUR
BADLY DETERIORATING FACILITIES
ON OUR MAIN CAMPUS. PRIOR TO
THE PANDEMIC WE RAISE 60% OF
THE SEVEN POINT FIVE MILLION
NEEDED TO COMPLETE THE SHOVEL
READY PROJECT. THE NEED FOR
FACILITY EXPANSION PROJECTS
LIKE OURS HAS NEVER BEEN
GREATER AND RAISING MONEY FROM
THE PRIVATE SECTOR DURING THESE
UNPRECEDENTED TIMES HAS NEVER
BEEN MORE DIFFICULT. I'M URGING
YOU TO PRIORITIZE INVESTMENTS
IN EARLY LEARNING FACILITIES
AND HELP REBUILD OUR STATE IS
BADLY NEEDED CHILD CARE
CAPACITY BY RESTORING FUNDING
FOR THE CHILD CARE
INFRASTRUCTURE INFRASTRUCTURE
GRANT PROGRAM. IT'S ALSO
CRITICAL THAT YOU CONTINUE TO
HOLD HARMLESS FOR TWENTY ONE
TWENTY TWO AND IS SUPPORT RATE
REFORM FOR EASY AND FUNDING
FLEXIBILITY ALLOWING FOR THIS
SEAMLESS TRANSFER TO TWENTY
THREE T. R. AND C. S. P. P. AND
OF COURSE PARENTAL CHOICE. FOR
FOUR YEAR OLDS THANK YOU. THEY
YOU AND WE HAVE PUBLIC COMMENT
FROM LINE OUT ONE HUNDRED AND
THIRTEEN NINE ONE ONE AND THREE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI THERE CAN
YOU HEAR ME. YEP GO AHEAD THANK
YOU. RIGHT GOOD EVENING
EVERYONE MY NAME IS ALI I'M OF
THE TALLY AND I'M EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF THE B. FIFTY ROUND
TABLE ON BEHALF OF THE THIRTY
TWO THOUSAND BC F. P.
INSTITUTIONS UNSIGHTLY CRACKED
THE STATE. I WANT TO THANK YOU
FOR THE CONVERSATION TODAY I'M
GOING TO KEEP IT SHORT IT'S
LATE IN THE EVENING PLEASE
FULLY FUND CHILD CARE INCLUDING
THE NEED FOR INVESTMENT IN
CHILD CARE NUTRITION.
PARTICULARLY IN THE WAKE OF THE
PANDEMIC. WITH INCREASED HUNGER
IN OUR COMMUNITY. WE TAKE CARE
OF TRIAL CARE PER. WHO ARE
TAKING. VERY GREAT CARE OF OUR
CHILDREN THANK YOU FOR OUR TIME
THANK YOU. HEY WE HAVE PUBLIC
COMMENT FROM LINE SIXTY FIVE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
MY NAME IS ATTACHED TO IT AND
I'M THE COMMISSIONER OF THE
HOUSING AUTHORITY OF SAN
JOAQUIN COUNTY I'M ALSO A
DIRECTOR OF FAMILY. FOR THIRTY
FIRST ST OF STOCKTON. IT TO BE
REPORTED WHO SUPPORT INCOME
PEOPLE SAN JOAQUIN COUNTY FOR
THE POOR HOUSING. CHILD CARE
ASSISTANCE FOR CHILD NUTRITION.
FOR BAND NUMBER PAC THE BILL OF
RESOURCES DO COMMUNITIES WAS
GREAT. THE PANDEMIC THE NEW
DOUBLE. I WOULD LIKE TO EXPRESS
MY SUPPORT ISSUE FOR. THE CHILD
CARE NUTRITION PROPOSED. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. THANKS SPEAKER
PLEASE. YES THANK YOU- WE GO
NEXT THAT PUBLIC COMMENT LINE
ONE HUNDRED AND TWENTY ONE
PLEASE GO AHEAD LINE ONE TWO
ONE. CAN THE SUPERINTENDENT OF
SCHOOLS WILL MAKE OUR COMMENTS
FREE. ONE EIGHT ZERO- LOOK TO
GET STABILIZE AND GROW THE
EARLY EDUCATION. ACTOR WE HAVE
THE LEGISLATURE TO CONSIDER THE
FOLLOWING EXTENDING FLEXIBILITY
FOR PROVIDERS THAT WERE GRANTED
DURING THE PANDEMIC SUCH AS
WAITING FAMILY SHE ACCEPTS AND
ACCEPTING ELECTRONIC SIGNATURES
TO NAME A FEW. ALSO TO PROVIDE
A HOLD HARMLESS PROVISION FOR
TWENTY TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO
AND LASTLY TO ESTABLISH A
SINGLE REIMBURSEMENT RATE
SYSTEM THAT INCLUDES ORIGINAL
COST AND QUALITY OBJECTS AND
FACTORS THANK YOU. THANK YOU
THANK YOU AND IF I COULD JUST
HAVE- NINE ONE TWENTY ONE JUST
REPEAT YOUR NAME AND
ASSOCIATION I THINK YOU. YEAH
GARCIA ON BEHALF OF THE
RIVERSIDE COUNTY SUPERINTENDENT
OF SCHOOLS. THANK YOU I NEXT WE
HAVE PUBLIC COMMENT FROM MY
NUMBER ONE HUNDRED AND FOURTEEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD LINE AT ONE ONE
FOUR. HELLO MY NAME IS A DOLLY
KING I'M CALLING FROM WITH THE-
THE ADVANCEMENT PROJECT
CALIFORNIA- AND ALSO ON THE- ON
BEHALF OF THE HOTEL PARTNERSHIP
AND ALSO IN SUPPORT OF THE IF
YOU COALITION ASK- PHYSICALLY I
WOULD LIKE TO HIGHLIGHT THE-
WHOLE CHILD EQUITY PROPOSAL.
WHICH FOCUSES ON AN EQUITY NEED
INDEX OF THE CREATION. OF A
TASK FORCE TO DEVELOP THE- NEXT
FORMULA AND WHICH- COULD BE
USED ALLOCATE FUNDS- ALSO
ADVOCATING. FOR THE HOTEL WELL
THIS HUGS. AND AND ALSO.
FUNDING TO PROVIDE FOR
ENTERPRISE TRADING- THANK YOU
AND WE APPRECIATE THE WORK OF
THE LEGISLATIVE LEADERS SHIP
THANK YOU SO MUCH. THANK YOU
AND THAT WE HAVE A PUBLIC
COMMENT LINE ONE HUNDRED AND
TWENTY FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI
MY NAME IS HEATHER POSTMARK I'M
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF LITTLE
RESIDENTS PRESCHOOL IN
CROCKETT. WE ARE THE ONLY
LICENSED CHILD CARE PROGRAM IN
OUR COMMUNITY WE TYPICALLY
SERVE FIFTEEN CHILDREN BUT OUR
CAPACITY HAS BEEN REDUCED DUE
TO THE PANDEMIC AND WE WOULD
LIKE TO BETTER SERVE THE NEEDS
OF OUR COMMUNITY BY INCREASING
OUR ENROLLMENT. AND OFFERING
INCENSE THROUGH PRE K.
EDUCATION AND CARE HOWEVER OUR
REVENUE WILL BARELY COVER OUR
EXPENSES AND AS A NON PROFIT
THERE'S NO OTHER WAY FOR US TO
EXPAND WITHOUT THE SUPPORT OF
GRANTS LIKE THE CHILD CARE
INFRASTRUCTURE GRANT. WE'RE
ASKING FOR THAT THREE HUNDRED
AND FIFTY MILLION DOLLARS TO BE
RESTORED MOST GRANTED DON'T
COVER HOSPITAL AND WITHOUT
GRANTS LIKE THAT FROM THE STATE
WE WON'T BE ABLE TO EXPAND AND
HELP REPLACE THE MOTHER CHILD
CARE SLOTS. HAVE BEEN LOST DUE.
TO THE PAIN THAT MAKE. THANK
YOU. YEAH WE HAVE PUBLIC
COMMENT LINE ONE HUNDRED TWENTY
FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD. ONE ONE
HUNDRED TWENTY FIVE THAT MUST
BE ME. MY NAME IS ANDREA
HEDSTROM AND I AM THE WIFE OF
AN EARLY CHILDHOOD CREDENTIAL
IN PUBLIC SCHOOL KINDERGARTEN
TEACHER I AM ALSO THE MOTHER OF
FOUR CHILDREN. I AM THE
DAUGHTER OF. A NOW DECEASED
THIRTY PLUS YEAR EARLY
CHILDHOOD TEACHER AND- ELL
TEACHER SHE WAS SELF. AND I'M
JUST CALLING BECAUSE IT'S ONE
OF THOSE THINGS THAT I DO
LATELY AS I TRY TO UNDERSTAND
THE INS AND OUTS OF. THE
DECREPIT FAILING CALIFORNIA
GOVERNMENT. AND THIS HEARING
HAS BEEN NO EXCEPTION IN THE
SPIRIT OF MY MOTHER MY DEARLY
DEPARTED EARLY CHILDHOOD
TEACHER MOTHER AND MY EARLY
CHILDHOOD TEACHER HUSBAND I
JUST FEEL COMPELLED TO SAY THAT
I AM REALLY SAD LISTENING TO
THE WASTE AND THE INCOMPETENCE.
IN THIS HEARING- AND IT ISN'T
UNIQUE TO EARLY CHILDHOOD IT
ISN'T UNIQUE TO EDUCATION I CAN
NOW OFFICIALLY ADDED. EARLY
CHILDHOOD TO THE WEST OF THE%
DECREPIT INSTITUTIONS THE
DECAYING INSTITUTIONS FROM THE
EDT TO THE CPUC TO- BUT DMV ALL
OF THE THINGS THAT ARE
LEGISLATURE IS FAILING TO
MANAGE HERE IN CALIFORNIA AS
FAMILIES BELIEVE. THEY FINALLY
THANK YOU EXCELLENT YOU'RE
PLENTY WHERE BUT HERE HEXAMETER.
NO WONDER WHEN I HEAR. THANK
YOU OUR NEXT PUBLIC COMMENT
LINE ONE HUNDRED AND TWENTY SIX
PLEASE GO AHEAD THE LINE IS
OPEN. AM I WON TWENTY SIX. YES
PLEASE GO AHEAD GREAT THANK YOU
HI MY NAME IS SAMMY WATKINS I'M
THE EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF EARLY
DEVELOPMENT SERVICES WHICH IS
THE LARGEST CENTER BASED
PROVIDER IN MONTEREY COUNTY AND
WE HAVE BEEN OPEN SINCE THE
PANDEMIC STARTED WE HAVE
CONTINUED TO SERVE FAMILIES IN
PERSON SERVICES THE ENTIRE TIME
DESPITE OUR ELEAZAR CLOSING
MANY OF THEM STILL BEING CLOSED
SO THE LITTLE TROUBLE FROM THIS
YEAR ABOUT THE TRANSITIONAL
KINDERGARTEN PUSH. TO THE L. A.
SYSTEM AND TAKING WITHOUT
PARENTAL CHOICE FOR PARENTS A
T. K. SYSTEM IS A HALF DAY
PROGRAM PART YEAR WE HAVE
WORKING FAMILIES THEY NEED
THEIR FOUR YEAR OLD HAD CARE AS
WELL AS AN EDUCATION SO IT'S
IMPERATIVE. THAT THAT CHOICE IS
STILL BEARS. WELL TO CARE
OPTIONAL YOU'RE TAKING WHETHER
OPTION TO HAVE STATE PRESCHOOL.
AND SO THEN YOU'RE NOT MAKING
IT AN OPTION FOR THEM AND IT'S
GONNA BECOME MORE OF A CONCERN
WHEN MANY OF OUR ELEAZAR DON'T
EVEN HAVE THE SPACE TO THE CITY
KAY CHILDREN. AND YET THE
PARENTS DON'T HAVE A CHOICE OF
CONTINUED KERR IN A PROVIDER
THEY MAY HAVE BEEN WITH THE
SEXUAL TO MORE INTENSE.
ADDITIONALLY AS DETAILS DETAILS
ON THAT IS THE NEED FOR THE
HOLD HARMLESS CLAUSE THE REASON
BEING IS THAT THIS T. K.
CONTINUES THE
REQUIREMENTS. THESE CHILDREN
WILL BE MOVING AND WE WILL HAVE
TO REPLACE A HUNDRED AND FIFTY
CHILDREN WE CANNOT DO THAT JULY
FIRST START JULY ONE. IF YOU
DON'T AND THAT OUR CAPACITY
CHANGE. THANK YOU AND WE HAVE
PUBLIC COMMENT FROM LINE NUMBER
ONE HUNDRED AND THIRTY THREE. I
ONE MOMENT PLEASE A LINE ONE
THREE THREE THE LINE IS OPEN.
GOOD EVENING MY NAME IS TONY
THURMOND I'M CALLING FROM SANTA
BARBARA COUNTY I'M CALLING TO
EXPRESS MY SUPPORT FOR
INVESTMENT INTO THE EARLY CARE
AND EDUCATION FIELD AS WITH
OUTLINED IN STATE HEARING. I
SUPPORT AND ENCOURAGE YOU TO
EXTEND THE HOLD HARMLESS FOR
THE TWO THOUSAND TWENTY ONE
THOUSAND TWENTY TWO YEAR. TO
PROVIDE GREAT REFORM TO REGION
REGIONALIZED THE STATE
REIMBURSEMENT RATE ENSURE
EQUITABLE REIMBURSEMENTS AT A
MINIMUM IN ALIGNMENT WITH THE
TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN MARKET
SURVEY. AND ALSO TO WAY FAMILY
FEATURE OCTOBER TWO THOUSAND
AND TWENTY TWO FOR ALL FAMILIES
WITHOUT IMPACTING TO TALK HER
SPOT. THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME
AND TAKE CARE. WE HAVE PUBLIC
COMMENT LINE NUMBER ONE HUNDRED
THIRTY FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI
GOOD AFTERNOON TURN MEMBERS
THAT THAT THEY'RE SELLING OF
OUR ON BEHALF OF THE CHILDREN'S
PARTNERSHIP I'M CALLING ON
ISSUE ONE INTO. THE MASTER PLAN
GOLDEN RECOMMENDATIONS TRENCHER
EVERY YOUNG CHILD WITH THE
COMPREHENSIVE QUALITY EARLY
LEARNING AND CHILD CARE
SERVICES A GLOBAL PANDEMIC AND
RESULTING IN SOCIAL ISOLATION
FAMILY INSTABILITY FOR FAMILIES
HAVE HAVE EXACERBATED GROWING
EARLY CHILDHOOD MENTAL HEALTH
CRISIS. BEFORE THE PANDEMIC WE
KNOW THAT ONE THIRD OF CHILDREN
EXPERIENCE AT LEAST ONE ADVERSE
CHILDHOOD EXPERIENCES BEFORE
THE AGE OF FIVE THE GLOBAL
PANDEMIC AND THE RESULTING
FAMILY AND ECONOMIC STRESSORS
AND THE DISPROPORTIONATE IMPACT
ON COMMUNITIES OF COLOR IS AND-
I'M CLIP UNEQUIVOCALLY AN
ADVERSE CHILDHOOD EXPERIENCE
FOR YOUNG THE CALIFORNIANS.
ATTACH WITH THE POOR INVESTMENT
LIKE THE WHOLE CHAO EQUITY
PROPOSALS THAT PROMOTE
COGNITIVE SOCIAL EMOTIONAL
DEVELOPMENT AND POSITIVE
RELATIONSHIP CARING ADULTS FOR
OUR YOUNG A CALIFORNIANS. AND
WE LOOK FORWARD. TO WORKING
WITH YOU THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TIME. THANK YOU AND WE HAVE
PUBLIC COMMENT FROM LINE ONE
THIRTY THAT FLYING ONE THREE
ZERO PLEASE GO AHEAD. TWENTY
ONE THIRTY WE HAVE THE LINE
OPEN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK. OKAY
NINE ONE THIRTY EIGHT- IF YOU'D
LIKE TO SPEAK PLEASE GO AHEAD.
OKAY WE'RE NOT GETTING A
RESPONSE NINE ONE THIRTY I WILL
MOVE ON TO LINE PUBLIC COMMENT
LINE ONE FORTY TWO THE LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI THERE
CAN YOU HEAR ME. YEAH HELLO YES
PLEASE GO AHEAD OF THANK YOU
THANK YOU- QUITTING ARSIA ON
BEHALF OF THE RIVERSIDE COUNTY
SUPERINTENDENT OF SCHOOLS ARE
WE JUST WANT TO ASK THE STATE
IF YOU LOOK AT TO STABILIZE AND
GROW THE EARLY CHILDHOOD
EDUCATION SECTOR WE ASK THAT
YOU CONSIDER THE FOLLOWING
EXTENDING FLEXIBILITY FOR
PROVIDERS THAT WERE GRANTED
DURING THE PANDEMIC SUCH AS
BLEEDING FAMILY SPEAKS AND
ACCEPTING ELECTRONIC SIGNATURES
TO NAME A FEW. AND YOU PROVIDE
A HOLD HARMLESS PROVISION FOR
TWENTY TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO
AND THE TABLETS A SINGLE
REIMBURSEMENT RATE SYSTEM THAT
INCLUDES REGIONAL COST AND
QUALITY. ADJUSTMENT FACTORS
THANK YOU. AND WE HAVE PUBLIC
COMMENT LINE ONE HUNDRED FORTY
THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY
NAME IS. AND I HAVE TWO
CHILDREN AND WHICH ONE IS- ONE
WITH SPECIAL NEEDS- CHILD CARE
IS IN A BIG ABSOLUTELY
NECESSARY FOR MY FAMILY TO EVEN
SURVIVE. AND I'D LIKE TO
BASICALLY ADDRESS A COUPLE OF
THINGS THAT I THINK WOULD HELP
MY FAMILY AS WELL AS AND THEIR
FAMILIES SH AND ONE IS WAIVING
THE FEE FOR ALL FAMILIES AS A
MOM WHO STRUGGLES ON FIXED
INCOME AND CAL WORKS. EVEN WITH
SUBSIDY AND THE SCHOLARSHIP I
STILL HAD TO PAY A FAMILY FEE
FROM MY SON TOP QUALITY EARLY
EDUCATION. AND IT DID NOT HELP
MY FAMILY HAVE ECONOMIC
STABILITY IN FACT IT FURTHERED
INTO POVERTY IT FURTHERED ME
INTO DEBT AND THE TUITION FOR
CHILD CARE WAS SO HIGH THAT. IT
WAS JUST UNBELIEVABLE WHAT I
WENT THROUGH A PANE FAMILY FEES
AND I REALLY REALLY. FEEL THAT
IN ORDER TO SUPPORT. EMILY
ATKIN IN THE WE NEED TO WAIT
BEFORE PLEASE I'D ALSO LIKE TO
SAY THAT WE HAVE OVER TWO
MILLION CHILDREN IN CALIFORNIA
WAITING FOR CHILD CARE. AND
THIS IS RIDICULOUS THIS IS NOT
ACCEPTABLE I REALLY DO BELIEVE
THAT WE SHOULD EXPAND THESE
EMERGENCY VOUCHERS TO HELP-
SPECIALLY ARE PARENTS WHO ARE
ON THE FRONT LINE IS ESSENTIAL
WORKERS THIS IS. SOMETHING THAT
CAN HELP- PEOPLE LIKE WHO ARE
MY HEALTHCARE STAFF WHERE I GO
TO UCSF AND ONE OF THE LADIES
WHO WORK THERE. IS A MOM OF THE
PARENTS WHO STRUGGLED AND
WORKED AT UCSF AS ASCENTIAL
WORKER AND SHE SAID WITHOUT
CHILD CARE THERE IS NO WORK AND
I WAS LIKE I REALLY WANT TO
ECHO THAT TODAY. WITHOUT CHILD
CARE THERE IS NO WORK SO WE
REALLY REALLY NEED TO MAKE SURE
THAT WE'RE INVESTING IN THE
CHILD CARE AND HELPING
FAMILIES. TO HAVE ECONOMIC
STABILITY AND HELPING OUR
CHILDREN TO HAVE ALL THE
SUPPORT THAT THEY NEED. THOSE
EARLY LEARNING FOUNDATION IS SO
IMPERATIVE FOR THEM AND I ALSO
WANTED TO SAY THAT AS A FORMER
PROVIDER MYSELF I STRUGGLED
WITH TRYING TO MAKE ENDS MEET
THAT I ENDED UP BECOMING
HOMELESS. SO WE ALSO NEED TO
SUPPORT OUR CHILD CARE
PROVIDERS- BECAUSE THEY ARE
ALSO IN STRUGGLE TO TRYING TO
HAVE ECONOMIC STABILITY SO I'D
REALLY LIKE TO DEATH REALLY
TOUCH ON BOTH THREE. POINTS TO
MAKE SURE THAT YOU KNOW WE ARE
INVESTING IN THE RIGHT WAY IN
THE CHILD CARE AND THAT OUR
CHILDREN ARE INVESTMENT AND
ONCE AGAIN I JUST WANT TO SAY
WITHOUT CHILD CARE THERE IS NO
WORK THANK YOU. THANK YOU JUNE
BAG I YOUR YOUR LAST SPEAKER SO
WE GAVE YOU- DOUBLE THE TIME
AND I ALWAYS APPRECIATE YOUR-
PARTICIPATION IN THE-
SUBCOMMITTEES THIS IS. LIKE I
SAID EARLIER THIS IS- ONE THE
MOST IMPORTANT HEARINGS WE HAVE
EVERY YEAR THAT YOU SEE DAY.
OUR YOUNGEST LEARNERS- MATTER
AND YOU SEE MATTERS AND- THEY
SHOULD BE OUR NUMBER ONE TWO
AND THREE PRIORITY THEY FOCUS
ON THE STATE BUDGET EVERY YEAR
SO- WITH THAT TOO THIS THAT
CONCLUDES. OUR PUBLIC COMMENT
AND YOU CAN ARRESTERS. THAT THE
IS THAT- WILL BE BACK A FEW MY
WITH THE PLAN FOR OUR STATE
BUDGET FOR TWENTY TWENTY ONE.
THAT HAS- SIGNIFICANT
INVESTMENTS IN EARLY EDUCATION.
AND WITH THAT- WE ARE ADJOURNED
THANK YOU.